GOOD
AFTERNOON. THIS WILL BEGIN
TODAY'S SOMEONE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR- HEARING TODAY I DO
FEEL. BOTH TO READ SINCE WE
HAVE NO PUBLIC HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH TWO I WILL SKIP THAT
PART BUT ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
TODAY ARE APPEARING REMOTELY
AND USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY.
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE IN THE
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY BUT WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WATCHING YOU MAKE CALLS
REPUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER WHICH
IS. 1-877-692-8957 AGAIN IT'S.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ONE
TWO. ALL PUBLIC COMMENTERS I
MENTIONED WILL BE TAKEN AFTER
WE HAVE FINISHED THE ENGINE
AND- INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES. WHICH ARE
ISSUES SIXTEEN SIX THROUGH
SEVENTEEN. AT THIS TIME I'D
LIKE TO START IF I CAN WITH A
FEW OPENING REMARKS REALLY
THEIR OPENING QUESTIONS TO HELP
US TO FRAME TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
AND THEY WILL BE WHO WHAT WHY
WHERE AND WHEN. WHO ARE WE AS
THE STATE IF WE DO NOT TAKE
CARE OF THE POOR THE IMMIGRANT
AND THE DISABLED. BECAUSE IT IS
BEYOND ME THAT CURRENTLY THE
DISABLED ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
TIER ONE B. WHAT DOES THE DATA
CURRENTLY SAY ABOUT OUR MOST
PRECIOUS. PRECIOUS RESOURCE THE
COVERT NINETEEN TAXI. ARE THEY
GOING CURRENTLY TO THE POOR AND
HARD TO REACH OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR OR ARE THEY GOING TO
THE WEALTHY AND THE PRIVILEGED.
WHY DID THE ADMINISTRATION
PIVOT FROM THE INITIAL VACCINE
ADMINISTRATOR TO THIS THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. WAS IT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LACK OF
DATA AND TRANSPARENCY AND THUS
NO REAL ACCOUNTABILITY. WHERE
IS THE ADMINISTRATION PIVOTING
TO AND CAN WE AS THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE SUGGESTIONS.
AS IN INCREASING THE VACCINE
SUPPLIED TO THE POOR SINCE IT
SEEMS THAT WE ARE FLYING BLIND.
WHEN CAN WE FINALLY ACHIEVE
HEALTH JUSTICE BECAUSE FOR TOO
MANY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IT IS
TAKING TOO LONG. MARTIN LUTHER
KING ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AGO
SAID THAT OF ALL OF THE
INEQUALITIES AND JUSTICE AND
HEALTH CARE IS THE MOST
SHOCKING AND INHUMANE. HAVING
PRACTICE IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT THROUGH PANDEMIC
SITE. IT IS WITH JUSTICE THAT I
STAND HERE AS A CHAIRED TODAY
ADVOCATING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HEAR ALL COMMUNITIES. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE REPRESENTED.
IT IS WITH GRATITUDE AND
THANKFULNESS AND APPRECIATION
AS WELL. GRATITUDE THAT WE ARE
HERE IN THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE DO VALUE
OUR IMMIGRANTS ARE POOR AND ARE
DISABLED. THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE
AN EYE TOWARDS EQUITY AND THAT
WE ARE MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
AND WITH AN APPRECIATION FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT HAS
OCCURRED FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TO OUR NURSES TO OUR
DOCTORS TO EVERYONE. WHO'S
HELPING DURING THIS PANDEMIC
THIS HAS BEEN STRESSFUL THIS
HAS BEEN HARD BUT MY TONE HERE
TODAY WITH QUESTIONS IS TO MAKE
US. MOVE TOWARDS EQUITY. BUT
IT'S WITH HOPE. THAT I MOST TO
SIT HERE TODAY. BECAUSE DURING
THE PREVIOUS PANDA WHEN I WAS
ON THE FRONT LINES OF HEALTH
CARE TAKING CARE OF ONE PATIENT
AT A TIME. I OFTENTIMES
COULDN'T WORK ON THE SYSTEMS
THAT NEED TO BE IMPROVED DURING
PANDEMICS. BUT IT IS HOPE
SITTING HERE IN THIS CHAIR THAT
TOGETHER WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT CHANGE THAT WE ALL
SEEK. AND SO IT IS IN THAT
THEME THAT I BEGIN TODAY SUB
ONE HEARING. AND WITH THAT WE
WILL BEGIN WITH PANEL ONE. OUR
FIRST PANEL TODAY. WILL HAVE TO
PRESENTERS DR DUNCAN AND LOUIS
BRONCHI. AND IF I CAN I WILL
HOLD ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS
UNTIL AFTER THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEMBER R ARAMBULA AND- I'M
GONNA SAY WELL SAID I REALLY
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS. I'M
DOCTOR DAVE DUNCAN I'M AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF TE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY. I
DO HAVE TO ADDITIONAL CHIEF
THAT ARE GOING TO A LINE SOME
COMMENTS FOR TODAY AND MY
APOLOGIES THAT THEY AREN'T ON
YOUR YOUR AGENDA TO SPEAK ONE
IS. ACROSS ALL OUR CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES THE
SECOND IS GREG JOHNSON OUR
CHIEF OF DISASTER MANAGEMENT
SERVICES- WITHOUT I'M I'D LIKE
TO GET STARTED ON ISSUE ONE IF
I MAY. PLEASE BEGIN. ISSUE ONE
INCLUDES A THREE ITEMS FOR HER
COMMENTS THE FIRST OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
MS- THE SECOND ANSWER IS ROLE
AND RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE
PANDEMIC AND THE THIRD A. B. C.
T. THAT DIRECTLY RELATES TO THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THAT
NUMBER THREE IS GOING TO CENTER
AROUND OUR BCP FOR. ALREADY MHS
IS. WHICH WILL BE COMING PRICE
NOW WANT TO START. WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
PERHAPS A THAT'S GOING TO BE
COVERED BY RICK RUSSELL ARE
CHIEF OF ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU CORRECT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND- I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HAVING
VIDEO. PRESENTATION THANK YOU
FOR. I HI THIS IS RICHA ALSO
WITH MERCY MEDICAL SIR
AUTHORITY AND I AM THE CHIEF
MINISTER. BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
FOR BY FOR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO REALLY IN JAN. INCLUDES
EXPANDED THOUGHT IN THEM OF
SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION AND
SEVENTY FOUR POINT EIGHT
PERMANENT POSITIONS. OF THIS
AMOUNT SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION OR FORTY SEVEN POINT 3%
IS DELEGATED FOR STATE
OPERATIONS IN NINETEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION OR FIFTY TWO
POINT 7% IS DELEGATED FOR LOCAL
SYSTEMS. STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING SEVENTY POINTS MILLION
IS BROKEN DOWN INTO 33% FROM
THE GENERAL FUND 42% FROM
REIMBURSEMENTS 13% FEDERAL
FUNDING. AND 12% FROM SPECIAL
FUNDS. OF PARTICULAR NOTE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
IS THE SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
GENERAL FUND BETWEEN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN
THE PRIOR TWO YEARS. OF THE
HIGHER GENERAL FUND AMOUNTS IN
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
REFLECT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
MS I HAS RECEIVED EITHER
THROUGH SB EIGHTY NINE FINES OR
THE DISASTER RECOVERY EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT. IN WHICH
WERE SPECIFICALLY DELEGATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT FOR OUR
CONTINUED BECAUSE THE. NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESPONSE ACTIVITIES.
HELLO THE RE FINDING ASSISTANCE
IS A AT NINETEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION AND BROKEN DOWN 257%
FROM REIMBURSEMENTS 37% GENERAL
FUND. 4% FEDERAL FUNDING INTO
PERCENT FROM SPECIAL FUNDS. TO
THE DEPARTMENT HAS THREE BUDGET
PROPOSALS UNDER CONSIDERATION
AND AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. NO ONE IS THE
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY NATIONAL AFFAIRS
LEGAL OFFICE INCREASED WORKLOAD
THE SECOND IS THE COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE OR TRIAGE
ALTERNATE DESTINATION AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEN THE
THIRD IS THE REGIONALS
ASTRONOMICAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS. THE FIRST TWO ARE
ON NON A NON DISCUSSION ITEMS
FOR THE AGENDA AND THE THIRD
ONE IS THE REGIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL HEALTH SPECIALIST IN
OUR CHIEF OF- DISASTER MEDICAL
SERVICES CRAIG JOHNSON RUN AN
OVERVIEW OF THAT PROPOSAL. SO
THIS IS CRAIG JOHNSON CHIEF OF
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES
DIVISION. AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
DO WE WANT TO GO OVER THE RDMA
CHEST BUDGET NOW OR SHOULD WE
START WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE
MS ACTIVITIES RESPONSIBLE. I
WOULD STAY ON ISSUE ONE THE
OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET. OKAY SO
THE R. MAJOR. THAT IS. ONCO
THROUGH SIXTY FIVE LOW ASSIST
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
IMPROVE REGIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL AND HEALTH PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE RECOVERY AND
MITIGATION BY FUNDING THREE
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL HELP SPECIALIST. TO
SERVE AS CHAIR RESOURCES WITHIN
THE SIX COUNT- WE ASK MUTUAL
AID REGION'S. THAT'S A QUICK
SUMMARY THAT PIECE. THANK YOU.
I WOULD THAT WOULD BRING ABOUT
TO THE FOR ANY QUESTION THAT WE
MAY HAVE ON AND SOME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ON THE. THANK YOU MISS
CHAIR- CRUSH ARE ON THE FUND
ASPECT IT BUT ALL WITH- THE
FOUR PER OF PHONE FUNDING THAT
THAT'S ALLOCATED- THAT'S THERE
IS THERE OUTRAGE TO THE LOCAL-
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE PART OF THE WHOLE
PROCESS WE START TO LOOK AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE VACCINE
SEEM THAT THAT MONEY IS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
ITSELF. THAT MADE A QUESTION ME
DOCTOR DUNCAN- I'M SAID DOES
NOT A DIRECT TIE INTO THE- THIS
MAKING BUDGET ADMINS- I WOULD
WANT TO LEVY AND HE OF
VACCINATION RELATED. TO OUR-
PUBLIC HEALTH AT CDP YOUR OKAY.
BOB BUT BUT LET ME. THE REAR IS
THERE A ORDER THIS QUESTION I
BE ABLE TO TAKE ON. ON THE
FUNDING GETTING DOWN TO LOCAL
THROUGH ICE. ARE THE LOCAL. IS
THAT FINE ALSO- THERE IS FOR AS-
REACHING OUT TO. THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MAKING SURE THAT IS
GETTING THERE. AND ALSO- WITH
THE NATIVE. POP THROUGHOUT THIS.
I'M NOT SURE I HAVE COMECLARITY I'M IN A- MINUTE TO
THAT QUESTION. IN ON THE TAKE
PART OF YOUR BACK IN AND COME
BACK YOU WITH A ANSWER WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS. THE FUNDING THAT
NOW STUFF RECEIVES IT IS. JUST
A THIS MEDICAL. IN THIS. AREA
WHICH REALLY. THE UNDER. CLUB.
IMMINENTLY WHEN WE- BRING
FORWARD THIS OUT MEDICAL
RESPONSE SPECIFIC TALK ULTRA
CARE SO. OF MANY OF THE
LOCATION WERE TO ARE UNDER SAID
AS IN CAL BUT- BUT THE FUNDS WE
RECEIVED THAT SPECIFIC RESPONSE
ARE NOT TIED TO A PARTICULAR
LOCATION RATHER THEY'RE TIED TO
OUR ABILITY TO DELIVER- THAT
MEDICAL CARE WHERE IT IS DEEMED
MOST APPROPRIATE. AND THE
VACCINE PIECE. WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPATION IN DECISION
MAKING ON ON THE OUTSIDE. THANK
YOU AND THROUGH THE CHAIR WE
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH A SEPARATE
MEETING ON THAT AND
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE EMSA
COMPONENT DOWN TO THE ICE FROM
A COMPONENT TO THE LOCAL-
COUNTIES AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE- IS GETTING- THE VOICE
AN ADVOCACY THAT'S NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL PEOPLE IN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVING OUR RESOURCES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. C. NON
I WILL THANK THIS PANEL AND
WE'LL MOVE ON THE PANEL TO ON
HARSH PAD AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO
ARE PRESENTING AND NOT JUST
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
PLEASE PRESENT IN THE ORDER IN
WHICH YOU APPEAR IN THE AGENDA
AS A PRESENTER FOR THIS NEXT
PANEL WE HAVE TWO PRESENTERS
ELIZABETH LANDSBERG AND KAREN
RESULT. WILL HOLD AGAIN ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL WE HAVE
CONCLUDED FROM THE PRESENTERS
PLEASE BEGIN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ELIZABETH LANDS BURKE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. I WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE OVERVIEW OF
OFFENSE OUR RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC AND OUR EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT A DIVERSE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. AND THAT OUR DEPUTY
OF OUR WORKFORCE DIVISION KAREN
RIGHT CELL WILL ADDRESS THE B.
C. P. AND THE COMMITTEES
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. OUR ANSWERS
HEALTH ACT TO SAFE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTS BY
FOCUSING ON THREE PRIMARY
AREAS. HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. HEALTH CARE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING AND
HEALTH CARE CONSTRUCTION AND
FINANCING. WE HAVE FIVE BCPS
THIS YEAR AND UNDERSTAND THIS
HEARING WILL FOCUS ALL ON ARE
CLOSELY RELATED WORK AND OUR
WORKFORCE INITIATIVES. I DO
WANT TO MENTION AS THE AGENDA
DOES THAT THE BUDGET PROPOSES
TO ADD A NEW OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. REFLECTING
AN EXPANDED MISSION THE BUDGET
WOULD RECAST AUSTIN INTO A
DEPARTMENT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE H. C. A. I. R.
H. CHI. THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY WILL IMPROVE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY PINE
CREEK INCREASING TRANSPARENCY
ON COST AND QUALITY AND
ADDRESSING THE UNDERLYING COST
DRIVERS IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM BUILDING ON OUR HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE. THE
ADMINISTRATION SUBMIT A
PROPOSAL IN THE SPRING WITH
MORE DETAIL ON THE RECASTING OF
US THAT INTO OUR INTUITIVE. AND
OUR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL BE RELEASED
SOON. I WANT TO THANK DR WHAT
AND HIS STAFF FOR BOTH THE
INTEREST IN AND CONVERSATIONS
ON THE OFFICE. NOW TURNING TO
OUR STREETS KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED ACTIVITIES. LIKE ALL
DEPARTMENTS IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY FAMILY
OPTION BUT IT'S BEEN
CONTINUING. HAS BEEN
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STATE'S
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND SAW JUST
GIVE A FEW EXAMPLES WE- HAVE
BEEN ASSISTING FEMA AND THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS AT OUR
STATE PARTNERS WITH THE DESIGN
AND APPROVAL OF ALTERNATE CARE
SITES AND SEARCH SPACE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS OUR
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN SO UNDER
SIEGE. WE'VE CREATED A COVERT
NINETEEN WEBSITE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL GUIDANCE AND OTHER
RESOURCES FOR HEALTH FACILITIES.
WE'VE ASSISTED WITH THEIR
CREATE OF FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
DASHBOARD. FOR THE- TO TRACK
VARIOUS MEASURES. REGARDING
HEALTH FACILITIES SEARCH SPACE
AND EQUIPMENT. WE SUCCESSFULLY
DISTRIBUTED A PRIVATE GRANT OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
STAFF WORKING IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THE SKILLED
NURSING HERO AWARDS WHEREBY
FIFTY THOUSAND LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WORKING IN SNAPS
EACH RECEIVED A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR HERO AWARD. LIKE MANY
OTHER AGENCIES WE HAVE STAFF
REASSIGNED TO CONTACT TRACING
AS WE GET ON TESTING EFFORTS.
OUR FIELD STAFF AND OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
HOSPITALS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
ON SEARCHSPACE VACCINE STORAGE
AND OXYGEN SUPPLIES WE HAVE
ALSO BEEN LICENSING THE USE OF
A VERY COLD OF FREEZERS
REQUIRED FOR THE FIZER VACCINE.
AND OUTSIDE OF HER USUAL SCOPE
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FACILITY
SAFETY GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOL RE
OPENING. AND OTHER ISSUES AS
REQUESTED. THE TERM OF OUR WERE
FORCE- WE'VE DURING THE PEN WE
CONTINUE TO TIMELY IMPLEMENT
OUR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS I KNOW
THERE IS INTEREST OF THE
COMMITTEE TO TALK MORE ABOUT
THIS- AND OUR EFFORTS TO
DIVERSIFY THE WORKFORCE. I
THINK WE'VE KNOWN FOR QUITE A
WHILE THAT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE NEEDED FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT TO MEET THE STATE'S
NEEDS. AND CERTAINLY COVER
NINETEEN HAS SHOWN AN EVEN
BRIGHTER LIGHT ON THE NEED FOR
AN EXPANDED AND MORE
REPRESENTATIVE WORKFORCE SO OUR
PROGRAMS ARE A LONG TERM
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE NEEDS. THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND IN PREVIOUS
YEARS TOWARDS WORK FORCE. AND
CONTINUES GENERAL FUND AND
OTHER INVESTMENTS TO BRING IN
PROVIDERS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES AND TO INCENTIVIZE
PROVIDERS TO WORK IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. SO THOSE
INVESTMENTS CONTINUE TO ALLOW
US TO PROVIDE DOES FOCUS ON
PROVIDING THE RIGHT PROVIDERS
IN THE RIGHT AREA. I WANTED TO
TALK HIGH LOW ABOUT- WORK
DIVERSE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
AND THEN AGAIN- MY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WILL TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS WELL ONE OF
THE THINGS I SPENT DOES IS TO
FIRST IDENTIFY MEDICALLY UNDER
SERVED AREAS. SO THAT WE KNOW
WHERE WORKFORCE IS MOST ACUTELY
NEEDED. WE CONCENTRATE OUR WORK
FORCE PROGRAMS IN THOSE AREAS.
WE KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO GROW UP
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY ARE
MORE LIKELY TO PRACTICE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHETHER THEIR
OWN OR ANOTHER UNDERSERVED AREA
SO WE TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WITH OUR WORDS. WE ALSO TRY TO
SUPPORT A RANGE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS- THE DATA IS
CLEAR THAT- NURSES NURSE
PRACTITIONERS BUSINESS
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE AND
ALLIED WORK FORCE PROFESSIONALS
TEND TO BE MORE DIVERSE THAN
ANDY'S MORE LIKELY TO SPEAK
ANOTHER LANGUAGE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT RESEARCH SHOWS BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS
WHOSE HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
REFLECT THEIR CULTURAL
BACKGROUNDS AND SPEAK THEIR
LANGUAGE AND SO WE DO WHAT WE
CAN WITHIN THE LIMITATIONS. OF
THE LAW TO SUPPORT APPLICANTS
WERE PROGRAMS THAT REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY. WELL WE
CANNOT TAKE RACE OR GENDER INTO
ACCOUNT EXPLICITLY IN MAKING
AWARDS WE CAN AND DO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
LANGUAGES SPOKEN. AND WE DO
INCLUDE A SERVICE COMMITMENT TO
SERVE IN ONE OF OUR IDENTIFIED
UNDERSERVED AREAS. SO WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
ATTENTION TO THE NEED FOR OUR
WORK FORCE TO LOOK LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND STAND READY TO
EXPAND OUR TOOLS TO ACHIEVE
THIS IMPORTANT CALL- SO REALLY
WERE VERY MUCH INTO LISTENING
MODE RIGHT NOW WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT OUR WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS. AND CHALLENGING
OURSELVES TO THINK CREATIVELY
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MODERNIZE OUR
PROGRAMS. TO BETTER SERVE THE
CALIFORNIA TODAY SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE FOCUS ON
THIS ISSUE AND THE PARTNERSHIP-
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR WE CAN PROCEED
WITH PRESENTING THE JERRY AFTER
GERIATRIC. WORKFORCE PCP.
PLEASE CONTINUE WITH THE OUT.
BCP PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. YES
I'M HEARINGS IN I'M THE DERBY
CARE ACT HEALTHCARE WE TO AT
AND OURAS MENTIONED ON ABOUT
YOUR CARE AND YOUR QUESTIONS.
THE BY INCLUDES A THREE ONE
TIME FUND FOR THE ARTS OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH ABOUT TO GROW
INTO. HI MY FOR THE JURY AT
MEDICINE WORK. REESING ENDEAVOR
MEMBERS OF DO LIVING REQUIRES
DEVELOPING A LARGE AND MORE
DIVERSE WILL HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
WITH EXTRA IN YOUR MEDICINE
HERE. WE GO TASK ON HOUSE
MEMBER DISEASE PREVENT AND
PREPAREDNESS IS A REPORT IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWO. INCOME
WITH MASTER ON A EUROPE. THE L.
HAMMERSTEIN PERSON WRECK THAT.
INVEST CAREER IS FOR THE ALSO.
OKAY WE'RE. RIGHT AWARDS TO
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS WHO
SERVE GERIATRIC POPULATION.
WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS WE CAN
MAKE AWARDS MORE EASILY AND
QUICKLY. OUR PROGRAMS ALREADY
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING PROVIDER
DIVERSITY. AND INCREASING
ACCESS TO CARE IN UNDERSERVED.
EXISTING PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM WHICH AWARDS TO
POSITIONS JEFF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PHYSICIANS'
ASSISTANTS. WITH A SPECIALTY IN
GERIATRICS AND GERONTOLOGY THIS
EVEN M. THOMPSON POSITION CORD
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM IN A
WORD PROVIDERS WHO AGREE TO
PRACTICE IN GERIATRIC CARE
SETTING. WE CAN ALSO YOU CAN
OTHER MONEY PAYMENT PROGRAMS
THAT FOCUS ON NURSING ALLIED
HEALTH AND LICENSE MENTAL
HEALTH TO WORK PROVIDERS THAT
SERVE OLDER ADULTS. WE HAVE THE
MINI GRANTS PROGRAM WHICH IS A
PIPELINE PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
ENERGIZE YOUTH AND STUDENTS TO
HEALTHCARE CAREERS. INCLUDING
GERIATRIC HEALTHCARE. THIS
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUEST
MULTI YEAR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY TO ALLOW SUFFICIENT
TIME TO ADMINISTER THE FUNDING.
IN WAS THERE ANY QUESTIONS I
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT SET OF
QUESTIONS. QUESTION ONE PLEASE
EXPLAIN THE SUBSTANTIAL
DECREASES IN BOTH GENERAL FUND
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
IN THE PROPOSED. BUDGET IN THE
GENERAL FUND THE NEXT HUNDRED
FIVE MILLION YEAR OVER YEAR
DECREASE BETWEEN CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET YEAR REFLECTS A DECREASE
OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION CARRYOVERS. FIFTY
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
THE HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM ND FIFTY THREE MILLION
FOR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. WHITE ANSETT BY ONE
TIME THREE MILLION HEALTH.
INCREASED TO SUPPORT THE
GERIATRIC CARE WORKFORCE. IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS CONNECT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION YEAR OVER YEAR DECREASE
BETWEEN CURRENT YEAR AND BUDGET
YEAR REFLECTS A DROP. OFF OF
THE FOLLOWING TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT ISSUES A PARTIAL
SHIFT OF FUNDING TO THE
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE PLAN FROM GENERAL
FUND TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON TWENTY MILLION-
CREATION OF THE BUDGET ACTIVE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I AM FORTY ONE
FORTY ONE ZERO ONE ZERO EIGHT
FIVE. TO CONTINUE THE SUPPORT
OF THE LACK TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN WHITE PLAINS.
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION.
QUESTION TWO PLEASE DESCRIBE
OUR SPENDS PROGRAMS THAT
PROMOTE DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. EVERY EVIDENCE OF
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS. THIS SONG BROWN
PROGRAM HAS SEVERAL KEY
STATUTORY OBJECTIVES INCLUDING
INCREASING RESIDENTS IN
TRAINING PROGRAM GRADUATES FROM
GROUPS TYPICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED IN PRIMARY
CARE. TRAINING RESIDENTS IN
THEIR SERVICE AREAS IN PLACING
GRADUATES IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN SONG
BROWN FUNDING HAS HELPED
SUPPORT EIGHTEEN YEAR PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM. IT IS
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
TWENTY THREE PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN SUPPORT
OF THE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO NEW
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY SLOTS.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY SONG
BROWN FUNDING SUPPORTED THE
OPENING OF THREE NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND EXPANDED- LEVIN
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. STRONG BROWN
SPENDING IS ALSO INCREASED
POSITION TO PERSON. PROXIMALLY
24% OF SONG BROWN FUNDED
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS HAVE
RESIDENTS THAT IN EITHER BLACK
OR LATINO- 211% OF THE OVERALL
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE. I SPREAD CURRENTLY
HAS THIRTEEN LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS THAT
ACTIVELY FOCUSED ON AWARDING
APPLICANTS WERE EXPERIENCE
LIVING OR WORKING WITH DIVERSE
POPULATIONS AND AGREED TO
PRACTICE IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
OUR SPEND ALSO HAS OTHER GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SEEK TO CREATE A DIVERSE
CULTURE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
WORKFORCE. ACTRESSES
UNDERSERVED AREA SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING OR RENT PROGRAM. I
SPENT COLLECTING REPORTS DATA
ON DEMOGRAPHICS FROM THE GRANT
PROGRAM. STAFF COMPARED THE
RACE AND ETHNICITY OF WHAT
AWARDEES AND THEIR LANGUAGES
SPOKEN TO THE CAP GENERAL
CALIFORNIA POPULATION. WENT
AWARDEES WERE REFLECTIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA POPULATION AND THE
PROGRAM WAS AFFECTING EFFECTIVE
IN WARDING INDIVIDUALS FROM
GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ONE
MEASURE OF SUCCESS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS IS WEATHER WARNINGS
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE IN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM OR
UNDERSERVED AREAS. AFTER THE
TERM OF SERVICE OBLIGATION IS
COMPLETE. ASHRITA SPEAKING THE
STATE OR THROUGH OUR RETENTION
SERVICE. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
SEVERAL SURVEYS TO MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF OUR LOAN REPAYMENT
AND STRIPE AND PROGRAMS. WE
ADMINISTER RETENTION SURVEY
PAST RECIPIENTS OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH LOAN REPAYMENT AND START
THE AWARDS. OF THOSE WHO ARE
GRADUATED AND COMPLETED THEIR
ONE YEAR SERVICE COMMITMENT 91%
STAKE IN THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. AT THE TIME OF
THE SURVEY AUTHORITIES HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM FOR AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT TWO YEARS
AFTER COMPLETING THEIR SERVICE.
NO WARRANTY IS THAT RECEIVED
BOTH A MENTAL HEALTH LOAN
ASSUMPTION. AND TYPE IN THE
WORD REACHED REPORTED THAT THE
WORDS WERE MORE IMPACTFUL. IN
TERMS OF GETTING EMPLOYMENT IN
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AND STAYING IN THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. WE ALSO
SURVEY PROGRAM AWARDEES FROM
VARIOUS LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING AUTHORITIES FROM THE
STEPHEN M. THOMPSON RUNNING
PAYMENT PROGRAM. OUR FINDINGS
INDICATED THAT 80% OF THE
WARNINGS WERE STILL SERVING IN
HIGH NEED AREA ONE YEAR AFTER
COMPLETION OF THEIR SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS. WE WILL CONTINUE
THIS SURVEY EACH YEAR TO
MEASURE RETENTION OVER TIME.
QUESTION THREE WHAT ARE
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS FOR
INCREASING DIVERSITY IN THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY OSCARS
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
INCREASING HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DIVERSITY AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCE. RESPOND BROWN
PROGRAM STRIVES TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE. I WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING FIVE
YEAR PLAN HAS A GOAL TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF DIVERSE
COMPETENT LICENSED AND NON
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS IN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF PERSONS.
WITH SEVERE MENTAL. OUR SPEND
LOAN REPAYMENT AND SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS INTEND TO INCREASE
THEIR CULTURAL COMPETENCE IN
QUANTITY OR PROVIDERS SERVING
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WE EXPAND OUR TOOLS TO ACHIEVE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE DIVERSITY.
QUESTION FOR WOULD YOU
MINISTRATION BE OPEN TO
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE EACH
COP WITH AN ARCH. WE ARE AWARE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
STATED THAT WELCOME. IT HEALTH
CAREER OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THE ONE FRESNO STATE
ARE KEY WORKFORCE PIPELINE
PROGRAMS TO RE ROUTE. HOW MANY
STUDENTS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
REGIONS AND BACKGROUNDS TO
PURSUE HEALTHCARE CAREERS. THIS
WORK IS SIMILAR TO WORK WE DO
WITH OUR MANY GRANTS PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUTH AND STUDENTS TO EXPLORE
HEALTHCARE EXPERIENCES. I
DIDN'T DEFERRED FINANCE IF
THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. NUMBER. FIVE HOW ARE
YOU COULD MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROPOSED
NEW ADVENTURE OKAY INCLUDED IN
THE GERIATRIC WORKFORCE B. C.
P. ANDERSON YOUR COMMENT. SORRY
YOU SEEN NO THANK YOU. I'M
SURPRISED BY HOW WILL I SHOULD
KNOW THE OF PROPOSED NEW AND IN
THE JERRY WERE. WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED WE SURVEYS THE ASK
AWARDEES ABOUT THEIR INTENT TO
STAY IN A- AREA. AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY IN THE SERVICE AREA.
WE WILL SURVEIL TO MEASURE
THEIR RETENTION AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND THE NUMBER OF HOURS
PROVIDERS DEVOTE TO GERIATRIC
CARE. MISS REMEMBER SAID MISS
RESUME I MAY STOP YOU HERE IF I
CAN AND BROUGHT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE OF THE WORK
PROJECT GEN ADVANCING GERIATRIC
CARE- BUT I'M ALSO CURIOUS ON
THE SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION I
MEAN I KNOW IT'S NOT RELEVANT
RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO SEE THAT AN EFFORT%
BEING MADE BECAUSE I'M HEARING
FROM PARENTS. THAT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING SPECIFIC- CAREFULLY
READ THEIR THEIR CHILDREN. ARE
TRAINED DOCTORS WHO KNEW HOW TO
WORK WITH THESE. THIS
POPULATIONS ROAD LIKE TO EITHER
FURTHER AGENDAS OR MAKE SURE
THAT HOSPITAL KNOWS. THAT ISN'T
A BIG CONCERN. I MADE- TABLE
THE QUESTION UNTIL OUR DD
HEARING WHICH IS- JUST IN A
WEEK OR SO AND SO I'M IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER ABSOLUTELY JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT TO NOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- S. FRESNO
STATE'S- PROGRAMS AGO BROUGHT
UP IT HAD ME THINKING ABOUT A
CONVERSATION I HAD WITH ONE OF
MY HOSPITAL CEOS THIS MORNING
IN REGARDS TO THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE- HUNDREDS OF NURSING
STUDENTS OUT THERE THAT HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR CLINICAL HOURS-
BUT WITH COVAY THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO GO IN AND GET THEIR TESTING.
SO WE CAN'T GET THEM LICENSED
AND GET THEM IN THE FIELD- SO I
WANTED TO BRING THAT TO THE
ATTENTION- AT THIS TIME IF
THERE'S ANYTHING- ANYBODY ELSE
CAN DO TO PUSH ON THAT OVER ON-
THE OTHER END THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. I CAN'T SEE US
CONTINUING TO PAY DOUBLE FOR
TRAVELLING NURSES WHEN WE HAVE
STUDENTS THAT ARE PUT IN THEIR
DAVIS AND ARE READY TO TEST.
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK
FOR A QUESTION- TO DIRECTOR
LANDSBERG. YOU HAD MADE THE
COMMENT THAT WE CANNOT TAKE
ETHNICITY DIRECTLY INTO ACCOUNT.
I WANTED TO SEE THE DIFFERENCES
WERE BETWEEN THE WHAT THE
WARRANTIES WHICH ARE REFLECTIVE
OF. AND SONG BROWN. WHICH DOES
NOT QUITE REACH EQUITABLE.
DISTRIBUTION OF PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION ASEMBLY MEMBER AND I
WILL START AND SEE. IT'S ALL
WANTS TO ADD ANYTHING BUT AGAIN
WE DO USE ALL TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL- WITH THE WET FUNDING
WE IT'S A REGIONAL APPROACH AND
SO WE DID ALL A LISTENING
SESSION. AND HEARD FROM FOLKS
IN THE REGION ABOUT WHAT THEY
MOST NEED ON THEIR ON THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. FOR
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS AGAIN WE
USE TOOLS SUCH AS LOOKING AT
UNDERSERVED AREAS FOLKS WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCE- SERVING.
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
LANGUAGES SPOKEN COMMITMENT TO
THE WORK I THINK- ON SOLID
GROUND. AGAIN WITH WITH
PHYSICIAN POSITIONS IN
PARTICULAR- WE SEE LESS.
DIVERSE DIVERSITY IN TERMS OF
RACE AND ETHNICITY WHEN WE DO
WITH OUR NURSE PRACTITIONER-
AND POSITION ASSISTANT AND
OTHER POSITIONS SO IN EACH OF
OUR PROGRAMS WERE USING. THE
TOOLS WE CAN AND SOMETIMES.
WITH THAT WITH DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES. I'M I FEEL ABA TO
MENTION THAT WHILE KERN THERE'S
A PERCENT WHICH IS THE FIGURE
YOU MENTIONED THAT IS
REPRESENTED BY. LATINO AND
BLACKS- WITHIN OUR CURRENT WORK
FORCE YOU SAID SONG BROWN IS
CURRENTLY TRAINING AT 24% AND I
FEEL OBLIGATED TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT. OF LATINO AND BLACK
CALIFORNIANS AND SO IT'S HARD
FOR US TO GET TO EQUITY BEFORE
CURRENTLY NOT TRAINING. ABOVE
THE LEVEL WHERE WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIANS AND- BUT JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT BECAUSE I DO
THINK THERE'S POLICY DECISIONS
WE CAN LOOK TO WENT.
SPECIFICALLY SINCE AGE COP WAS
MENTIONED IN THE FRESNO STATE I
FEEL AGAIN- NEEDING TO MENTION
THAT IT ORIGINALLY WAS A
FEDERAL H. COPS PROGRAM AND IT
WASN'T. UNTIL WE REALIZED THAT
THERE WERE SO MANY UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AT THE WHO WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM THAT
THEY HAD TO CHANGE THE PROGRAM
ITSELF AND BROUGHT IT
INTERNALLY INTO THE OFFICE.
SIGNET MORE STUDENTS TO IN. AND
SO I MENTIONED THAT AS A WAY
FOR US TO BE CREATIVE IN COMING
UP WITH SOLUTIONS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE BEING FORWARD THINKING
AND- DIRECTOR WOULD JUST
APPRECIATE FOLLOW UP WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. WITH THAT WE WILL
THANK THIS PANEL FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY AND WILL MOVE ON TO
THE PANEL THREE CD PH WHERE WE
WILL HAVE EIGHT PRESENTERS.
INCLUDING DR THOMAS ARAGON
SUSAN FANELLI DR ERICA PAN
MONICA MORALES ADRIAN BERASA
SCOTT VONA SERRA BOSS AND SONYA
PADDOCK. AGAIN WE WILL HOLD OUR
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL THE
PRESENTERS OF LOOTED PLEASE
BEGIN DR ERAGON. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR- THE NEW
YORK TIMES TODAY SO THAT WE CAN
PREVENT TO- OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGET MY NAME IS DR TOMASZ
ARTICLE I'M- THE NEW DIRECTOR
OF. THE PH THIS IS BEGINNING OF
MARCH WEEKS SO. I'M STILL IN
MODE. WE HAVE A LOT OF SPEAKERS
SO IS GOING TO JUMP IN I'M
GONNA HANDLE. TO BRANDON NUNEZ
EACH THE FIFTH OFF. GOVERNANCE
CHIEF ARBITER OF BUFFER THAT HE
GONNA AND- THE ARE BUDGETING.
FOR GOOD AFTER MR CHAIRMAN ON
BRANDON IN THE FROM THE
CHEAPEST DIRECTOR FOR
OPERATIONS HERE APART- I HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED FOR A KIND OF OVER
OF OUR BY ON THE AGENDA THE YOU
HAVE OF YOU TODAY ACTS PROVIDES.
A REALLY OVER OF OUR BY ALL CAN
HIT SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS- TO
SUPPORT OF BUT- WE MINUTES. OUR
ARE OTHER WE MINISTER OF FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION- PURPOSE
CLEAR TWENTY TWO ONE AND FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION IS FOR PO.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS
INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR TEAM OF
ABOUT ABOUT STAFF. OVER ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED EVER PROGRAM AREAS.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO ABOUT
THIRTY PER OF OUR COMES FROM
FIFTY TO SPECIAL FUNDS. EXCUSE
ME WITH ANOTHER LARGE FOR OF
30% COMING FROM MARK FUNDS.
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF OUR BUDGET
COMES FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
WANTED OUT ON THE AGENDA- THAT
TOTAL DOES ACTUALLY THAT TOTAL
DAYS HIGHER THAN MOST YEARS AND
REFLECTS THE SUPPORT PROVIDED
TO OUR DEPARTMENT FOR COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE. THIS YEAR
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO A
COUPLE KEY PROPOSALS OUTLINED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDE. ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS IN RESPONSE FOR A FROM
FEDERAL AND STATE SOURCES FOR
VARIOUS RESPONSE FUNCTIONS.
INCLUDING TESTING CONTACT
TRACING AND SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. ANYONE
TWENTY TWO THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION TO FURTHER SUPPORT
STATEWIDE TESTING EFFORTS. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES SEVENTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND OF WHICH
TEN POINT TWO MILLION FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE PROGRAM- THIS IS ONE OF
THE BTP THE WILL DISCUSS WITH
YOU TODAY. AND THE FUNDING WILL
BE AVAILABLE OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD TO SUPPORT AN EQUITABLE
AND COURTNEY THEIR PRO SAL
TIMERS DISEASE AND RELATED
DEMENTIAS. IN OUR CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FOUR MILLION.
ABOUT NINETEEN MILLION OF THIS
SUPPORT THE ACTION TAKEN A
COUPLE YEARS AGO IN THE BUDGET-
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO A CITY
INCREASED SUPPORT FOR A LOT
ANGELES COUNTY. CONTRACT ON
THEY DO SOME WORK FOR US. IN
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION-
AND THEY HAVE CONTACTED WE
CONTACT WITH THEM FOR MANY
YEARS FOR THAT AND ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION OF THAT
INCREASE BECAUSE THE SUPPORT
THAT. THE REMAINING FUNDING
INCLUDED- IS INCLUDED IMPORTED
FROM BCPS- ONE OF WHICH IS
RELATED TO P. P. HER HEALTHCARE
AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND WE'LL
BE DISCUSSING WITH THAT- WITH
YOU TODAY- AND FINALLY THE
MEDICAL AND ADULT USE CANNABIS
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT- PAST
PUBLIC HELP WITH LICENSING
COMMERCIAL COMMERCIAL RATHER.
MEDICINAL CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES. TO ESTABLISH
THE NEW DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL IN ORDER TO CONSOLIDATE
LICENSING AND REGULATORY
FUNCTIONS. AND AS SUCH PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL TRANSFER- OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THAT AREA.
ALONG WITH- TWENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS AND ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY POSITIONS OVER TO THE
NEW DEPARTMENT- BIJAN THE ALONG
WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE
BUDGET. ACTUALLY AFTER TO
PRESENT ON FIVE OF THE BPP THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN OUR PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR- WE HAVE ELEVEN TOTAL
BTP THIS YEAR ALONG WITH
UPDATES TO OUR VARIOUS- LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ESTIMATES THAT WE
HAVE EVERY YEAR- SO IF YOU LIKE
WE HAVE A TEAM ON THE LINE WHO
CAN PROVIDE. AN UPDATE ON THOSE
FIVE BCPS OR WE CAN GO INTO-
RESPONSE EFFORTS WHICHEVER-
WHICHEVER. LIKE LET'S FOCUS ON
RESPONSE EFFORTS PLEASE. YEAH
ALL HANDING BACK OVER TO OUR-
DIRECTOR IN OUR TEAM. OKAY IN
ORDER THEM UP ALONG WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND WE HAVE. DR
ERICA PAM WHOSE BIRTHDAY
HAPPENED IN THE OLDEST AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND I'VE
BEEN THE SCENE- ARTIFACT OF THE
RESPONSIBLE TO GO AHEAD AND
HANDED OVER TO HER TO YOU NEED
HELP OR NEW FAN AFTER HER.
BELLY GO AHEAD AND THINKING
TEAM AFRICA. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU'LL HEAR ME. RIGHT SO- I CAN
JUST PROVIDE A SORT OF OVERALL
OVERVIEW OF OUR AND OF THE CALL
THE ROLL RESPONSIBLE AND OUR
STRATEGY IS RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC- WE'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT IT IS SORT OF SEVEN OVER
ARCHING AREAS THAT WE- OVERSEE
AND FOCUS ON SO A REALLY AND-
OF COURSE THE CRUCIAL PART OF
IT IS MONITORING THE SCOPE AND
THE PROGRESS IN THE PANDEMIC
SO- THAT HELPS INFORM OUR
RESPONSE SO EVERYTHING FROM THE
SURVEILLANCE WHICH HAS TO DO
WITH ALL THE CASE REPORTING ALL
THE TESTING AND HAVING ON THE
TESTING DATA COME TO US. WE
WORK ON MODELING AND ANALYSIS
ALL THAT DATA- AND OF COURSE
THAT'S GOING TO REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DISPARATE IMPACTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC ON OUR POPULATION. AND
OF COURSE ALL THE FOR ALL OF
THAT IT'S REALLY PHENOMENAL TO
HAVE- GOOD DATA COLLECTION AND
GOOD DATA AND IT SYSTEMS SO
THAT'S ONE A HUGE ERROR AREA OF
OUR STRATEGY AND- AND ROLL AND
THEN WE OF COURSE WANT TO
DEVELOP AND- ADVOCATE FOR
POLICIES THAT SUPPORT OUR
MISSION- TO PROTECT THE HEALTH.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH- FROM THIS
PANIC SO WE PROVIDE A SCIENCE
BASED FRAMEWORK FOR SAFETY
OPENING OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
CONNIE TO MINIMIZE HEALTH
IMPACTS WHILE WE MINIMIZE
TRANSMISSION- WE WILL HAVE
POLICIES BASED ON DEVELOPING
AND PROMOTING EQUITABLE
POLICIES- AND RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS THAT'S COURSE HANG
RIGHT NOW THAT SEEMS WHICH
WILL- TALK ABOUT IN A LITTLE
BIT- ALIGNING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE POLICIES AND ACTION
WITH CHANGING SCOPE AND DEMANDS
OF THE PANDEMIC SO. IT'S BEEN A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR NOW SINCE
WE'VE BEEN RESPONDING IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MEMBER MANY
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EMERGENCY
RESPONSES STARTED LAST JANUARY
WHEN WE FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS
SO- WE'VE HAD TO RAPIDLY HAVE
IT EVERY TIME WE LEARN MORE AND
THIS VIRUSES- OFTEN ONE STEP
AHEAD BUT WE HAVE BEEN LEARNING
A LOT ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT-
POLICIES WE NEED TO DEVELOP-
AND- THEN. THE HUGE IS A-
ANSWER. COVER NINETY SO- AGAIN
WE ARE DRY. PREVENTION AND NOT
PHARMACY AND I'VE- TO MINIMIZE.
HOW IMPACTS- WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
SUPPRESSING CONTAIN COVER
NINETEEN AND THAT. ENCOMPASSES
DOING CASE AND CONTACTED US
OCCASION TESTING- ISOLATION AND
QUARANTINE ON THE GROUND. AT
THE HELP AT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT LEVEL. AND WE
PROVIDE A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OPERATE CONTROL
AND CONGREGATE LIVING
FACILITIES OF COURSE THE
HIGHEST RISK OF THOSE A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES WE HAVE A-%
VERY ROBUST HEALTHCARE
ASSOCIATED INFECTION PROGRAM
THAT. PROVIDES A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- AND THEN OF COURSE
IN OTHER RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS
THAT ARE HIGH RISK INCLUDING
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES OTHER
WORKPLACES SCHOOLS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY SETTINGS SO WE
PROVIDE A LOT OF. TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS ARE THERE'S MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL OPERATES WE GET
MORE INVOLVED BUT A LOT OF THAT
FRONT LINE WORK HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL. LEVEL AS WELL- AND THEN
WE'D CHRIS DEVELOPING PROVIDE
INNOVATIVE AND EQUITABLE
SOLUTIONS FOR CHANGING THE
COURSE OF THE CALL THE
NINETEENTH AND I CAN. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY DEVELOPING OUR
BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK FOR RE
OPENING ECONOMY AND- HAVING
THAT HEALTHEQUITY METRIC HAS
REALLY CHANGED. THE WAY WE
RESPOND AS A STATE- ANOTHER HE
ERROR AND- IS COORDINATING AND
SOMETHING. THAT HEALTH CARE S
AND HEALTH CARE RESOURCES AND-
PHARMACEUTICAL INTERVENTIONS
SO. AGAIN RIGHT NOW TOP OF MIND
IS DEVELOPING AND- AND
IMPLEMENTING OUR EQUITABLE
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION PLAN. BACK SAYING
CALIFORNIANS BASED ON THE
AVAILABLE VACCINE SUPPLY- WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE IN THE FALL
FLU VACCINATION TO REDUCE THE
BURDEN ON THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THINK WE HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN-
HARDLY ANY FLU WHICH IS- WHERE
ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT
GIVEN HOW MUCH SURGERIES ON THE
HOSPITAL'S CHESIL COVE THE
NINETEEN- WE HAVE BEEN.
ASSURING INFECTION CONTROL
PROTOCOLS AND ALL HEALTH CARE
FACILITY SETTINGS ARE FOLLOWED
AND- AGAIN MITIGATING OUTBREAKS
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
MARIN PROVIDING AVAILABLE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
HEALTH CARE STUFF I SEE YOU
BETTER THAN THE LEADERS TO MEET
YOUR DEMANDS. AS YOU KNOWN AS
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT- WOMEN'S
FINALE COMES TO SPEAK AROUND
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE SUPPORT WE
PROVIDED AS FAR AS PREVENTING
CRISIS CARE RESPONSE AND- I'M
REALLY KEEPING PEOPLE- AT WORST
AND CONTINGENCY WITH ALL KINDS
OF. INTERVENTIONS IT'S OF
COURSE REALLY CRUCIAL AS A
HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE COMMUNICATING EFFECTIVELY
TO THE PUBLIC. AND ENGAGE IN
ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS- SO
COMMUNICATE I GUESS. AND UP TO
DATE CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
APPROPRIATE SCIENCE BASED EASY
TO UNDERSTAND INFORMATION AND
ACCESSIBLE FORMATS AND
LANGUAGES ABOUT THE STATUS OF
VIRUS TRANSMISSION. AND KEY
RESPONSE AND PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES. WE WORK VERY HARD
TO INCREASE AWARENESS ABOUT THE
DISPARITIES AND DISEASE IMPACT
ON COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PARTNERS TO
DESIGN TARGETED PUBLIC HEALTH.
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS- WE ALSO
COURSE NEED TO FOCUS JUST ON
OUR OVERALL COORDINATION ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENT- AND ACROSS
OUR OWN INTERNAL AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE A
COORDINATED RESPONSE AND-
REALLY ENSURE WE HAVE AN ALL
GOVERNMENT AND ALL COMMUNITY
REALLY RESPONSIVE THIS PANDEMIC
SO- WE HAD THEN LEADING- ACROSS
WITH HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AND A LOT OF OTHER- EXCELLENT
PARTNERS- WE HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH
A LOT OF DIFFERENT TASK FORCES
WORK GROUPS AND INITIATIVES.
WE'VE BEEN FOSTER ACCORDING TO
MULTI AGENCY APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF-
SUBGROUPS WITHIN THE POPULATION
INCLUDING IN GEOGRAPHIC AREAS.
AND DEVELOPING A UNIFIED DATA
SYSTEM ANALYTICAL DASHBOARDS
FOR THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
CONTINUE ON THAT CROSSES
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS. AND THEN
REALLY CRUCIAL AS WELL COURSES
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SIXTY ONE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS SO AS
A STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
PARTNER WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE NOT AN ARM
ESSENTIALLY OF OUR OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH ACROSS THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT ALL OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE COLLABORATE
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN THE DEVEOPMENT
OF EQUITABLE POLICIES AND-
PLANS WITH THE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH- EACH OF LOCAL DEPARTMENTS
AND THEIR- SO THE SISTER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE-
CALIFORNIA COVERS LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION- AND
HELP US AS A NATION OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE DISTRICT OFFICES FOR
LICENSING INSERT THAT WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH. OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE GROUND AS WELL AS OUR LOCAL
COORDINATION TEAMS. WERE
DEVELOPED- AND WE'RE RIGHT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPLEMENT SUPPORT
THE LOCAL RESPONSE. SO THAT'S
SORT OF A OVERVIEW OF HOW WE
THINK ABOUT OUR OVER ARCHING
STRATEGIES- RESPONSE. AND THEN
WE WERE ASKED TO ADDRESS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT REMAINING COVE
IN NINETEEN CHALLENGES. THAT
ARE STILL FACING THE STATE AND
I THINK- THERE'S A FEW KEY
AREAS WE WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT-
OBVIOUSLY AGAIN VACCINATION
AND- GETTING OUR VACCINE OUT-
YOU KNOW QUICKLY YEAH I QUICKLY
AND EFFICIENTLY AND HAVING GOOD
DATA COLLECTION AROUND THAT SO
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHERE. MAXINE
IS- I THINK OUR OTHER BIG
CHALLENGE- WELL WE ARE GETTING
EVERYONE EXCITED IS MODERATING
AND STAYING ON TOP OF ANY
VARIANTS THAT. MERGE SO WE KNOW
WE HAVE SOME OF THE YOU CAME
HERE AFTER BE ONE SEVEN IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ONE OF THE
MOST ROBUST GENOMIC SEQUENCING-
NETWORKS IN THE COUNTRY- BUT WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO DO MORE AND
WE'RE RAPIDLY SCALING THAT UP
RIGHT NOW AS WELL- IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEQUENCE OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND. AYE SLIPS
WHICH IS A HUGE PROPORTION OF
THAT SEQUENCES- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- SO WE'VE BEEN ALSO
WORKING WITH OUR MODELING TEAMS
TO LOOK AT HOW THAT MIGHT
IMPACT THINGS ARE ALSO
MONITORING. OF VARIANCE THAT
YOU KNOW- WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN
SEEN IN OTHER STATES BUT WE'RE
DETECTING A LOT HERE AND
UNDERSTAND. THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT ACCORDING WITH THE SEC AND-
THE GROUND FOR AT THE END OF
THAT. A HUGE HUGE CHALLENGE IS
THAT. THE T. THE- RIGHT UP IS
TIRED YOU ARE HARD TIME. WE
TIRED AND PEOPLE. WE NEED TO
REALLY- BE PATIENT WITH US
GETTING VACCINE OUT. SORT OF
GET. THROUGH TELLING TO HER TO.
AND WE ALL NEED TO CAN TO DO
ALL THESE IMPORTANT. UNTIL WE
CAN GET THERE. SO CONTAINING
I'M ASKING OUR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING ALL THESE REALLY
IMPORTANT NON PHARMACEUTICAL
INTERVENTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
UNTIL WE REALLY CAN GET- TO A
HERD IMMUNITY AND GET ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS AND AGAIN WE
KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL HUMAN AND
PEOPLE ARE REALLY TIRED OF
THOSE THINGS SO. TRYING TO FIND
FRESH AND NEW WAYS TO KEEP
PEOPLE- KEEP PEOPLE WITH US AND
ALL THESE IMPORTANT
INTERVENTIONS. AND THEN OF
COURSE AS WE ALL KNOW GETTING
OUR SCHOOLS REOPEN IS A HUGE
IMPORTANT CHALLENGE THAT WE
NEED TO- THAT WE'RE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON WITH ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS AND TAT IT'S JUST-
STILL FACING US AS WE NEED TO
GET OUR KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL.
AND YOU KNOW IF FOR MOST AND
CENTER WE'VE BEEN TALKING
THROUGHOUT AS ONE OF OUR CORE
VALUES MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING EQUITY AND ALL THESE
ISSUES IS KIND OF EXTREMELY HAS
MAGNIFIED- THE DISPARITIES IN
OUR- SOCIETY AND IN OUR STATE
AND I THINK WE HAVE DONE-
WITHIN A REAL LEADER AND THAT'S
NATIONALLY- BUT WE- CONTINUE TO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
ADDRESS ALL THE INEQUITIES
THAT- THAT WE'RE. SEEING THIS
CATHOLIC. THERE WERE A COUPLE
OTHER. THAT WERE. TO LATER ON.
AND THEY WERE TO JUST MENTION
AS WELL. I NUMBER. WAS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
OUTSTANDING UNMET NEEDS. AT THE
STATE LEVEL THEY'RE SLOWING OUR
PROGRESS AND I THINK THE ONES
THAT I JUST OUTLINED ARE ARE
EXACTLY THAT SO AGAIN GETTING
ALL OVER. THANK SEEN- AND
GETTING MORE SUPPLY AND GETTING
THAT INTO PEOPLE. AND AGAIN
MONNING THE VARIANT. COOL I
THINK THOSE ARE REALLY ARE OUR
FUTURE AND OUTSTANDING. AND
THEN AS FAR AS HOW WILL THE
STATE INSURE EQUITY IN THE NEW
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM-
UTILIZING A NEW THIRD PARTY
STRAIGHTER SO WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH- ON THE
PLANS FOR THAT AND WE- ARE
WORKING ON NOT ONLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ALLOCATIONS- WHEN
THE T. PAY STARTS WILL BE-
LOOKING AT OUR HELP THE PLACE
INDEX WHICH WE ALSO USE FOR
HEALTH EQUITY METRIC IN THE
BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK. AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY PROVIDING
ALLOCATION VACCINES IN THOSE
AREAS THAT HAVE THE MOST IMPACT
SO THAT IS ONE KEY THING AS FAR
AS ALLOCATION AND THEN OTHER
PRINCIPLES WERE WORKING CLOSELY
ON- INCORPORATING INTO HAVE I
SEEN IS DISTRIBUTED WOULDN'T
INCLUDE. HEY FOR PERFORMANCE
PAYMENTS SO WE WILL- BE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE INCENTIVES
FOR VACCINATING INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE LIVING IN THE LOWEST EACH
BACKWARD TILES. AND ALSO- THANK
AGING AND NOT ONLY A PROVIDERS
THAT CAN- BRING VACCINES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT ALSO
WITH THE CAMPUS ORGANIZATIONS
ARE TO HELP THAT OUR REGION
ENGAGEMENT. REALLY ADDRESS
VACCINE HESITANCY- SO AND PAY
FOR TERM OUR REGION AND IS AN
EFFORT AND CANCER PAYMENT FOR.
AND JUST RESOURCE NEEDED AS
ACCESSIBILITY INTERPRET
INTERPRETERS- PROVIDING MOBILE
SITES GETTING INTO
NONTRADITIONAL SITES AS WELL
AS- AFTER HOURS MAKING SURE
IT'S AVAILABLE AT ALL DIFFERENT
TIMES- AND OTHER CRITICAL
SERVICES LIKE THAT SO THOSE ARE
THE DIFFERENT WAYS WE ARE.
WORKING TO ENSURE THERE IS
EQUITY AND THE NEW VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION. AND THEN I WAS
ALSO- I SHALL WAIT TO- TURN
OVER TO SEASON FINALE TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS THEN I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW AFTER THAT WASN'T
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT- DOCTOR
REGULAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
HAVE PRESSED ABOUT SOME OF THE
DATA. THANK YOU DR GRAHAM
MISPRONOUNCED. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
YOU ALL HEAR ME. HELLO YES OKAY
SO I WAS ASKED TO- TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- WHAT HAS
WORKED WELL AND NOT ROLE IN
TERMS OF OUR SHARED
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE- I THINK
I'LL START WITH THEM BY SAYING
THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
FOUNDATION OF OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND- HAVE CONTINUED
THE DIALOGUE ON POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF MANY OF
THESE- DIFFERENT POLICIES I
THINK WE CONTINUE TO LEARN AND
ADAPT THOSE POLICIES. AS WE
WORK WITH OUR SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS BUT AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SIXTY ONE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND SOMETIMES
WHAT THEY'RE SEEING ON THE
GROUND HAS BEEN DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT PLACES AND SO I THINK
THAT IS SOMETIMES A IFFICULT
AS WE TRY TO CREATE STATE
POLICIES. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT- DOES SIXTY
ONE DIFFERENT- PICTURES ON THE
GROUND AND SO WE'VE DONE OUR
BEST TO. ALLOW FLEXIBILITY WHEN
WE CAN AND TO HAVE STATEWIDE
POLICY WHEN WE NEED TO AND I'LL
GIVE SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT I
THINK THE WORST EXCESSES SO I
THINK WHEN WE MOVED TO- TORN
AWAY FROM THE VARIANTS AND SOME
OF THE EARLY STAGES INTO THE
BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK. I THINK
THAT WENT A LONG WAY AND
PUTTING EVERYBODY ON THE SAME
PAGE AS TO WHAT TO EXPECT WHAT
WOULD OPEN AND WHEN AND WONDER
WHAT CONDITIONS AND I THINK
THAT TRANSPARENCY LEADS TO A
MUCH BETTER PROCESS IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO PREDICT AND- BOTH
AT THE PUBLIC SECTOR- YEAH THE
PUBLIC AND BUSINESS SECTOR AS
WELL AS LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS ABILITY. TO
EXPLAIN WHAT WAS HAPPENING I
THINK OUR EQUITY PLAYBOOK IN
OUR EQUITY METRIC IS A TRUE
SIGN OF SIX UP BETWEEN YOU KNOW
WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH STAND FOR
AND HOW WE WANT TO RUN THE
RESPONSE TO- PROTESTS VIRUS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE REALLY DO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. ADEQUATELY
AND THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MAKE THAT REAL-
ACROSS THE STATE I THINK WHAT
WE MOVED AS WE OPEN SECTORS AND
REALIZED THAT OUR COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION WOUND UP MOVING TO
THE REGIONAL STAY AT. HOME
ORDER I'M LAWS FOR REALLY. AND
US. MAKE SURE THAT. PREVENTIVE
DENTICLE HEALTH CARE CAPACITY
FROM BEING OVER ONE- AND THE
OBJECTIVE TO SET LIMITS IN A-
WITH. WITH OTHER FROM OUTSIDE
THE HOUSEHOLD AND NOT SOLD TO
REDUCE. COVE IN NINETEEN
TRANSIT. BY REDUCING THE STERN
TRANSMISSION WE'RE ABLE TO I'M
REALLY REDUCE THAT. BEND THE
CURVE DOWNWARD SO THAT WE COULD
REDUCE THE IMPACT ON THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE
HAVE OUR MODELERS LOOKING OUT
THAT AND MAKING SURE
PREDICTIONS AS TO WHAT IMPACT
THAT HAD AND COMPARED TO
PROJECTIONS FROM. PRIOR TO THE
REGIONAL STAND HOME ORDER WE
THINK BY LATE JANUARY THERE
WERE AT LEAST. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FEWER
HOSPITALIZATIONS- FIVE THOUSAND
FEWER DEATHS BECAUSE OF THE
REGIONAL STAY AT HOME ACROSS
THE STATE. AND AS YOU KNOW THE
REGIONAL STAND HOME ORDER
TEMPORARILY BARRED PRIVATE
GATHERINGS CLOSE RESTAURANT
OPERATIONS. KLEPPER CARRY OUT
DELIVERY AND REDUCED RETAIL
CAPACITY IN REGIONS WITH LESS
THAN. 15% I SEE YOU PAPER
AVAILABILITY. WE GAVE NEW GUY.
OUT THE TO GO ALONG WITH THAT
REGION STAND HOME ORDER WE THEN
ALL MOVE TO A PUBLIC ORDER.
THAT CANCELLED ELECTIVE
SURGERIES WHEN A WITH THAT.
CAPACITY FOR- ALL FOR A LOT SEE
YOU PASS IT. AND THAT HELP TO
REALLY- MAY SURE THAT WE HAD AN
APPLE ACT DISTRIBUTION OF
HEALTHCARE RESOURCES ACROSS THE
STATE AND STATE OUT OF CRISIS
CARE OR MOVE VERY QUICKLY OUT
OF CRISIS CARE. THROUGHOUT ALL
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE. I
THINK WE CONTINUE TO USE OUR
MODELS AND PROJECTIONS TO TRY
TO IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SITUATION AND TO MAKE
POLICY DECISIONS I THINK YOU
KNOW IT THEY IT HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING OF WE ARE ALL ARE
LEARNING MORE AND MORE EVERY
DAY ABOUT THE VIRUS AND WHAT.
WE CAN DO TO COMBAT THAT BUT I
THINK REALLY THAT SUCCESS HAS
BEEN THE ONGOING DIALOGUE AND
THE ABILITY TO CHANGE COURSE
WELL AS WE LEARN MORE. ABOUT
THE VIRUS. OBVIOUSLY SOME
COUNTIES BETTER WORSE THAN
OTHERS IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
TOOLS EXPERTISE AND EVEN
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION- AND I
THINK WE HAVE DONE OUR BEST.
EVEN EVEN IN SPITE OF THE FACT
THAT THE COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS DECLINED
OVER THE PAST DECADE- AND MANY
ALLERGIES HAVE BROADER OR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE. SEEN
SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTIONS IN
STAFF. THEIR DATA SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH
TECHNOLOGY. OUR RESOURCES ARE
NOT. EVENLY DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
THE STATE SO WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE JUMPED IN A BIGGER WAY IN
PLACES LIKE IMPERIAL COUNTY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SOME OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES- SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT HAVE SEEN THE
HIGHEST TRANSMISSION- TO REALLY
TRY EQUAL. OUT THAT- THOSE
RESOURCES AND REALLY HAVE
RELIED ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL RESPONSE STRUCTURE. TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO AFTER THE
NEEDED RESOURCES AND TO DO OUR
BEST TO GET THEM. SO IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY WE STARTED BEAR
GIVEN THE HIGH TRANSMISSION
LARGELY IMPACTED BY THE BORDER.
AND REALLY HELPING WITH THE
HEALTH CARE SIR JOHN OF TWO
HOSPITALS BUT ALSO HELPING THE
CONTACT TRACING. AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAD ACCESS TO
TESTING AND REALLY AN ALL OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO GET THEM
THE RESOURCES THAT NEED THEY
NEED IT. AND WE DID SEEN HERE
OF FOUR TO SIX WEEKS LATER A
REAL REDUCTIONIN THEIR
TRANSMISSION AND LYFT IMPACT ON
OUR HOSPITALS. WE THEN USE THAT
AS AMODEL FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE WE- CREATING
UNIFIED SUPPORT TEAM SEND ONE
OUT TO YOU. EACH OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COUNTIES CAN WORK WITH
THEM I AM THE SAME WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED MEDIA PER HEALTHCARE
SURGE. THAT THEY HAVE AND WHAT
THEY NEED OR FOR TESTING AND
FOR CONTACT TRACING. WE'VE SET
UP A SERIES OF LOCAL
COORDINATORS WHO ARE ON THE
GROUND HELPING BASE WITH EVERY
COUNTY EITHER SIGNED A
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
COUNTY EVERY WEEK AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING OUR BEST. TO
GET THEM THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED. HEALTH CARE THIRD WE
HAVE THOUSAND STATE. AND STAFF.
CLINICAL PEOPLE OUT. IN THESE
HAVE. ARE THE TO ME SURE. THE
RESOURCE THAT ARE NEEDED-
SUPPLEMENT HEALTH CARE TO. SO
ARE IN PLACE- AND WE HAVE- WHO
REALLY SPENT TIME AND OF THE
CONTACT RACING WE BUILD TECH
HOW CAN ACCESS THEM WITH A LOT
OF INPUT FROM OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS TO CREATE A SYSTEM
WHEREBY NOW. WE HAVE FIFTY FOUR
OUT OF SIXTY ONE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS REALLY USING THAT
CAL CAN ACCESS THEM FURTHER
CONTACT RATING AND CON AND
DISEASE INVESTIGATION- AND THEN
WE DID OUR BEST TO CREATE
TESTING- ACCESS TO TESTING
ACROSS THE STATE THROUGH-
VOLUNTEER LAB THROUGH THE OPTIM
SURFSIDE'S THROUGH MANY WAYS.
OF GETTING ACCESS IN. THOSE
HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS. I'M
AND SO I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW
WE TO TRY TO DO OUR ABOUT TO
EAT OUT THE- AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED TO AND
RECOGNIZING THAT. YOU KNOW NOT
EVERY COUNTY HAS ACCESS TO THE
SAME ORG RESOURCES WHETHER THAT
BE CONTACT TRACING. TAPPING
SOME OF THE- PUBLIC HEALTH.
DEPARTMENT THAT DON'T HAVE
THEIR OWN TESTING LABS- LAWYER
GIVEN GREATER ACCESS TO THE ON
SALE- SO I MOVE ON TO SOME OF
THE OTHER- IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
ART. CDPH AS ROLAND BAXEEN
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTION. AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS AN- TRANSITION AS WE
MOVE TO A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO RUN THE COMMITTEES
AND SUCH AS THE COMMUNITY A
VACCINE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THAT SCIENTIFIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND THAT DRAFTING
GUIDELINES COMMITTEE WHERE WE
GET INPUT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
POLICIES THAT WE ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE ARE SOLID. WE SAT POLICY
WORKING WITH THESE STAKEHOLDERS.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
THE COMMITTEES. WE SERVE AS A-
TO CDC DIRECTLY AND WORK
DIRECTLY WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE.
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE- J. OR Q.
COMBAT THE FIRE AS WELL- MAN
GET PEOPLE VACCINATED. WE IN
ROLE PROVIDERS FOR THE VACCINE
TO- AND MINISTRATION. WE
ALLOCATE DOSES OF VACCINE BASED
ON THE PRIORITY POPULATIONS
PROPORTIONATE TO THE PUBLIC
PREVALENCE OF EACH POPULATION
THAT IS PRIORITIZED IN NOT
COUNTY. WE HELP WITH THE
STATEWIDE MEDIA CAMPAIGNS AND
EDUCATION. AND WE MAINTAIN AND
DEVELOP THE DATA SYSTEMS IN
COLLABORATION WITH. OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHERS- THAT
INCLUDES THE CARE AND REGIONAL
REGISTRY. HI MY CAL BACKS- THE
MY TURN SYSTEM WHICH IS ON BOTH
THE PUBLIC SCHEDULING AND
CLINIC MANAGEMENT. WE INTERACT
WITH THE FEDERAL DATA SYSTEMS
SUCH AS VACCINES- FINDER AND WE
TRACKED BAXEEN ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE WILL BE ASSISTING IN THE
TRANSITION. TO THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. THE LAST PIECE I
WANTED TO COMMENT ABOUT WHAT
THE FUNDING. AND THERE ARE
REALLY TWO BLOCK OF FUN THE
MIDDLE CLASS WAS AND WHY REALLY
UP THAT HUNDRED FIFTY SOUTH
MILLION. THAT IS SPECIFIC BACKS
DISTRIBUTION THAT MONEY- WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF THE-
DETERMINING HOW MUCH WILL BE
GRANTED TO OUR LOCAL PARTNERS.
ON THE THIS IS DEDICATED SOLELY
TO VACCINE ADMINISTRATION- AND
THERE ARE. THIS IS DUE TO THE
FED'S ON MARCH FIRST WE'RE
STILL WORKING TO IRON OUT
EXACTLY HOW WE'LL USE THOSE
DOLLARS IN COMPARISON TO THE
ONE POINT. SEVEN BILLION THAT
WE GOT- IN THE ENHANCED
DETECTION HE'LL SEE GRANT-
WE'RE WE ARE GIVING ONE POINT
TWO BILLION OUT TO OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS. AND LOS ANGELES IS
FUNDED DIRECTLY AT FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN ADDITION TO R. ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION- THE
FUNDING FORMULA FOR LOCALS AS I
SAID IS ONE POINT TWO BILLION.
DIVIDED UP TO THE REMAINING
OUTSIDE OF TOP OF LOS ANGELES
GIVING EACH COUNTY OR EACH
LOCAL HEALTH CARE SECTION I
WILL ONE MILLION DOLLAR BASED.
WHAT THE REMAINING FUNDS
DIVIDED 50% ON POPULATION BASE
SHARE 25% ADOPTED FOR POVERTY
AND 25% ADJUSTED. FOR AGE RACE
AND ETHNICITY. TRYING TO ALLOW
THEM. TAXABLE IN THE USE OF
THIS. ACROSS STRATEGIES WE HAVE-
THAT FINANCE HOUSES A LETTER TO
THE DAILY BEAST BREAK DOWN THE
COUNTY ALLOCATION ON THIS
APPLICATION IS DUE TO THE FEDS
ON MARCH EIGHTEENTH. AND
BECAUSE OF THIS HAS BEEN
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION A LARGE- YEAH
THE IT IS COMPREHENSIVE AND NOT
IT STILL INCLUDES CONTACT
TRACING LABORATORY. CAPACITY
AND TESTING AND INCLUDES-
VACCINE ADMINISTRATION DATA
ANALYTICS AND STOPPING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT IT ALSO CAN
BE USED FOR VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION. MMHM MANY OF
THE- MAXINE SUPPORT CAN BE DONE
AN EITHER PRODUCTS FUNDING
HOWEVER THERE ARE A FEW
DISTINCT THINGS THAT CAN ONLY
BE DONE OUT OF A VACCINE
SPECIFIC FUNDING OR THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION. SO
WE'RE LOOKING ABOUT WILL BE
WORKING WITH JACK AND CCHL TIRE
NOW BUT- WHAT THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION WILL BE
USED. TO SUPPORT. WITHOUT FIVE
I WOULD IT BACK OVER TO A WHO
WILL- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS ON RACE AND ETHNICITY.
THANK YOU SUSAN- YOU KNOW
HEARING AGAIN. YES MA'AM OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU- SO- AGAIN WE
DID RECEIVE YOUR LETTER DR
AMBULANCE SOMETHING ABOUT THIS-
AND I'M JUST GOING TO KIND OF
WALK THROUGH I'M SORRY THAT
SOMETHING TECHNOLOGY WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO SHARE SCREEN TO SHOW
YOU BUT I'LL JUST TRY TO READ
YOU SOME NUMBERS- AND WE CAN OF
COURSE FOLLOW UP AFTER- AND
SEND THESE OVER TO YOU- AS FAR
AS HOW MANY VACCINES WE
RECEIVED ON A PERCENTAGE OF AN
ADMINISTERED WE HAVE NOW
RECEIVED. OVER SEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION DOSES DELIVERED TO US
FROM THE CDC IT'S US SEVEN
POINT ONE ONE NINE TWO TWO FIVE
TOTAL DOSES AMONGST THOSE WE
HAVE NOW- ADMINISTERED FOUR
POINT SEVEN OF OVER FOUR POINT
SEVEN DOSES ADMINISTERED SO ONE
MILLION SEVEN FORTY SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE- SO THAT IS
BASICALLY TWO THIRDS OF THAT
IT. DOESN'T DELIVER HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED. AT ALSO REALLY
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ARE FULLY VACCINATED SO EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND TO
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. HAVE
RECEIVED TWO DOSES THAT MEANS
ARE FULLY VACCINATED- SO AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO ADD WE HAVE
REALLY. YOU KNOW MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE CAPACITY FROM ABOUT
FOUR WEEKS AGO AND SO WE ARE
NOW SEEING OU KNOW AND DALY.
TAXATION RATES OF- I BELIEVE
IT'S A HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND A DAY. AND
REALLY DRAMATICALLY INCREASING
CAPACITY AND NOW YOU KNOW THE
REAL ESTATE CONTINUES TO BE-
GETTING THE VACCINE AND GETTING
MORE SUPPLY. AS FAR AS
ACCOUNTING FOR THE RESET AND-
OF EACH PERSON- SO THEIR RACE
ETHNICITY DATA IS COLLECTED
WITH THE VACCINATION RECORD-
AND TO KIND OF READ THROUGH SO
FOR AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN.
NATIVE OF THAT PERCENT IS ZERO
POINT TWO EIGHT PERCENT- TEN
THOUSAND SEVEN FORTY TO THAT OF
AN ACCIDENT WITH A AT LEAST ONE
DOSE. SO THAT IS- ZERO POINT 3%
OF BAD PEOPLE GOTTEN AT LEAST
ONE DOSE. THAT ASIAN RACE IN
THE STATE WOULD HAVE THIRTEEN
POINT 6% OF THE TOTAL DOSES
ADMINISTERED- I THINK I'M JUST
GONNA TALK TO THE PERCENTAGES
THAT SEEMS- MOST EASY TO RELATE
TO. BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN IT'S
BEEN TWO POINT 7% OF THE TOTAL
DOSES ADMINISTERED. A LATINO
FIFTEEN POINT ONE PERCENT.
MULTIRACIAL FOURTEEN POINT 6%
ACTUALLY VERY LARGE CATEGORY-
THAT I'M NOT SURE WHERE WE'RE
STARTING TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE
BUT WE'RE NOT SURE IF WE'LL BE
ABLE TO TEASE THAT OUT BUT IT
IS AGAIN A LARGE CATEGORY. A
NATIVE ONE OR OTHER PACIFIC
ISLANDERS ZERO POINT 5% AND
THEN OTHER TWELVE POINT THREE
PERCENT- SO AGAIN TRYING TO
LOOK INTO THAT A LITTLE MORE
DEEPLY- AND THEN OR. MISSING
DATA FOR TEN POINT 3% UNKNOWN
AT AND THEN OF WAITED THIRTY.
5% SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
CLEANING THIS DATA- AND- WELL
IT WILL BE REPORTING THIS- ON
OUR DASHBOARD SOMETHING AT
LEAST AS WELL. AS FAR AS AGE
BREAKDOWN- SO WE DO COLLECTED
OF BIRTH PERFECT MISSION
RECORD- IN THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY. SO YOU KNOW AS YOU
KNOW- AS YOU LIKELY KNOW THAT
AND HAS NOT THESE VACCINES HAVE
NOT BEEN APPROVED YET OR-
INDIVIDUALS UNDER SIXTEEN YEARS
OF AGE SO WE DO HAVE. A POINT
005% SO PROBABLY SOME SIXTY AND
SEVEN YEAR OLD THAT HAVE- THE
NEXT NEEDED AND IN EIGHTEEN TO
FORTY NINE YEAR EIGHT- GROUP.
THIRTY FIVE POINT 6% OF THE
TOTAL DOSES ADMINISTERED HAVE
BEEN IN EIGHTEEN TO FORTY NINE
YEAR OLDS. IN THE FIFTY TO
SIXTY FOUR YEAR OLD- AGE GROUP
WE'VE HAD NINETEEN POINT FOUR
PERCENT. AND THEN- ALMOST FORTY
FIVE PERCENT- HAVE BEEN IN
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR
OLDER AND AGAIN TO REMIND YOU
THIS DATA- IS PRIMARILY FROM
OUR PHASE ONE EIGHTEEN WHICH
WAS FOCUSING ON HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND- INDIVIDUALS IN
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND%
THEN. IN THE LAST- ABOUT THREE
WEEKS OR SO- THERE HAVE ALSO
BEEN- VACCINATIONS FOR PEOPLE
OVER SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
AND THEN IN SOME AREAS WAS
STARTING TO VACCINATE OR- IN
THE OTHER THREE SECTORS THAT
WERE IN TIER ONE OF THESE
WENDY. WHICH ARE EMERGENCY
SERVICES- AGRICULTURE AND. FOOD
AND EDUCATIONAL SERVICES. AS
FAR AS AND CRY ABOUT HEALTH
STATUS THE IMAGE REGS IT'S- CAN.
ARE PART OF THE MAX RECORD AND
THAT IS WHERE WE'RE RELYING ON
THE SERVER MUSICIAN DATA- YOU
KNOW AND SEEING SOME OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
RESPONSES TO THIS QUESTION.
SOME OF THEM ARE COLLECTING IT
BUT IF. OF AND OF COURSE IF- IF
WE'RE RECEIVING SOME DATA FROM
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS WITH
THAT DATA IS NOT TRANSFERRED.
TO THE IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY-
IS EVERY ASIAN BROKEN DOWN BY
ZIP CODE YES. THE KIND OF
RESIDENTS IS COLLECTED WITH TAX
NATION RECORDS- AND THAT REALLY
HELPS US LOOK AT THE HELP THE
PRICE INDEX DATA. SO WE HAVE
SEEN- THAT- AMONGST PERSONS
PERSONS WITH- AT LEAST ONE DOSE
AS- 31% THIS MIGHT HAVE BEEN
LOCKED IN WITH MORE THAN ONE
DOES- AND ONLY POINT 006% HAVE
BEEN RECEIVED TWO DOSES AND
THEN IN THE- SECOND MOST
DISADVANTAGED GROUP WE HAVE A
20% OR ZERO POINT TWO. RECEIVE
AT LEAST ONE DOSE AND THEN
POINT OUT OR THOSE EXTENDED
WITH MORE THAN TWO DOSES- AND
THEN FOR THE S. SECOND AB TO
HIGHEST LEASES SPENT
DISADVANTAGE. ZERO POINT TWO OF
THOSE- THAT REVISING RUNNING
WINDOWS AND THEN POINT OH FOUR
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IS
AND THEN FOR THE LEAST
DISADVANTAGED- WHAT THE MOST
ADVANTAGE ZERO POINT TWO NINE-
SO AGAIN WE CAN GET THESE
NUMBERS TO YOU- ON A HARD COPY.
LATER THAN THE EXPLAINS WHAT TO
SEE- SORT. OF THE NUMBERS AND
SOME GRAPHICS RELATED TO. I
THINK THAT YEAH THE QUESTION
YOU DOCTOR BROWN WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO MISS MORALIS. IF MR
MORALIS IS UNAVAILABLE SHE MAY
BE ON UTAH OR SHE MAY HAVE-
TECHNICAL ISSUES WE CAN MOVE ON
TO. A MISTER BUT ALSO. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW ARE A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL TO I'M
SUPPORT PICTURES DISEASE
MODELING AND THEN HAPPY TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS. I'M SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE A REQUEST FOR A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND INCUMBENTS ARE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. TO SUPPORT INSPECTIONS
DISEASE MODELING ACTIVITIES AS
PART OF THE URGENT COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC RESPONSE BY
INCREASING INTERNAL CAPACITY TO
CONDUCT OVERSEE AND UTILIZE
HIGH QUALITY DATA MODELING TO
INFORM PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
DECISIONS. TO HELP PARTICIPATE
IN A CUPBOARD NINETEEN MODELING
AND ANALYTICS CONSORTIUM. AS
EVERYONE'S WELL AWARE AT THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC WE AT THE
DEPARTMENT QUICKLY ESTABLISH
CORONAVIRUS BY MODELING TEAM.
AND THIS MODELING IS PLAYED A
VERY CRITICAL ROLE IN INFORMING
NUMEROUS PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
AND POLICIES. I'M SINCE THEN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT.
DEVELOPING LAUNCHED H.
CALIFORNIA COVER NINETEEN
MODELING AND ANALYTICS
CONSORTIUM IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY- WITH INPUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND THIS CONSORTIUM
WAS DEVELOPED TO REALLY.
CONSOLIDATE MODELING AND
ANALYTIC ACTIVITIES ACROSS THE
UC SYSTEM WHICH WILL BE USED TO
INFORM STATE POLICY DECISIONS
AND TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THE
REACH OF THE UC SYSTEM. WHICH
SPANS ACROSS NINE WC ACADEMIC
AND HEALTH CAMPUSES AND BRINGS
TOGETHER OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY INVESTIGATORS. WITH VERY
DIVERSE ACADEMIC AND TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE. THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY INTENDS TO LEVERAGE THE
COLLABORATIVE NATURE OF THIS
CONSORTIUM AND MEET THE URGENT
NEEDS OF THE KOBE NINETEEN
RESPONSE THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
SEEKS TO ADDED. A VERY MUCH
NEEDED CAPACITY. ORDER PART AND
HIRING DEDICATED STAFF MEMBER.
EXISTING STAFFING. MAINTAINED
THE- TO SERVICE THE CONSORTIUM
LEAD. ACTUALLY SURE WERE
EFFECTIVELY LEVERAGING OUR THIS
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PARKERS. AND SO THAT'S
REALLY JUST STARTED THIS
PROPOSAL IN SUMMARY IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THOSE. MISTER BONNER. WE
WILL. NOW MOVES ON TO MISTER
VIDAL. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
WHAT THE CITY PIZZA BROKER
QUALITY- WE OPPOSE ANY PC P.
REQUESTED ONE POSITION AND-
HUNTING FOR ONE UNDERSCORES
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ARE GOING THROUGH AFTER.
THE FIRST EMISSION REGULATIONS
FOR A PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT STOCKPILE TO ENSURE
AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF P. P. FOR
ALL HEALTH CARE TO SITUATE
CHRISTMAS DAY IT IS MANDATED BY
SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE. CDPH WILL
NEED TO WORK WITH THE CURRENT
OF THE- RELATIONS TO DETERMINE.
THE TYPE AND AMOUNT OF P. G.
BEING MAINTAINED BY THE
PROVIDER BASED ON THE TYPE AND
SIZE OF EACH PROVIDER. AS WELL
AS THE COMPOSITION OF HEALTH
CARE WORKERS IN THIS WORKFORCE-
IT IS REALLY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE HASN'T. THANK YOU SIR
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DOCTOR
WALKS IS ME TO SERRA BOSS. ONE
IF MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD TO
SEE YOU I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS SERRA
BOSTON I'M THE MADERA COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR. ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF JACKSON
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL CULTURE
STATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
LOCAL PERSPECTIVE ON COPING
NINETEEN RESPONSE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO DISCUSS THE
EROSION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO BE
MADE. IN PUBLIC HEALTH STAFFING
OF RESET AND RESOURCES SINCE
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE TRUST FOR
AMERICA'S HEALTH RECENT
ANALYSIS REPORTED THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. HAS BEEN
UNDER FUNDED BY FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS NATIONWIDE.
LOCALLY THE UNDERFUNDING OF
PUBLIC HEALTH MEANT LIMITED
CONTACT TRACING AND DISEASE
INVESTIGATION WORKFORCE.
LIMITED EPIDEMIOLOGISTS.
OUTDATED DATA SYSTEMS AND
REDUCED PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY CAPACITY AND LACK OF
UPDATE EQUIPMENT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE SERVING
A MUCH LARGER POPULATION TODAY
LESS LESS FUNDING AND STUFF AND
WE HAD PRIOR TO THE RECESSION
WHILE ALSO FACING GREATER
HEALTH INEQUITIES AND CRITICAL
ISSUES LIKE HOMELESSNESS AND
CLIMATE CHANGE CONTRIBUTING TO
MORE EXTREME WILDFIRES.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AGAIN
DUE TO LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN AND CONTINUE ESTATE OF
RAMPING UP CRITICAL ASPECTS OF
KOBE NINETEEN RESPONSE. CONTACT
TRACING INTO SEASON BEST
OCCASION TESTING EDUCATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO EVERY
SECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY AROUND
STATE GUIDANCE FOR PENSION
PLANS AN OUTBREAK MEDICATION.
AND NOW VACCINE ADMINISTRATION.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS LACK
ENOUGH CONTACT TRACERS AND
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS HOWEVER.
ARE ABLE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CONTACT TRACERS AND IF HE'S
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS WITH
CARES ACT FUNDING AND OTHER
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT CAME TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
MANY JURISDICTIONS THE STATE
ALSO SUPPORTED CONTACT TRACERS
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS BY
DEPLOYING STATE STAFF INTO
THESE JURISDICTIONS. WELL THE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING CAPACITY IS
TEMPORARY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS COULD BENEFIT FROM
RETAINING STAFF TO WORK ON
OTHER CRITICAL DISEASES LATER
ON SUCH AS STDS. AND OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS.
PROTESTING SOME JURISDICTIONS
ARE ABLE TO STAND UP TESTING
SITES USING FEDERAL CARES FUNDS
WHILE OTHERS WERE SUPPLMENTED.
COUNTY WE HOUSE BOTH STATE AND
LOCALLY FUNDED TESTING GIVING
US FLEXIBILITY WHETHER TESTING
SITE TO DEPLOY TO HIGH RISK LOW
ACCESS COMMUNITIES. AS THE
STATE CONTINUES TO EXPAND
TESTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
ACCESS ADDITIONAL TESTING
MODALITIES IN PHASES. INCLUDES
ACCESS TO TESTING KITS THAT ARE
SHIPPED TO VALENCIA BRANCH LAB
AND NEW MOBILE TESTING TEAMS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW COSTS
ARE STILL BEING INCURRED BY
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
CONTINUE EXISTING LOCALLY
FUNDED TEST SITES TO SHIP
TESTING KIT STUFF ONCE YOUR
BRANCH LAB. AND OR THE COST OF
LOCATION AND SECURITY FOR THE
STATE RUN SITES. LOCAL ALSO
WERE WITH CARE PROVIDERS
HOSPITALS LONG TERM HEALTH.
FACILITIES AND I'M SORRY
THROUGH OUR MEDICAL HEALTH
OPERATIONAL COORDINATOR OR THE
BALLPARK. TO COORDINATE RE
RECALL FOR FROM. TO VENTILATORS
TO HEALTH CARE STAFFING AS WELL
AS HELP WITH PATIENT MOVEMENT
DURING SEARCH TIME. OKAY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS MANAGE LOCAL
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPECTATIONS
WITH REGARDS TO STATE SECTOR
pEDUCATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO EVERY SECTOR OF
THE COMMUNITY WITH LOCAL MEDIA.
TO QUITE CORRECTLY APPLY STATE
PLANS AND EIGHT AND ALBERT
MEDICAID. THESE HAVE BEEN
FURTHER PIMARILY FUNDED
THROUGH CARE ACT AND LOCAL. FOR
AND LASTLY ON FEB ADMIN I'D
LIKE TO DOWN THE PART ON
VACCINE. AND HOW THIS ARGUED
SPEC. FIRST THE STATE ALLOCATES
A PORTION CAL. ALLOCATION TO
THE FOR. OF PHARMACY. I WOULD
CVS AND- ARE SO TO FAX. ONE
TERM CARE FOR. AND
PARTICIPATING JURISDICTIONS. A
STATE THEN ALLOCATES ABOUT PER
OF THE REMAINING ALLOCATION TO
WHAT THEY CALL AND SEE EASE OUR
MULTI COUNTY ENTITIES WHICH
INCLUDED STATE CORRECTIONS AS
WELL AS HEALTH SYSTEMS THAT ARE
LARGE LIKE DIGNITY KAISER AND
SUTTER. THE STATE PROVIDES THE
ALLOCATION TO THE M. C. DECIDE
HOW VACCINE WILL BE ADDED TO
THEIR ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE STATE ALLOCATES THE
OTHER 80% TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS THIS INCLUDES A
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND THREE
STUDY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
DECIDES HOW MUCH RETAIN OR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT CLINICS
OR HI IT'S WHAT WE CALL THEM
POINTS OF DISPENSING. AND HOW
TO ALLOCATE TO PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE JURISDICTION. WHILE
BALANCING THE SCARCITY ISSUE.
AS PART OF THE EFFORT TO RAMP
UP OPERATIONS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LEVERAGE
PARTNERSHIPS AIMED AT REACHING
Q. COMMUNITIES. IN THE STATE
ASKED LHD USED TO INCREASE
AREN'T SEXY VACCINATION QUICKLY
THE RESPONSE WAS SWIFT AND
EFFECTIVE. AND THEN THREE WEEKS
FOR EXAMPLE MADERA COUNTY
INCREASED VACCINATION PASTI
FROM A FEW HUNDRED PER WEEK TO
TWO THOUSAND VACCINATIONS
WEEKLY. WE HAVE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO SUSTAIN THIS PACE DUE
TO VACCINATION SHORTAGE WE DO
MAINTAIN THE CAPACITY. TO
PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
VACCINATION. WITH ADDITIONAL
VACCINE MADERA COULD CONTINUE
TO INCREASE CAPACITY WHILE
STILL PRIORITIZING HONORABLE
GROUPS. EQUITY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HOWEVER CURRENT
DATA ON VACCINE ADMINISTRATION
MAY NOT YET REFLECT AN
EQUITABLE ADMINISTRATION.
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
FOLLOWING THE STATE'S
VACCINATION PRIORITIZATION.
WHICH FIRST PRIORITIZE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND THE VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION WILL LIKELY THEN
ALIGN THIS POINT MORE AROUND
HEALTH CARE WORKER
DEMOGRAPHICS. HOWEVER S. LHD IS
MOVE INTO A PHASE ONE B. WE ARE
DEPLOYING VARIOUS STRATEGIES TO
TARGET VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND ARE LEANING ON PARTNERSHIPS
TO FURTHER SUPPORT EQUITY. BUT
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR AND NOW THE
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO USE MY TURN. LHD
IS ENCOURAGE THE STATES TO
PROVIDE NEEDED DOSES TO LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS SAID THAT
THE VACCINE SITES CAN RAMP UP
TO FULL CAPACITY. CONSULT WITH
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ON
VACCINE ALLOCATION THROUGHOUT
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
TRANSITION CURRENT PROVIDERS
INTO THE TGA PROVIDER NETWORK
WITH LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
INPUT SO THAT PROVIDERS THAT
CAN REACH VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS BUT THAT MAY NOT BE
CONSIDERED EFFICIENT BASED ON
VOLUME OUR PACE COULD CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THEY ARE TRUSTED. UNLESS
THEY PROVIDE THE FUNCTIONALITY
NEEDED FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS. AND AN
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE PROVIDED. I'VE BEEN ASKED
I'M TO PLEASE DESCRIBE WHAT IS
WORKS WELL AND WHAT HAS NOT
WORKED WELL IN TERMS OF THE
SHARED PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND THE STATE. BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE NAVIGATING THE
IMPACT OF THE DECLINE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAS
NOT BEEN EASY. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
MADE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
HAD MAINTAINS REGULAR
COMMUNICATION THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. THE STATE HAS ALSO
TAKEN SOME PROACTIVE STEPS TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES IN
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES SUCH AS
CREATING UNIFIED SUPPORT TEAMS
ARE CENTRAL VALLEY COUNTIES I
SEASON FINALE DESCRIBES. WE
RECOGNIZE THE PASTE AND MUCH
WE'RE ALL WORKING TO SAVE LIVES
AND THE TREND AMOUNT OF WORK
THE STATE IS DOING. HOWEVER
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MUST
BE PARTNERS IN SHAPING THE
POLICIES AND STRATEGIES BEING
ANNOUNCED. WE ALSO MUST HAVE
CRITICAL DETAILS TO ENSURE WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING APPROPRIATELY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AS POLICIES
CHANGE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
MUST IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE SHARED DECISION
MAKING TO BE ENHANCED AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND AT. SECOND
QUESTION READS FROM ALL SOURCES
HAVE COUNTIES HAD SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC AFFECTIVELY. AND THE
SIMPLE ANSWER IS NO. LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MET THE
CONTAINMENT WITHIN UNDER
RESOURCE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE NOT
ALWAYS HAD SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
WHICH IS WHY THE STATE HAS
SUPPLEMENTED CONTACT TRACING
AND TESTING EFFORTS LOCALLY.
RESPONDING IS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE IT IS HELP TO
INCREASE OUR STAFFING CAPACITY.
READ AND IT'S IN EQUIPMENT AS
NOT. A CROSS CAL LHD IS. TELL
AND TRIPLING AND SIZE RESPONSE
KOPET. NEWS STAFF ARE SOLD AS
AFFECT AS WELL TRAINED AND
EXPERIENCED PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF.
IN MADERA COUNTY WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FORTY SIX EXTRA HELP
TEMPORARY PEOPLE. THAT ARE
HELPING WITH KOVIN. THAT
REPRESENTS 30% OF OUR CURRENT-
DEPARTMENT WORK FORCE AND 77%
OF THE TEAM THAT'S DIRECTLY
RESPONDING COVET OR EXTRA HELP
SO ALL OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THAT THEY'VE ALL
BEEN WORKING IN PUBLIC HEALTH
FOR LESS THAN A YEAR. MANY OF
THE STAFF. ARE FOR CONTACT
TRACING AND DISEASE
INVESTIGATION. PRIOR TO COVERT
MADERA HAD THREE FULL TIME
STAFF POSITIONS FOR CONTACT
TRACING IT SEES INVESTIGATION.
THREE WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
INCREASE THIS TEAM TO MEET THE
NEED TO RECHECK OUR LARGEST
NUMBER DURING THE LAST SURGE
WHICH INCLUDED. TEN PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFF SIX COUNTY STAFF
REDIRECTED FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS EIGHT STATES STAFF
ASSIGNED TO MADERA. AND SIX
STAFF WE TRAIN FROM A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
CONTRACTED TO OUR REACHED A
FORMER KURDS. THIS TOTALS
THIRTY PEOPLE TEN TIMES THE
SIZE OF OUR PERMANENT TEAM.
WHEN THE PANDEMIC IS OVER
UNFORTUNATELY WITHOUT A NEW
ONGOING INVESTMENT THIS WILL GO
AWAY. QUESTION THREE HAVE SOME
COUNTIES BETTER OR WORSE THAN
OTHERS IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
TOOLS EXPERTISE EXTENT ARE
NEEDED TO PROTECT THEIR
RESIDENTS. IT IS FAIR TO SAY
THAT SOME HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HAVE HAD HAVE MORE OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAN OTHERS FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE SOME VERY SMALL
JURISDICTIONS. THAT MAY ONLY
HAVE A PART TIME EPIDEMIOLOGIST
AND MAYBE ONLY ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE AND MADERA COUNTY
AT THE BEGINNING OF MARCH WE
HAD SIX FULL TIME PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES AND THREE NURSE
INSURANCE FOR A POPULATION OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND. NOT ONLY WAS FUNDING
NEEDED- BUT HAVING TRAINS THE
WORKFORCE WITH EXPERTISE AND
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AS A
VITAL FOR SWIFT AND EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE. RESOURCES SUCH AS
VACCINES ACCESS TO TESTING PP
AND DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SAXENA
WAS ORIGINALLY ALLOCATED TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS HOWEVER MANY AND MULTI
COUNTY ENTITIES AND FEDERAL
PHARMACY PARTNERSHIP I'M
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE UNCLEAR AND SO WITH
INCOMPLETE DATA IT'S DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
ALLOCATION HAS BEEN EQUITABLE
TO DATE. AS VACCINATION
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IS COMPLETED
WE ANTICIPATE ALLOCATIONS WILL
REFLECT THE STATE
PRIORITIZATION FOR HIGH RISK
GROUPS. IDENTIFIED IN PHASE ONE
B. TIER ONE INCLUDING. AGE
SIXTY FIVE AND UP I MERGING SEA
SERVICES CHILD CARE WORKERS
EDUCATION. AND FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. NUMBER
FIVE WHAT ARE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY OUTSTANDING UNMET
NEEDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT
ARE SLOWING PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE ENDING OF THE PANDEMIC.
WHAT SEVERAL OUT OF THAT E. L.
C. FUNDING- ALSO REFERRED TO
AND THE NEXT QUESTION UP THERE
REALLY REMAINS ONE. ITEM THAT
IS. THE HIGHEST PRIORITY ON
MATCH WHICH IS MORE VEXING. AND
PREDICTABILITY OF VACCINE
ALLOCATION. WITHOUT
PREDICTABILITY OF WHAT'S COMING
UP WE ARE UNABLE TO REALLY DO
GOOD PLANNING ON THE GROUND IT
TAKES A LONGER LEAD TIME TO
EFFECTIVELY PLAN AND PROMOTE
OUR POINTS OF DISPENSING AS
WELL AS PLANNING FOR SECOND
DOSES. AND THE LAST QUESTION
HOW WILL COUNTY SPENDS THE
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED ONE POINT
TWO BILLION IN NEW FUNDING AND
HOW CAN THE STATE ALL COUNTIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SPENDING IT
EFFICIENTLY AND EQUITABLY.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
USE FUNDING TO CONTINUE TESTING
SITES CONTACT RAISING HIS
INVESTIGATION ALSO SUPPORT THE
RAMP OF THE VACCINES. MEASURES
ARE IN PLACE TO HOLD LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACCOUNTABLE
TO EQUITY. SUCH AS THE
POSITIVITY RATE AMONG CENSUS
TRACTS WITH A LOW SCORE ON THE
HEALTHY PLACES INDEX IN THE-
BOTTOM QUARTILE. I WILL
CERTAINLY ACCOUNT FOR AND
REPORT SPENDING TO SEE TEACHERS
ARE. IT'S IMPORTANT. TO HOLE
ALL TURN ACCOUNTABLE TO ECHO
JUST DISTRIBUTION OF FACTS. AS
WELL AS THE U. S. OF FUN SO.
ADDRESSING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS MULTI
COUNTY AND SHE'S LOCATIONS OF
FEDERAL SITES AS WELL AS THE
STATE AS WE ALL STRIVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MEET EQUITY. I ALSO
HAVE A MORE DETAILED LISTS THAT
I CAN PROVIDE WITH REGARDS TO.
COMMON EXPENSES THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISS BOSS
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THIS
PATRICK. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS I AM SEND
YOUR HEADACHE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
HAVE ABOUT TWO COME MY PRESENT-
I THINK YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF
THAT. M. IN ADDITION FOR THE
VIEWERS ARE WATCHING ON THIS
HANDOUT BE FOUND AT OUR WHICH
AT L. A. R. DI CA DOT. I AM IF
YOU I'M GOING AND MOVE TO ONE-
MY PRESENTATION WILL REALLY BE
FOCUS ON THE CO NINE. RESPOND
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
PUBLIC BUDGET INCLUDING THE
MONEY THAT. OUT TO LOOK PUBLIC
MEASURES FROM THE- I'M WHAT'S
REALLY YOU KNOW. IS HOW. IT IS
TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE CODE
NINETEEN RESPONSE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. PUBLIC
HEALTH JUST BY LOOKING AT THE
ANNUAL BUDGET- IN LARGE PART
THIS IS BECAUSE MINISTRATION
HAS RELIED VERY HEAVILY ON. A
WEAK YEAR. PRESSMAN'S AND IT'S
CLEAR FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELEASED IN JANUARY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONTINUE TO RELY ON THIS VERY
FLUID APPROACH- WE ALSO
ANTICIPATE THAT ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE AT MAYOR VISION SO MY
IT REMARKS TODAY IT WILL
ATTEMPT TO DESCRIBE THE PROCESS
SEES THAT THE ADMINISTRATION-
WILL LIKELY CONTINUE TO USE
OVER THE REMAINING PART OF THE-
I'M SORRY OVER THE REMAINING
CURRENT YEAR AS WELL AS- THOSE
THAT THE WILL EMPLOYEE. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. I WILL THEN GO
OVER SOME OF THE TOOLS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S DISPOSAL FOR
PRESSING ITS OWN GOALS AND
PRIORITIES IN LIGHT OF THIS
MORE SORT OF PIECEMEAL APPROACH
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN
BECAUSE- THIS INCREMENTAL
APPROACH BY THE ADMINISTRATION
REALLY REQUIRES THE LEGISLATURE
TO RESPOND QUICKLY TO VARIOUS
ACTIONS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE OFFER SOME
CRITERIA- THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN USE TO QUICKLY ASSESS THOSE
PROPOSED ACTIONS AND THEN I'LL
CLOSE WITH SOME ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. ONCE
THE STATE ENTERS SORT OF THE
RECOVERY PHASE OF THE CODED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SO I AM
PRETTY TO BE TWO OF THE HIM OUT-
AS I KNOW PRE. IF YOU JUST LOOK
AT THE ENACTED TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET IT REALLY
DOES NOT TELL THE WHOLE STORY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH'S RESPONSE TO CODE
NINETEEN. THEY MADE A NUMBER OF
KEY ADJUSTMENTS SINCE THE
BUDGET WAS ENACTED- INCLUDING
ALLOCATION OF A SIGNIFICANT ARE
GRANT FROM THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AS WELL AS SOME GENERAL FUND
FUND TRANSFERS- WHICH I'LL
DISCUSS THAT PROCESS MORE IN A
MINUTE. I AM SUMMIT THIS
FUNDING HAS SUPPORTED A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT INITIATIVES
INCLUDING OPENING THE STATE'S
VALENCIA BRANCH LAB- TO
INCREASE TESTING CAPACITY-
TURNING TO PAGE THREE
CONTRACTING WITH OPTUM SERVE
FOR TEST COLLECTION. FUNDING
INCREASE TESTING CAPACITY OF
OTHER- A LABS- OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS- AND FUNDING
IMPROVEMENTS TO A T. SYSTEMS-
AMONG OTHER INITIATIVES. I AM
SO THE GUY BUT PROPOSAL IN A
PER FOR THE- ANSWERED THE-
BUDGET THAT WAS RELEASED IN
JANUARY DID NOT INCLUDE A LOT
OF DETAILS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
APPROACH FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE CURRENT YEAR- AND IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE FOUR THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE SOME VERY
IMPORTANTISSUES FOR
CONSIDERATION. INCLUDING AS
OTHERS HAVE DISCUSSED THE
FUNDING AND MANAGEMENT OF
VACCINATION EFFORTS THE FUNDING
IN MANAGEMENT OF A SUSTAINED
AND EXPANDED TESTING EFFORTS
AND HOW TO SPEND A POTENTIAL
FUTURE FEDERAL FUNDS. SO THE
ADMINISTRATION- WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE TO RELY ON A MID YEAR
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS AND I'M
GOING TO QUICKLY GO THROUGH
THOSE PROCESS SEES SO THE FIRST
IS CONTROL SECTION TWENTY
BUDGET I'M SORRY BUDGET CONTROL
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT. THIS IS A
PROCESS THAT- OFTEN INCLUDED IN
THE ANNUAL BUDGET AND IT REALLY
GIVES THE ADMINISTRATION THE
ABILITY TO SPEND ON ANTICIPATED
FEDERAL FUNDS AND IT REQUIRES A
THIRTY DAY ADVANCE.
NOTIFICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE.
CONTROL ELEVEN POINT FIVE WAS A
NEW SET ADDED WITH THE ENACTED.
DIDN'T ACTED TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. AND THIS IS
SIMILAR TO CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT BUT IT WAS
SPECIFIC TO THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WAS PROVIDED- FROM
LEGISLATION PASSED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN MARCH AND
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS
I'M CONTROL SECTION WERE
REQUIRED ATTENDED VANCE
NOTIFICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE.
NEXT IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOR-
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS RELIED
ON FUNDING FROM THE STATE'S
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT ALSO KNOWN
AS TRIO. THIS IS SOMEBODY SEAT
SPECIAL FUNDS FOR ECONOMIC.
WHICH CAN BE AND CAN BE USED
DURING- A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY. I'M IMPORTANTLY IT'S
ONLY IT'S- ACTIVATED IN ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY
INCREMENTS AND IT'S ONLY
OPERATIONAL DURING THE- THREE
ONE FISCAL YEAR OR THE FISCAL
YEAR WHEN THE LAST RENEWAL I
TOOK PLACE SO IN THIS CASE IT'S
ONLY GOOD FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE CURRENT FISCAL. YEAR WHICH
ENDS JUNE THIRTIETH. AND
IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE THREE
AT IS IT ROOF STATUTE REQUIRES
THE ADMIN. TO KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN IT MAKES A
TRANSFER FROM THE SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES INTO
THE TRIO ACCOUNT BUT IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE. OF
THE ALLOCATIONS- MADE FRIENDS
RIO IT TO THE SPECIFIC-
DEPARTMENTS AND HOW THAT
FUNDING WILL BE USED. A FINAL-
THAT I WOULDN'T ABOUT THE
VARIOUS AUTHORITIES AVAILABLE
TO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SPENDING FUNDS IS THE FACT THAT
DURING DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY- STATUTE ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FOREGO USING.
THE FORMAL BIDDING PROCESS FOR
PUBLIC CONTRACTS SO JUST TO
NAME AN EXAMPLE THE CONTRACT-
THAT THE STATE ENTERED INTO
WITH PERKIN ELMER TO OPEN THE
VALENCIA BROWN SHOULD LAB- DID
WAS NOT ENTERED INTO USING A
BIDDING PROCESS. RIGHT NOW IF
YOU'D TO PAGE. SIX- MOVING ON
TO THE GUY BY PER. FOR ONE
TWENTY TWO. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
LACKED A DESCRIPTION OF THE
OVERALL CODE NINETEEN DID
MINISTRATIONS OVERALL COMMIT
NINETEEN. SPONSORED STRATEGY
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HOW THE PROPOSED BUDGET
WOULD SUPPORT THAT STRATEGY THE
PRIMARY KNOWN EXPENDITURE.
WOULD BE TO SUSTAIN OUT THE BOY
YOU BRING WHILE AND SO OTHER AT
ADD- AND. AS WELL AS SOME X. IN
OTHER TO. TOTALING ONE FOUR
BILL SO THAT APART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PLUS THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TOTAL POINT FOUR
BILLION SH IN MINISTRATION ALSO
ESTIMATES THAT ANOTHER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION WILL BE NEEDED.
FOR COVERT RESPONSE BUT IT HAS
NOT YET ALLOCATED- THAT FUNDING
TO SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS. THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO INDICATES A
CONTINUED RELIANCE ON MIDYEAR
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS VIA BUDGET
CONTROL SECTIONS SO IN ADDITION
TO CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
PROPOSES A NEW CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE. WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION
TO INCREASE OR DECREASE AMOUNTS
AVAILABLE TO SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENTS FOR COVERT RESPONSE
IT WOULD ALLOW TRANSFERS
BETWEEN AND AMONG THOSE
DEPARTMENTS AND IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE STATE TO SPEND.
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS. VERY
IMPORTANT WE THIS CALL SO DOES
NOT ANY NOTICE. OF THAT TO
LARGEST. ADMINISTRATION ALSO
PROPOSES CONTROL SECTIONAL
LEVIN POINT NINE TWO WHICH
WOULD EXTEND OF THE THREE- OF
SORTIES- THE ENTIRE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. BOTH OF
THESE WILL GIVE SIGNIFICANT
DISCRETION OVER SPENDING
DECISIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION- SO GIVEN THE
FACT THAT- IT WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION AND THE
FACT THAT WE'RE A YEAR INTO THE
CODE NINETEEN RESPONSE WE
SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
MORE SPECIFIC GUIDANCE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT ITS OWN
GOALS AND PRIORITIES FOR KOBE
NINETEEN RESPONSE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. SO
HE TO PAGE. NINE SOME OF THE
TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THE
LARGEST FOR A THESE GOAL AND-
SENDING ONE TO THE ADMIN.
WESTING OR INFORMATION ABOUT
SUB COMMITTEE HERE SUCH AS THE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED TODAY BY THE- OF
REQUEST OF THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE. INCLUDING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET ACT. IN REQUIRING ROBUST
FOLLOW UP REPORTING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- IN ITS- THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN REQUEST
MORE ROBUST REPORTING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT RESPONDS
TO IT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
NOTIFICATIONS OF MID BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS. NO JUST EXAMPLES
OF WHAT SOME OF THE PRIORITIES
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
EXPRESS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
THOSE LISTED ON PAGE NINE I
WON'T GO THROUGH ALL OF THOSE
BUT IT MAY INCLUDE ENSURING
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF AN ACCESS TO
VACCINES. IT COULD BE- ENSURING
THAT THE STATE HAS AN ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN SURVEILLANCE
PLAN AFTER CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- IT COULD BE TURNING
TO PAGE TEN. CURRENT THE
MINUTES FOR MORE MODELING OF
THE NEED FOR PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
NEW COVER NINETEEN VARIANTS
THAT ARE SPREADING ACROSS THE
STATE. PROCESS RELATED GOAL
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION MAY
WISH TO EXPRESS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. NOT MAKING
MODIFICATIONS TO SOME OF THE
CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE
PROPOSALS- FIRST. FOR ELEVEN
POINT NINE ONE REQUIRING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY
NOTIFYING THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
IT INTENDS TO- MAKE CHANGES
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS. I'M IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE COULD
POTENTIALLY- REQUIRED THAT THE
CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE MORE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION WHAT IT DOES MAKE A
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE A CLEAR
DESCRIPTION OF THE PROBLEM THAT
THE FUNDING IS INTENDING TO
ADDRESS AND HOW IT WILL ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM. GIVEN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
RESPOND QUICKLY TO PROPOSALS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON PAGE
TEN WE ALSO OFFER SOME KEY
CRITERIA THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN USE WHILE ASSESSING THESE
PROPOSALS. SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER THE RELEVANCE AND
IMPORTANCE I'VE BEEN GIVEN A
PROPOSAL SO FOR EXAMPLE WHAT'S
THE GOAL OF THE INTENDED ACTION.
HOW DOES THAT GOAL FIT INTO THE
STATE'S OVERALL CODE NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND STRATEGY. TURNING
TO PAGE AWAY THE TEN FOR OF THE
PROPOSED ACTION WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT- SO FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
EVIDENCE HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDED THAT THIS- POST ACTION
WILL ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE WHAT
OTHER ALTERNATIVES TO CONSIDER
WHAT ARE THE RANGE OF POSSIBLE
HAVE POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES. FEASIBILITY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CRITERIA IN TERMS OF-
IS THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
IS MORE STAFFING NEEDED. IT HAS
THE DEPARTMENT- IF LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS WILL BE
EXPECTED TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROPOSAL HAS THAT BEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR IN IN THE
PROPOSAL WHAT'S THE TIME LINE
AND IS THAT TIMELINE FEASIBLE.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER HOW WITH
THE PROPOSED ACTION AFFECT-
DIFFERENT. GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE WHAT IT WHAT IT WORKS AND
DISPARITIES ARE IMPROVE
DISPARITIES. ON PAGE TWELVE A
FINAL CRITERION WOULD BE
FUNDING. ISSUES RELATED TO
FUNDING AND CONTRACTING SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT ARE THE FUNDING
SOURCES PROPOSED- AND IT FOR
EXAMPLE IF IT'S FEDERAL FUNDING
DOES THE PROPOSAL INCLUDE
ELIGIBLE USES OF FEDERAL
FUNDING- IF IT'S STATE FUNDED
HOW WITH THE EFFORTS COMPLEMENT
FEDERAL EFFORTS. AND THEN
FINALLY ON ON CONTRACTING. AND
HOW MANY COMPANIES OR
APPROACHES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER FOR THE
PROPOSED ACTION AND IS THE
VENDOR THAT THEY ARE INTENDING
TO SELECT THE BEST VALUE FOR
THE STATE. NOW FOR. IF YOU WERE
TO PAGE THIRD WE A FEW FOR.
CONSIDER AS THE STATE- ONE THE
STATE MOVES INTO THEIR INCOME
PHASE OF THE PANDA. SO THE
FIRST IS TO A- CODE NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH. NEEDS BOTH NEAR
AND LONGER TERM. SO COMMON
EIGHTEEN COULD A PROBLEM FOR
SOME TIME AND WE WOULD NOTE
THAT- BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DEVELOP A NUMBER OF RESOURCES.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE THAT OULD BE
LEVERAGED IN THE NEAR TERM AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN ON AN ONGOING
BASIS SO THIS COULD THIS
INCLUDES OUR PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
CAPACITY INCLUDING THE NEW
VALENCIA. BRANCH PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE AS WAS MADE- AS BUYER
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CAN- SOME
OF THE VERY RESEARCH PARTNERS.
IN DATA SURE AGREE AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE I. T. SYSTEM. A
MERGER WE READ. THAT THE JUST
OUR THE ADMIN ABOUT ITS FOR
MAINTAIN COVERT NINETEEN. COULD
PASS OVER THE NEXT YEARS. A
SECOND KEY ISSUE FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IS TO
OF FIND OUT WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE BEEN
DEFERRED AS THE FOCUS HAS
REALLY NEEDED TO BE ON COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE. SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ASK SUCH QUESTIONS AS WHICH
RESPOND RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE
BEEN DEFERRED IN WHAT WOULD BE%
NEEDED TO RECOVER IN THOSE
AREAS. FINALLY WE- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. CONSIDER FINDING
AN AFTER ACTION REVIEW TO LEARN
FROM THE PANDEMIC. AS WE ALL
KNOW THE COVER NINETEEN KADAMPA
PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PROBLEMS INCLUDING
I'M NOT AMONG OTHERS I UNDER
RESOURCE STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE OUTDATED
IT SYSTEMS SIGNIFICANT RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
COORDINATION PROBLEMS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH GOVERNANCE. AND
INADEQUACIES IN OUR HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. THERE ARE OF
STUDIES CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSIDERATION ONE IS IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY THAT WOULD BE FOCUSED
ON. LOOKING AT DOING A
RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS- FOCUSED
ON EQUITY THERE'S ANOTHER
ASSEMBLY BILL THAT PROPOSES AN
ASSESSMENT OF LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE A COMPREHENSIVE AFTER
ACTION REVIEW- IN THIS REVIEW
REALLY SHOULD ASSESS WHAT WENT
WELL AND WHAT DID NOT GO SO
WELL WITH THE STATE'S RESPONSE
AND IT SHOULD. SERVE AS A BASIS
FOR REMEDIATING- THE STRUCTURAL
ISSUES IDENTIFIED- WE SUGGEST
THAT THELEGISLATURE COULD USE
SOME OF THE ONE TIME WINDFALL
THAT'S EXPECTED. I IN THE NEXT
YEAR FROM A BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE TO FUND THE STUDY.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY FOR
ALL OF YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MR BURKE. I WILL NOW BRING
IT BACK TO THE CMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE-
VICE CHAIR OF BUDGET ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG FOLLOWED BY. MEMBER
FRAZIER. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I FIRST WANT TO STORE
WITH- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR FROM THE DAY- I'M
TRYING TO I'M I'M I'VE GOT TO
SCENARIOS ARE TO TWO WORLD THAT
I'M A VERY TO GET WELL. THE
WORLD THAT YOU LIVE. AND THE
WORLD AS HE P. IN SO FROM FIRST.
DO YOU IN REAL TIME. OR WEEKLY
OR- I GUESS IT WOULD MAKE MAYBE
CAN TELL ME HOW OFF DO YOU GET
YOUR ALLOCATIONS INFORMATION OF
ALLOCATIONS DO YOU KNOW. I'M
DOSES OF ARE. INTO YOUR CAL.
AND YOU KNOW HOW VACCINE ARE
BEING ADMINISTERED. ON A DAILY
BASIS. WE RECEIVED A
NOTIFICATION OF ALLOCATION.
TWICE WEEKLY- I'M AT THIS POINT
IT IT'S STILL ALLOCATED IT
BASED ON FIRST DIBS ISN'T
SECOND DOSES MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT WE WILL TRANSITION TO A
SINGLE OCCASION AND IT DOES IS
IT DOES RIGHT NOW WE'RE GETTING
IT. ON TUESDAYS AND ON SUNDAYS
SO IT'S BROKEN INTO PIECES- AND
THAT IS OUR ALLOCATION FOR THE
WEEK. AND WE PLAN BASED ON THAT
NOTIFICATION BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INDICATION OF WHAT NEXT
WEEK'S ALLOCATION IS GOING TO
BE. THIS WEEK BY WEEK- AND DOES
THAT ALLOCATION INCLUDE- THE
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL HOSPITALS
THAT YOU MENTIONED OR WHAT'S
GOING TO CVS AND WALGREENS. NO
IT DOES NOT THAT IS JUST THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
ALLOCATION WE DON'T SEE THE
ALLOCATIONS YEAH GO TO THE
PHARMACY PARTNERSHIP OR MULTI
COUNTY ENTITIES. THERE ARE
THREE SO AND THIS IS CORRELATED
I'M TRYING TO COOPERATE OF
COURSE WHAT WHAT YOUR
EXPERIENCES WITH WHAT HAPPENS
IN KERN COUNTY SO THERE ARE
THREE BUCKETS OF VACCINES THAT
ARE COMING INTO YOUR COUNTY AND
TO KERN COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES. AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE
A WAY TO ANALYZE. ALL OF IT
TOGETHER. THAT'S CORRECT. AND I
KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OUT THEY JUST
RELEASED THEIR DASHBOARD IN
TERMS OF VACCINES. VACCINES
BEING ADMINISTERED IS THERE A
WAY FOR YOU TO VERIFY THAT THE
DATA THAT'S ON THAT DASHBOARD
TO THE PUBLIC AND WHAT YOU
KNOW. IS BEING ADMINISTERED BY
YOUR CLINICS AND- AND
INDIVIDUALS IN YOUR COUNTY. IN
THIS LAST WEEK WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WHICH THEY HAVE SENT TO US
THE DATA THAT THEY HAVE- FOR-
ALL OF THE ENTITIES THAT ARE
PROVIDERS THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ALLOCATE TO. US SO
NOT THE PHARMACY PARTNERSHIP
AND NOT THE MULTI COUNTY
ENTITIES BUT WE ALLOCATED OUT
TO OTHER LIKE FQHCS AND
HOSPITAL AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS LET'S SAY. AND SO THEY
PROVIDED US WHAT THEY HAVE IN
TERMS OF DATA AND WORK IN THE
MIDDLE OF A RECONCILIATION
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DATA THAT THEY SEE. IS WHAT'S
pISSUES AND THINGS THAT ARE
BEING RESOLVED CURRENTLY. OCCUR
SO I GUESS HE ANSWERED MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WHICH IS THE
DATA DOESN'T. TECHNICALLY
CORLEY AT THE MOMENT. WHERE YOU
HAVE THE NUMBERS YOU HAVE ARE
NOT EXACTLY THE NUMBERS ON THE
DASHBOARD THEY DON'T MATCH UP.
CORRECT WE'RE RECONCILING THAT
RIGHT NOW WITH THE STATE. OKAY
AND- SO I GUESS MAYBE IS A BIG
FOR THE FOUR OR FOUR C. PH N.
AND ANYONE ANSWER THIS QUESTION
I GUESS IS. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHAIR
TODAY THAT WHEN SOMEONE GETS
VACCINATED THAT INFORMATION HAS
TO BE UPLOADED. INTO THE
COMPACT SYSTEM. WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN YES. AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE COMPLIANT WITH
THAT THERE ARE SOME PROVIDERS.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH THAT
REQUIREMENT. AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE CONCERNS OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IS SOME OF THE
PROVIDERS THAT REACH OUT TO
VERY SPECIFIC VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. HOUSING CHALLENGES
WITH REGARDS TO THE DATA SIDE
OF THINGS AND SO IT IT EQUITY
AND EFFICIENCY MAY NOT. REALLY
OVERLAP VERY WELL IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE IF WE'RE
GOING STRICTLY FOR LOTS AND
LOTS OF VACCINE OUT THE DOOR
AND GREAT DATA TRANSPARENCY.
THAT'S IDEAL BUT I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE TRAINING AN
ONBOARDING WITH PROVIDERS THAT
SPECIFICALLY REACH OUT TO
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SO THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS WELL. FOR WHAT
WOULD BE THAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
SOLUTION THERE I MEAN IF
BECAUSE OF COURSE. I MEAN MY
PARENTS GOT THEIR FIRST DOSE
AND SO I WOULD IF THEY LOSE
THEIR CARD I WOULD WANT THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA. IS
CORRECT WHEN THEY GO BACK TO
MAKE SURE THEY GET THE RIGHT
BACKS IN THE SECOND TIME SO.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT QUESTION
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE DATA IS ACCURATE. AND PUT
IN ON A TIMELY BASIS SO THAT
YOU CAN SEE THINGS IN REAL
TIME. WE CAN SEE THINGS IN REAL
TIME AND CDPH CAN SEE THINGS IN
REAL TIME. SO WHAT WOULD BE A
POSSIBLE SOLUTION. WELL I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AS
LONG AS IT INDIVIDUAL IS
RETURNING TO THE SAME PROVIDER.
THAT PROVIDER WILL HAVE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR FIRST
DOSE FOR SECOND DOSES. SO THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT DATA ACCURACY
AND TRANSPARENCY IN THE STATE
SYSTEM. AND WE AGREE IT IT
NEEDS TO BE ACCURATE AND NEEDS
TO BE TIMELY. WHAT WE RECOMMEND
IS. REALLY WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO
IDENTIFY THOSE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT FOR PROVIDING
VACCINE EQUITY. WHAT WHAT ALSO
NEED SUPPORT WITH REGARDS TO
THE DATA ENTRY. AND ACCURACY ON
THAT SIDE AND THAT MIGHT TAKE
SOME TIME. WE DON'T WANT TO
LOSE THOSE. IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDING VACCINE ON THE
GROUND. TWO GLOBAL POPULATIONS.
BUT NEED TO ONBOARD THEM
APPROPRIATELY. HOW KERN. AND
THEN I GO TO CVS AS A SINCE I
HAVE. THIS IS A I HAVE YOU IN
TERMS OF YOU YOU MAY A STATE.
THAT HE WOULD- PREFERRED SHARE
DECISION MAKING- COULD YOU GIVE
AN EXAMPLE OF WHEN A WHERE THEY
WAS A CHAIRED MAKING A ONE THAT
COULD HAVE IMPROVE- I DON'T PUT
ON THE SPOT I'M JUST TRYING TO
INTERNET WE JUST WANTED TO IT
MAY I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT- I'M PRESENTING IT
ACCURATELY. I THINK ONE EXAMPLE
IS- THE THIRD PARTY- I THINK
THE THAT HAS BEEN MIXED. UP
THERE DETERMINATION TO HAVE A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WAS A
DECISION THAT WAS MADE. AND
BROUGHT AS A MAY DECISION TO
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
WE RAISE OUR CONCERNS WITH
REGARDS TO THAT AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
TO WORK THROUGH THAT ISSUE-
THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF. A
DECISION FULLY COMPLY DONE.
WITHOUT OUR INPUT PRIOR TO
DECISION BEING MADE. I
APPRECIATE IF THIS IS. IF
DOCTOR PAN OR PERCEIVED IS
AVAILABLE. I GUESS MAYBE. HOW
WOULD YOU ADDRESS THOSE CAN. BY
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER FOR
MADERA. SORRY I DON'T KNOW
MIDDLETOWN ERNEST FINELLI MAY
BE ON. FIVE HI THIS IS ANOTHER.
I'M NOT SURE. BUT. OKAY IS
FIRST OFF ON THE OF THE WINDOWS
OF THE A MAX I THINK THAT'S
WHAT. SITUATION AND WHICH WE
WERE ON THE GOVERNMENT TO UP
OUR- AND WE DON'T GET ANY MORE
ON UNTIL WE SEE ALLOCATE WE-
WORD OF TO GET LITTLE BIT OF
INSIGHT ABOUT LEVEL ON BACK
COMING HOME AND SO YEAH I THINK
I A QUESTION FOR. PART AND OF
HOW DO WE GET INFO ON TO WHAT
COMING AND SO THAT WE CAN SHARE
THAT WITH OUR LOCAL. I'M I
THINK THAT WE HAVE TRIED OUR
BEST TO- BRING IN OUR LOCAL BUT
I THINK THAT- YEAH THEY ARE
RIGHT AND NOT SOMETIME WE MOVE
QUICKLY THE SOMETHING THAT. WE
DON'T SHARE AS MUCH- AND GET AS
MUCH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
AND I THINK WE'RE WE'RE ON THE
WE BY ABOUT IN THE FUTURE. AS
OUR ANOTHER CAR. I STILL
DOESN'T SO THEY ACTUALLY THAT'S
A GREAT TRANSIT TO. MY MIGHT
SAID OF QUESTIONS FOR PH. SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE VACCINE CAN.
SUPPLY SO FOR WHAT DOES INTO
THIS CAN. THEN HOW. HE TO TERM.
HOW MANY DOES IT COUNTY.
RECEIVES A THERE A FOR. THAT
USES. BASED ON TO BASED ON
PUBLIC SIZE. BASED ON. CAPACITY
MAIN WHAT ARE THE INFO AND WHAT
DO YOU UP WITH THAT EXACT
NUMBER. SURE AND DOES CHANGE
OVER TIME SO WE REALLY WILL AT
WHAT IS THE THAT WERE TRYING TO
FAX A UP THE TIME THAT WE THE
EARLY DAYS WHERE. WE WERE DOING
ON PAGE ONE EIGHT WAS REALLY
FUN ON THE HEALTH WORKER. AND
SO AND LONG CARE AND- REALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT PERCENT OF
THOSE WERE IN EACH COUNTY OF
BUT BASIC FOR THE FARM. WE DID
CHAIRED BY AIM FOR WITH THE
COUNTY IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
LOCAL. CARE- HOW MANY HELP
WORKERS FOR BOTH IN CASE- I DO
UNDER THAT OTHER FOR COUNTY IS
AND HER OF P. WORKING IN ONE
COUNTY WE AND I COUNTY VOTING
FOR YOU KNOW OUR HARD. BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE AN OP. FOR SHERIFF
TO WAY AND THOSE NUMBERS. AS WE
MOVE TO PHASE ONE BEING- WE ARE.
TO SHIP THAT- FORMING. I WE
TAKE IN ACCOUNT THE- FOR
STARTING WITH. SEVENTY YEAR OLD
AN OLD. AND THEN IN COURT THE
TO BY YEAR OLDER AND THEN MOVE
TOWARD SOME OF THE- POPULATE SO
I THINK IT ALWAYS POPULAR. OF
PROPORTION OF PARTY GIRL WITHIN
THE COUNTY SO THAT WE HAVE
OFTEN SHARED DATA COUNTY BUT-
TO- OF TECH ASSISTANCE AND
GOING THE NUMBER SO THAT CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND. WHY THEY ARE
GETTING THE ALLOCATE THAT THERE
GETTING. SO ARE THOSE NUMBERS
FROM THE CENSUS DATA OR DO YOU.
THOSE NUMBER ARE AT THE DESK
PROVIDE YOU THOSE NUMBERS OR
YOU. DO YOU HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
AND GIVE THEM THAT COUNTY. THE
COMMITTEE OR THE CHAIRED WITH
THAT THAT THAT THE FORMULA FOR
THAT. YEAH WE- IS THAT CHANGING
FORMULA FOR WE CAN- TELL YOU
LIKE WHAT AT WHAT POINT WE
CHANGED THE FORMULA AND WHAT WE
CHANGED IT TO COVER HAS CHANGED
SEVERAL TIMES AS YOU MOVE
THROUGH THE TEARS ARE AS WE
MOVE THROUGH. AS YOU ADD
ADDITIONAL ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS
THAT FORMULA BEGINS TO ADJUST
CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY AND IN
TERMS OF THE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
DO YOU HAVE A SAY S. C. PH AND
WHERE. THOSE SUPPLIES WHERE
THEY GET DISTRIBUTED OR DOES.
THAT THE COUNTY DO THEY GOTTA
SAY OR IS THE SYSTEM DETERMINE
WHERE THE DOSES GO. DO NOT GET
A SAY- IT IS- CDPH IN
COORDINATION WITH BY
MINISTRATION WHO DETERMINES
WHAT PERCENTAGE GOES TO THAT
I'M FEES. OKAY THE CDPH
DETERMINES THAT ALLOCATION FROM
THE SYSTEM. I'M IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE MINISTRY.
SO THEN WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT. ASSESSMENT TO THE
COUNTIES BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO
BE THE MISSING PIECE AND WHAT
GOES INTO EACH CATEGORY THAT
REPORTING THAT ON TO OUR-
PUBLIC WEBSITE SO THAT YOU CAN
TELL THE TOTAL DOSE IS GOING TO
EACH AND SEE WHETHER THAT'S A
STATE OR A MULTI COUNTY. MC I
THINK WHERE IT BECOMES
CHALLENGING AND WE'RE WORKING
ON IS HOW MANY DOSES GET
ADMINISTERED IN EACH COUNTY
THAT PROGRAM C. E. SERVICES AND
SO THAT'S THE DATA THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK ON BUT CHINESE
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT. WHAT BENEFIT EACH MCD
PROVIDES TO THEIR JURISDICTIONS
OKAY SO I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO COMPARE
WITH THE MADERA PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS HAVE A SHE WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW. THE OTHER THREE
BUCKETS HELLO I THINK SHE WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW IS HOW MANY DOSES
ARE PROVIDED TO MADERA COUNTY
FROM THE M. C. E. I'M NOT IT'S
NOT YEP AND SHARE- THAT HAS A
MAJOR. OKAY WITH THAT SURE THAT
THE OR- WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
DATA AND TRYING TO GIVE MORE
DIRECTION SO THAT WE ASWE MOVE
ON INTO THE FUTURE THAT WE GET
BACK TRANSPARENCY OF DATA SO
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. NOT
ONLY THE DOSES THAT THEY'RE
ADMINISTERING OR ALLOCATING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT ALSO THE
LAW TO BEING BROUGHT INTO ON
THAT COMMUNITY OR THAT COUNTY
FROM- BMC'S. OKAY SO SEVEN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG AND IT
IS WHAT I UNDERSTAND NOW WHAT
I'M TOLD IS THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DASHBOARD THAT YOU'VE
THAT IS NOW EXTERNAL. THAT WE
CAN SEE THE NUMBER OF DOSES
BEING ADMINISTERED DOES THAT
INCLUDE. THE THREE BUCKETS THAT
WAS OUTLINED ITS THEY COUNTY
ALLOCATION THAT MULTIPLIES
SECTIONAL AND THE CVS WALGREENS
AND THE PHARMACY PARTNERSHIPS
THAT IS ALL INCLUDED ALL PUBLIC
SITE THAT IS ALL INCLUDED IN
THE DASHBOARD GAS OKAY BUT THE
KEY. SAYS WIRES AND THE
COUNTIES THE PART COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICES THEY DON'T THEY
SEE THAT NUMBER BUT THEY DON'T
SEE THE- THE THREE THEY DON'T
SEE A BROKEN OUT INTO THREE
WAYS THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO BREAK
THAT OUT INTO. EACH COUNTY FOR
THE MC IS RIGHT NOW. OKAY YOU
MAY ASK WHY THAT IS I AM JUST
CURIOUS I JUST I DON'T I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW SO I JUST. THINK
THEY'RE WORKING WITH BMC'S TO
PROVIDE BETTER DATA- IN TERMS
OF WHERE EXACTLY THEY'RE
ADMINISTERING THOSE DOSES
ACROSS THEIR MANY. FACILITIES
IN THE STATE. OKAY AND SOME OF
IT AS A LOT OF. AS BY I'M IN.
THERE ARE SOME. CODE ON SOME
ISSUE ARE. PEOPLE USING
MULTIPLE CODE OR MULTI ORGAN-
THAN ONE. FOR THE WHICH MAKE IT
HARD TO PARTICULARLY. NOT THOSE
DIRECTLY BUT WE ARE DOING A LOT
OF WORK RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS AND WITH THE
DATA TEAM AT THE STATE. TO
REALLY MAPPED OUT ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CODE SO THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER PICTURE AND
HOPING TO HAVE THAT VERY SOON.
OKAY I THINK THAT I THINK THE
COMMITTEE WOULD WOULD LIKE THAT
TO SEE THAT INFORMATION AS WELL
SO IF THAT COULD DIFFERENCE
PROVIDED- AND I HAVE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS. MISTER JACK- IN
TERMS OF. SO FORGET MY SOME. BY
SAID. IN TERMS OF THAT. THE
AMOUNT OF DOES IS BEING
ADMINISTERED. IF THE DATA
EVENTUALLY ANY WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A PLUS OR MINUS A
DAY OR TWO IF ALL OF THE
INFORMATION IS UPLOADED INTO
THE COMPACT SYSTEM WHY COULDN'T
I WOULDN'T WHY COULDN'T YOU
JUST PULL THE COUNTY DATA THE
NUMBER OF VACCINES BEING
ADMINISTERED IN EACH COUNTY AND
GIVE IT TO THE COUNTIES FOR
THEM. TO VERIFY OR THAT OR THE
ARE THERE MULTIPLE INPUTS INTO
THE COMPACT SYSTEM THAT
PREVENTS THAT FROM HAPPENING IS
A COMPLEX SYSTEM THAT IS A
MYERS ANY HAS TO BE 100%
ACCURATE. YEAH THERE ARE
MULTIPLE DATA SYSTEM ABOUT PULL
DIFFERENT PIECES OF DATA ABOUT
HAVE TO BE BROUGHT TOGETHER SO
THERE'S THAT CARE DATA WHICH
SHOWED BE ADMINISTERED. DOSE
SAYS THERE'S ANOTHER SYSTEM
THAT SHOWS THE SHIP DOES MOVE
BEARS. ON ANOTHER. SYSTEM THAT
SHOWS THE INVENTORY OF WALK ON
HAND AND EACH PROVIDERS PM VERY
TO LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
AND BECAUSE OUR PHONES ARE A
MULTITUDE OF SYSTEMS THAT
INFORMATION HAS TO BE BROUGHT
TOGETHER- AND WE ARE SHARING
THAT WITH THE COUNTIES NOW AND
THAT IS. WHAT WE'RE I'M USING
TO REALLY CLEAN UP THAT DATA
AND I THINK OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS. WE'VE GOTTEN
PRETTY FAR IN TERMS OF THE ORG
CODES MATCHING AND REALLY.
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE GOT TO
CLEAN THAT UP SO THAT WE CAN
INDEED PROVIDE. JUST WHAT
PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR. AND HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE TO CLEAN
CLEAN UP THE- IT TAKEN OUT
WHILE I'M IN ITS FIRST IN
BRINGING ALL THAT DATA FROM THE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS INTO ONE
PLACE WHICH WE'VE NOW DONE- AND
THEN IT REALLY IS A PROCESS OF
THOUSANDS OF CODES IN MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS AND BRINGING THEM
TOGETHER SO. YOU KNOW WE WISH
IT COULD BE FASTER BUT WE THINK
WE ARE ALMOST THERE. AND I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE DOES
THIS EXIST FOR OTHER. DISEASES
AND DATA THAT'S COLLECTED FROM
OTHER DISEASES AND OTHER
VACCINES. I DON'T THINK THAT
THE MAGNITUDE OF THEIR FOR
OTHER VACCINES OF THE CARE
SYSTEM REALLY DOES WORK FOR
CHILDHOOD VACCINES AND YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
AN ISSUE. I THINK WE HAVE. SOME
FOLKS HAVE SAID IN THIS HEARING
YEAH THE SYSTEMS WEREN'T
DESIGNED TO DO WHAT WE'RE
ASKING THEM TO DO IN THIS
PANDEMIC AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
LEARNING. ABOUT HOW TO CREATE
SYSTEMS WITH NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT COULD BRING UP INTO THE
FUTURE OKAY AND THEN JUST. SO
THAT WHEN THE LA DODGERS
STADIUM AND PACO PARK AND CAL
EXPO FAIRGROUNDS WHEN THOSE
SITES ARE LAUNCHED- OR BEING
ARE I DOUBT THAT A LARGE ARE
THEY PART OF THE COUNTY ALLEN.
ALLOTMENT OR THEY SEPARATE ON
TOP OF WHAT THE COUNTY GETS BI
WEEKLY. I THINK IT UPON US. IS
SO OF THE FEDERAL SITES BETTER
COMING IN THROUGH FEMA WILL
BRING THEIR OWN DOSES- AND-
THAT ARE ON TOP OF WHAT THE
COUNTIES ARE GETTING. IN OTHER
CASES WE HAVE- RELIED ON A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY AND
USING SOME OF THE COUNTY
ALLOCATIONS. AND SOMETIMES THEY
ARE WITH PROVIDERS OR ENTITIES
THAT ARE RUNNING SOME OF THOSE
SITES AND RELYING ON THE-
ALLEGATIONS THAT THEY RECEIVED
SO IT REALLY IS A MAX. OKAY AND
MY LAST QUESTION IS AND I HOPE
YOU CAN JUST PROVIDE SOME BIG
JUST CLARITY ON THIS. ARE WE
AND ONE B. I WE'VE ACTION
ADDING ONE BE IN CALIFORNIA AT
THE WEBSITE. A CITY BASED
WEBSITE SAYS THAT WE ARE IN ONE
B. AND THEN BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CDPH GUIDANCE IT SAYS THE
PRIORITIZE ONE A. AND SIXTY
FIVE AND UP FIRST AND SAID
THAT. MY COUNTY AND I WON'T
SPEAK FOR OTHER COUNTIES.
THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S SOME
BUT THERE'S SOME CONFUSION.
BECAUSE THOSE AND ONE BE WANT
TO GO AND GET VACCINATED. SO IS
IT ARE WE CAN CURRENTLY
VACCINATING ONE B. NOW OR IS IT
A WE PRIORITIZE IN ONE DAY AND
SIXTY FIVE IN A- AND THEN WAIT
AND WAITING FOR. ONE BEAD
BUYING SUPPLIES. ONE B. IS
ELIGIBLE TO BE VACCINATED RIGHT
NOW- WE'RE STANDING KNEELING TO
FINISH BLOCKS AND ENDING ON A-
AND COUNTIES ARE IN SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT PLACES IN TERMS OF
HOW FAR THEY'VE GOTTEN INTO THE
ONE BE ON MAXIMIZATION
SEPTEMBER FOCUSING ON YEAH BUT
IT'S NOT THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
SO SIXTY FIVE AN OPT AND THE
THREE SECTORS ARE ELIGIBLE AT
THE SAME TIME. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE SHORTAGE OF VACCINES YOU
CAN'T DO EVERYBODY OUT LONG
TERM SO THEY ARE- PRIORITIZING-
SOMETIMES THE SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
AND OLDER AND THEN MOVING TO
THE SIXTY FIVE AND MOVING
ACROSS THE SECTOR SO I THINK
THAT THEY'RE ALL ELIGIBLE THE
QUESTION IS GIVEN THE LIMITED
VACCINE HOW MUCH CAN THEY- YEAH
REALLY- HANDLE IN TERMS OF.
REALLY HAVING THE SITE DELIVER
THE. VACCINE TO THE APPROPRIATE
GROUPS.SO BOTH ARE CORRECT SO
THE COUNTIES ARE DOING THEY CAN
CURRENTLY THEY'RE RIGHT AND
THEY CAN IS THERE PRIVATIZING
AND WAITING ALL RIGHT. WHY I
THINK WE'RE WHAT I'M SAYING IS
EVERYBODY IS L. A. AND ONE B.
TIER ONE THAT INCLUDES THE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS AND OLDER AS
WELL AS THE THREE SECTORS. AND
SO HOW THE COUNTIES ARE SUB
PRIORITIZING TO ADDRESS THAT
GIVEN THE NUMBERS THAT THEY
HAVE IN EACH OF THOSE
POPULATIONS MAY VARY A LITTLE
BIT. AND SO THE TIMING MAY VARY
BUT THE GROUP IS STILL ELIGIBLE
ACROSS THE STATE. OKAY I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU
ANSWERING THOSE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THE
GENERALLY THIS IS GONNA BE
ADDRESSED TO THE WHOLE PANEL
TODAY AND I JUST WANTED AS THE
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THE INTELLECTUALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA. IN WITH- MY
COLLEAGUE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE TEARS. I REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO YOU TO ADDRESS THE- HE A
POSSIBILITIES OF MOVING UP THE
I. D. D. POPULATION. IN THE
INTERIOR ONE B. JUST JUST IN
THE GENERALITY OF. WITH THE AND
YOU LOOK AT THEY ARE AS LIKELY
TO GET INFECTED AS ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE GENERAL POPULATION BUT
TWO TO THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO DIE IF THEY ARE INFECTED-
WITH THIS POPULATION IT'S HARD
TO COMMUNICATE A LOT OF THE
TIMES THAT. IF THEY'RE BUILT.
ON THEIR CARE GIVERS- NEED TO
HAVE PRESIDENT'S ALSO. AND I'M
JUST LOOKING FORWARD TO- MOVING
THE DIALOGUE I'VE SHARED SOME
STUFF WITH DDS AS FAR AS THE
CDC RECOMMENDATIONS. GOING FOR
WITH DOWN SYNDROME CHILDREN.
AND DOWN'S SYNDROME ADULTS HOW
SUSCEPTIBLE THEY ARE AND- I'D
LIKE TO HAVE A DIALOGUE TODAY
ABOUT WHY THIS POPULATION HAS
NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED. AS A
PRIORITY WITH A THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SOMETHING THOUSAND-
PEOPLE IN THIS IN THIS
COMMUNITY. I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO SEE THAT ADDRESSED AND- MADE
A PRIORITY GOING FORWARD. HELLO
DOCTOR OF THE LAW BUT A
GAUNTLET OF THE CDPH. SO YOU
WERE RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT STATE
DEFINING EXACTLY AS YOU'RE
DESCRIBING. TWO SEPARATE
SEPARATE CATEGORIES ONE IS
PERSONS WITH MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT PUT THEM AT HIGH RISK FOR
COMPLICATIONS FROM CORRECT
NINETEEN. THEY'RE WORKING THOSE-
THE NEW DISABILITIES. THE HELP
DRAFTING GUIDELINES GROUP
THAT'S WORKING ON THE SPECIFICS
THEY WERE MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. HERE TO DISCUSS
HOW WE'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT SO THAT IS THAT IS MOVE
FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY OVER THE
NEXT. OKAY YOU'LL BE HEARING
MORE DETAILS. AND SO THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE M. MO BELT WON'T
IMMOBILITY OF IT. I DID THE
ADULTS IN THESE GROUP HOMES IN
ALL OF THE ABILITIES TO GET
THESE THESE RESOURCE TO THEM
BECAUSE WE DID THE NURSING
FACILITIES WE DID. THE PRISONS
WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DRESSING THERE IN MOBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO THE ADULT POPULATION
WHO. RIGHT IN LARGE WE TOOK OUT
OF THE- THE CENTERS THE
DISABILITY CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE DEMONIZE THEM.
AND NOW THERE ARE AT RISK SO I
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THE
OF MOBILITY COMPONENT HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DISPERSE TO THESE PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T GET TO. THE SITES. YES
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHY SO WE
MET LAST WEEK WE WERE MEETING
WITH. A TEAM OF STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER TO DEAL IT
SPECIFICALLY WITH THAT ISSUE WE
REALIZED. REALLY THAT THAT
POPULATION IS GOING TO REQUIRE
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION. BOTH NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL- DISABILITIES BUT
WHETHER THEIR HOME GROUND
TRANSPORTATION- AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE WORK WOULD BE A
LITTLE APPROACH OR AGAIN TAKING
IS THAT ANY DOOR IN THE RIGHT
DOOR. TO GET VACCINATED. AND
WE'RE MEETING EVERY WEEK WITH
THEM TO COME UP WITH AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO ADDRESS
THE. ISSUE THAT YOU'RE A
PRODUCT. THANK YOU LOOK FOR TO
SUBMIT THAT PLAY TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANNA APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER WHO MADE A SPECIAL TRIP
AND TODAY TO MAKE THIS
STATEMENT AND FOR ALWAYS
STANDING UP FOR OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I HAVE QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
LAB THAT WE CONTRACTED WITH I
DON'T KNOW WHO THE- PERSON
WOULD BE BUT- SO NUMBER ONE-
AND SOME NEWS- MEDIA. THERE'S
BEEN REPORTS THAT THE WHISTLE
BLOWER COMPLAINTS- REGARDING
UNLICENSED AND UNSUPERVISED
PERSONNEL IN THE VALENCIA LAB
DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION OR
ANY REPORTS ON THAT. IT'S
CURRENTLY UNDER- INVESTIGATE
INVESTIGATION SO THE STATE IS
LOOKING INTO THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AT
THIS TIME. SO WHAT DO YOU MEAN
LOOKING INTO THAT. WELL WE KNOW
WE KNOW ABOUT THE WORK WE DO WE
DO KNOW ABOUT THE REPORTS WE
HAVE- INVESTIGATORS JOHN IN THE
LANCIA. AND I KNOW I DON'T HAVE
THE I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFICS
OF WHERE THEY'RE AT BUT- THE
STATE IS TAKING THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE'RE LOOKING
INTO THE ALLEGATIONS. DO YOU
HAVE A TIME FRAME AS TO WHEN
THAT INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO
BE COMPLETED. I'M NOT IN THERE
I'M NOT A LABORATORY EXPERTS I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW QUICKLY IT'S
GOING TO BE- IT HOW LONG IT'LL
TAKE TO BE COMPLETED BUT BUT I
KNOW THAT- I DO KNOW THAT WE DO
HAVE- REGULATORS. AND DO THIS
ALL THE TIME BECAUSE THE
CERTIFIED LAB THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THEY'RE VERY
EXPERIENCED IN DOING THESE
TYPES OF INVESTIGATIONS. SO WE
DO HAVE WE DO HAVE- THE
EXPERTISE AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
DO TO DO THIS INVESTIGATION BUT
I. I STILL DIDN'T GET. I'M
SORRY. HI WE DO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF THE
INSPECTORS BUT I CAN'T I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE-
SO CAN I ASK FOR AN UPDATE FOR
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE AND- YOU
KNOW EVEN IF YOU HAVE NOTHING
TO REPORT- IS THERE A WAY THAT
WE CAN GET A REGULAR UPDATE ON
THE HOW THE INVESTIGATION IS
GOING. I WILL GIVE ME I WILL
COMMUNICATE THAT I'VE NOT ****
I WILL COMMUNICATE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS REQUEST IS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT I'M NOT SURE WHAT- LET
ME LET ME FIND OUT HOW THAT
WORKS LIKE I SAID I'M NEW HERE
THIS IS MY SIX WEEK- SO I WILL
BUT I WILL FIND OUT HOW THEY
COMMUNICATE THIS TYPE OF-
EVENT. PUBLICLY THANK YOU I
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT OVER THERE THAT ARE
NOT NEW THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO-
HELP- DO YOU THINK IT WOULD
HELP IF I. DRIVE A LETTER I.
REQUEST YEAH I KNOW I THINK-
YEAH I THINK THAT'S- THAT ON
THE BURKE. THANK YOU THEN THE
NEXT QUESTION- SOUL SOUL WHEN
OF THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED THE
CREATION OF THE LAND SELLOUT
THE GOVERNOR SAID THAT THAT I
WOULD BE DOING ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND TESTS PER
DAY BY MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS A
COUPLE WEEKS AWAY SO HOW MANY
TESTS. PER DAY IN THE LAB DOING
CURRENTLY. PACKSIZE DR PANDIT
THINK WE CAN GET BACK TO THAT
INFORMATION- I ANYWAY WE'LL GO
OVER PART BACK TO ON THE
NUMBERS WE DO GET A DAILY
REPORT BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION
TO MAKE UP FOR THAT. CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT THE DAILY REPORT
NUMBER WAS FROM YESTERDAY. I
DON'T HAVE IT IN MY TRAINING.
YEAH WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR SO
FIVE IS THERE ANY WAY THAT YOU
CAN. AT LEAST HELP ME WITHA
NUMBER- BY THE END OF THE
MEETING TODAY. OKAY THANK YOUNG.
AND THAT CA- LET'S SEE- AND
THEN THIS IS- IN TERMS OF THE
PRICING WHEN THE VIOLENCE AT
LEVELS ARE OPEN THE GOVERNOR
SAID THAT THE PRICE OF PROTEST
WOULD BE THIRTY DOLLARS PER
TEST AT MAXIMUM- DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE CURRENT. BECAUSE
PROTEST IS RIGHT NOW NUMBER
ONE. AND- WHAT HAS BEEN THE
AVERAGE OF THE TESTS- SINCE
INCEPTION. YEAH- I DO I DO NOT
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION- WHAT WE DID WE
TRANSCRIBER PAIRING FOR THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE SUBMITTED
BUT IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WE WILL WE WILL- TAKE
THIS INFORMATION BACK AND K.
AND- GET BACK TO YOU. OKAY
LET'S SEE. THE AND THEN ON
THERE WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT- THAT THERE WAS NO BID
PROCESS FOR PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SPECIFIC TO THE VIOLENCE A LAB
CAN YOU TELL ME WHY THAT WAS.
WHAT AND THEN TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT AND WHAT IS THE ALLELES-
ASSESSMENT OF THE NO BID
CONTRACT. I A ONE UNDERSTAND
WHY THERE IS NO BID. ARE NOT
BIDDING PROCESS. MISS PATRICK
CAN YOU ANSWER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REVEALS QUESTION. HELLO AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
AND WHEN THE STATE IS UNDER
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT OBLIGATED
TO USE A FORMAL BIDDING PROCESS
TO ENTER INTO PUBLIC CONTRACTS-
WE HAVE NOT DONE AS SEPARATE
ASSESSMENT OF THE PERKIN ELMER
CONTRACTS AND YOU KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE OR
SUCCESSFUL SO I CANNOT ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BUT THAT'S THE
REASON THE DEEP THE
MINISTRATION DOES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ENTER INTO NO BID
CONTRACTS FROM THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY- AND OUR COMMENT WAS
THAT- YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO REQUEST MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE- ABOUT
THE VENDORS THAT IT USES TO
WORK WITH. THANK YOU I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE I HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF VIOLENCE ALLOWED
LIKE WHERE DID WE COME UP WITH-
YOU KNOW VERSUS ANY OTHER-
TESTING LABS UP ACROSS THE
STATE SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW
I CAN FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY
PICKED ON VALENCIA- DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUGGESTIONS. AS TO HOW I
CAN GET THAT INFORMATION. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
QUESTION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO THEM. I MEAN THERE IS
A COPY OF THE CONTRACT ON- THE
CODE NINETEEN DOT CA DOT GOV
WEBSITE BUT- I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE ASKING FOR YOU KNOW MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TRICAN
ELMER WAS CHOSEN AS- THE VENDOR
TO OPEN THIS LAB IF I'M IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOU CORRECTLY
YES. YES THAT'S THAT'S EXACTLY
I MEAN YOU KNOW. THROUGH THIS
CONVERSATION WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT- ACCOUNTABILITY WE KEEP I
AND THIS IS NOT DIRECTED AT
YOU- BUT JUST IN GENERAL- THE
WHOLE AT LAST. WHAT IS IT
ALMOST TWO AND A HALF HOURS
ALMOST THREE HOURS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY-
EQUITY NO WE'VE BEEN THROWING
THOSE WORDS AROUND- VERY
LOOSELY. AND NOW THAT I'M
ASKING QUESTIONS WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE INFORMATION AS
TO WHY THINGS WERE DONE SO HOW
CAN WE ENSURE. EQUITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND- IF WE CAN'T
ANSWER KIND OF IN MY OPINION
THE BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU
DON'T THROUGH THIS PROCESS- YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND OBVIOUSLY
YOU GUYS ARE BEING BOMBARDED AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE WE'RE BEING
BOMBARDED AND WE HAVE WAY LESS
INFORMATION THAN YOU DO. AND SO
IT'S FRUSTRATING- THAT YOU KNOW
WE ALSO USE TERMS AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BETTER. THAT
IS NOT- THAT DOESN'T HELP ME
AND IT DOESN'T HELP I BELIEVE
AND I WON'T SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUES BUT IT DOESN'T HELP
ANY OF US TO GO BACK TO OUR
DISTRICTS. AND TELL THEM
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO BETTER
THAT'S NOT YOU KNOW A DATE OR
TIME OR ANY KIND OF ASSURANCE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE FIXED-
SOMEWHERE ANOTHER AND SO- I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO REQUEST THAT
INFORMATION AND I'LL LOOK TO MY
COLLEAGUES. BITE I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE AGAIN FOR OVER TWO
AND A HALF HOURS AND WE REALLY
HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY SUBSTANTIATE
YOU KNOW SUBSTANTIAL
INFORMATION IT'S BEEN ALL KIND
OF- AGAIN BIG WORDS THROWN
AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY EQUITY.
AND WE WANT TO DO BETTER WE ALL
WANT TO DO BETTER BUT HOW. DO
WE ACTUALLY GET INFORMATION
THAT IS GOING TO VALUABLE FOR
US BE ABLE ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS FOR CONSTITUENTS. MY
STAFF AND I CAN. PROBABLY
ASSUME THAT ALL OF THE- MY
COLLEAGUES UP HERE THEIR STAFFS
ARE GETTING BOMBARDED WITH
QUESTIONS THAT THEY CAN ANSWER
AND OUR PUBLIC DOESN'T ACCEPT
WE WANT TO DO BETTER. THEY WANT
ANSWERS AND THEY WANT. A REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY SO AGAIN IT'S
MORE OF A GENERAL COMMENT RIGHT
NOW BUT I DO NEED HELP AS TO
HOW WE CAN GET ACTUAL
INFORMATION INSTEAD OF. YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO DO BETTER.
I WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE EQUITY
WERE TRYING TO- INVESTIGATE YOU
KNOW INVESTIGATE THE VIOLENCE
THE ALLEGATIONS YOU KNOW WHEN
IT COMES OUT IN THE NEWS WE ARE
THE FACES AND WE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE RESPONDING TO. TO THE
PUBLIC AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR US
BACK THERE WERE FORTUNATELY FOR
US THAT'S WHAT WE SIGNED UP FOR
HOWEVER WHEN I'VE COME HERE AND
TRYING TO GET THOSE QUESTIONS I
CAN'T GO BACK TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND SAY. WELL I
ASKED THEM THEY TOLD ME YOU
KNOW THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
BETTER THAT IS NOT A GOOD
ANSWER STILL SOMEHOW IF. IF WE
CAN ALL COME UP WITH. YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW BENCHMARKS OR- YOU
KNOW- TIME FRAMES AS TO WHEN
WE'RE GOING TO GET THAT
INFORMATION AS OPPOSED TO WILL
GET THAT TO YOU AT SOME POINT-
I IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AGAIN FOR
US TO DO OUR JOBS. AND IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO YOU TO GIVE US THAT
INFORMATION AND WHAT WE GET IS
YOU KNOW WILL EVENTUALLY GET IT
TO SELL. AGAIN AT THEIR
QUESTIONS THEIR ACTUAL
QUESTIONS AND I WILL SUBMIT.
THAT REQUEST OF THE FIRST
REQUEST IN WRITING BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW FOR THE REST OF THE
MEETING IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT-
WE'RE GONNA BE MEETING ON A
REGULAR BASIS IF WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW I CAN ASK THAT QUESTION
SO THAT I CAN GET. ACTUAL
ANSWERS AS OPPOSED. TO YOU KNOW
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU AT SOME
POINT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD. YES FIRST I'D
LIKE TO SEE A IS OUR MADERA
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR
STILL WITH US IT'S ONE TO ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. MISS BOSS.
I'M STILL HERE GOOD GOOD THANK
YOU THANK YOU- JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SO I HAD HEARD FROM
ANOTHER COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR THAT THAT THEY'VE HAD
TO YOU GUYS HAVE HAD TO
INTERFACE WITH EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT NINE DIFFERENT DATA
SYSTEMS IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS IS THAT. IS THAT
ACCURATE FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AS WELL. THERE ARE SEVERAL DATA
SYSTEMS I CAN'T GIVE YOU A
NUMBER- BUT THERE IS A- KIND OF
A- FRACTURED WAIT IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHICH WE'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH- THE MAGNITUDE OF COALBED.
AND I SUSPECT IT'S BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T AN INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE TO
DEAL WITH THIS KIND OF EVENT
AND SO WE'VE- AND THE STATE
HAVE USED SYSTEMS THAT WERE
AVAILABLE- TO BE ABLE TO
REPURPOSE TEM OR EXPAND A LOT
ALONG THEIR ORIGINAL PURPOSE TO
BE ABLE TO HANDLE COBIT. SO-
WELL THAT'S AND THAT'S THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I WHAT I
WHAT I WAS TOLD TO SO
APPRECIATE THAT SO FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AS THE COUNTIES
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN TO WHAT IS
YOUR PERCEPTION OF WHAT'S THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR IS
GOING TO BE DOING FOR YOU AS A
COUNTY AND WILL THAT REQUIRE
YOU ENCOUNTERING ADDITIONAL
DATA RICH DISTRICT DISTANCE NEW
KINDS OF DATA REPORTING SYSTEMS
AS ON TOP OF THE- OTHER SYSTEMS
YOU ALREADY HAVE. SO THE
DIGITAL DATA SYSTEMS THAT WE'VE
HAD TO EMPLOY THE LOCAL LEVEL
ARE REALLY TO LINK TOGETHER OR
AUGMENT. THE SYSTEMS THAT HAVE
BEEN AVAILABLE TO US TO DATE.
I'M SO FOR INSTANCE OUR
APPOINTMENT- SYSTEM. WE HAVE TO
KIND OF. PUT SURVEYS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEM AND THINGS
LIKE THAT TO ACTUALLY COLLECT
THE COMPLETE DATA THAT WE NEED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. LIKE
OCCUPATION FOR INSTANCE WAS A
COLLECTED IN THE SYSTEM THAT
WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO US AT
FIRST. WE UNDERSTAND THAT MY
TURN WHICH IS REPLACING NODDED
AND ROLLING OUT STATEWIDE WILL
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS BUT IT
NEEDED TO BE BUILT. AND ADAPTED
TO LOCAL HEALTH NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT. WHAT WE HAVE.
HEARD FROM WITH REGARDS TO THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. IS
THAT- THEY ARE REALLY AN
OPERATIONS MACHINE. THAT THEY
ARE WORKING ON THE ISSUES OF
DATA AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE-
ALLOCATIONS RUN SMOOTHLY. AND
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE SPECIFICS ARE WITH REGARDS
TO THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
THEY ARE BEING NEGOTIATED IN
THE CONTRACT- BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO MANAGE THE ALLOCATIONS
THAT COME INTO THE STATE BASED
ON INFORMATION THAT THAT'S C.
PAGE HAS AS WELL AS BEING
INFORMED BY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS OR WHAT'S GOING ON
ON THE GROUND. AND THEN
DISTRIBUTING DIRECTLY OUT TO
THOSE PROVIDERS SO THEN LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS WILL NOT BE
MIDDLEMAN IN TERMS OF VACCINE
ALLOCATION LOCALLY BUT MORE IN
AN ADVISER ROLE. SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT FROM
A LOCAL HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK INTO
THOSE SPECIFIC PROVIDERS THAT
MAY NOT HAVE MAXIMUM EFFICIENCY
AT FIRST BUT CAN TARGET
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THANK
YOU- AND THAT AND THIS IS A
QUESTION I GUESS FOR. THIS WEEK
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE CONTRACT WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
CONTRACT WE DON'T KNOW REALLY
WHAT THE CONTRACTS GOING TO
COST. SO I. I GUESS IT FROM
SOMEONE FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
MAYBE CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
DIRECTOR- AND THAT IS- NOPE.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S NOT
LIKE IN THE EARLIER
CONVERSATION THAT THAT A BUNCH
OF THINGS THAT THAT YOU GUYS
ARE DOING THAT PUBLIC HEALTH OR
GOING TO BE- NOW THE ROLE OF
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
AND SO LIKE I SAID WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT CONTRACT WE DON'T
KNOW THE SIZE OF THE CONTRACT
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW ALL OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES- HOW'S THAT
AFFECT THE BUDGET. THAT'S
BEFORE US. HOW DO WE DON'T NOT
WE WON'T REALLY KNOW SO. THEN
WHEN WILL WE KNOW HOW THAT'S
GOING TO AFFECT THE BUDGET
THAT'S BEEN PUT OUT OUT THERE-
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE BEING
SHIFTED TO A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. THAN DO THEY RIP
I THINK ARE YOU AT THE PUMP
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH LIKE
THE MIDDLE MAN OR WHERE IS THE
MONEY COMING FROM FOR THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. IT JUST
FEELS LIKE A BIG BLACK BOX
RIGHT NOW. ANYONE UP DIRECTOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SOME. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE ASKING A VERY A VERY
GOOD QUESTION- I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHERE THE MONEY'S COMING FROM-
I CAN EXPLAIN TO CONCEPTUALLY
WHY WE THINK THAT THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATORS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT- THE QUESTION IN
TERMS OF. THE MONEY. SO WE
DON'T SO DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW
THIS IS GONNA AFFECT YOUR
BUDGET. I GUESS I'M I GUESS I'M
KIND OF WONDERING WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE RIGHT NOW. WE EXPECT
FRANKLY BECAUSE I DO WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE FULL PICTURE.
OF WHAT YOUR BUDGET'S GOING TO
BE A LIE- BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS HOW MUCH OF
THIS NEW THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR WHERE THAT
MONEY'S COMING FROM ISN'T
COMING OUT YOUR BUDGET IS A
COMING OUT OF SOMEWHERE ELSE.
IF YOU'RE OFFLOADING WORK TO A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR THAT
CERTAINLY SHOULD HAVE AN EFFECT
ON YOUR ON YOUR BUDGET THIS
YEAR. SO AT SOME POINT I GUESS
REALLY THE POINT OF MY
QUESTIONS IS AT WHAT POINT ARE
WE GOING TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND. THE RAMIFICATIONS
OF THAT. NEW MEMBERS AND I AM
JACK'S WALL FROM GOVERNOR
FINANCE- SPEAKING ABOUT THE-
THE DEPARTMENT STRICTER
CONTRACT IN SORT OF THE ON
GOING RESPONSE BROADLY- THESE
ARE COSTS THAT- YOU KNOW WHAT
THE- COSTS ARE NOT NEW TO THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WE'VE HAD TO
RIDE IN. A NUMBER OF- HELLO
REQUEST SECTION THREE SIX
REQUEST TO DEAL WITH THESE
SORTS OF EXPENDITURES IN THE
PAST WHETHER THAT WAS IN THE
EARLY DAYS THEN BACK. TO BITE
VENTILATORS ARE OR WRAPPED YOU
KNOW WHAT THE OKAY STATE SENATE
STAFF SURGEONS OR OR WHATEVER-
YOU KNOW AS AS WE SORT OF.
MOVED TOWARDS TO FINALIZING THE-
THIRD PARTY. AGREEMENTS WE WILL
BE ABLE TO- JEFF MORE DETAIL-
TO THE LEGISLATURE. AND AS WE
SORT OF CREATED A UNIVERSE OF
FIVE I THINK. THE NECESSARY TO
REQUEST AFTER. SO I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOKING FOR IS AT SOME
POINT WILL WE GET SORT OF A
OKAY THERE'S A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR HERE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH BUDGET HERE'S HOW THEY
INTERACT OR DON'T INTERACT- SO
WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF ALL OF THIS
RELATED TO THE PUBLIC HELP
BUDGET. THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET TO. WE WILL GET
THAT INFORMATION AT SOME POINT.
YES. YEAH I WHETHER YOU WILL
GET THAT INFORMATION AT SOME
POINT- YEAH WE HAVE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF NAY L. A. R.
TO PROVIDE. OUR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON VARIOUS FUNDING.
REQUESTS AND SORT OF
ALLOCATIONS THAT YOU PROVIDED.
TO DPH AND A NUMBER OF OTHER-
THE DEPARTMENTS OF THE STATE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO-
THIS THIS- THIS PARTICULAR CASE
IS- IS AN ON GOING PROJECT THAT
THAT WILL BE IT FURTHER
COMMUNICATION- WITH YOUR STAFF
ON AS WE- AS WE MOVE. FURTHER
THROUGH THIS KIND OF RESPONSE
PROCESS. BUT I GUESS MY
OVERARCHING POINT OF THAT IS IT
FOR PAIN ONE PERSON ONE GROUP
TO DO IT AND ANOTHER GROUP HAS
BEEN DOING A LOT OF THIS. I
DON'T SEE IS PAIN TWICE. I
THINK THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THE. SO WE UNDERSTAND CLASS OR
WHEN- THAT IS A VERY REASONABLE
CONCERN AND- SOMETHING WILL BE
TAKE A LOOK AT. AND SO AT WHAT
YOU CAN DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
WHEN WILL WHEN THE CONTRACT AND
ALL THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE WHEN
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION. WHAT IT WOULD
HELP IF I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
I'M AFRAID. OKAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- SINCE WE DO
HAVE. MORE LET'S LOOK AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BACK. AND
TALK ABOUT THIS THIRD PARTY
CONTRACT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S A COUPLE MORE DAYS LEFT
OF THIS- CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
IS THAT CORRECT. S. R. AT THIS
I'M NOT BOTH THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THIRD PARTY
STRAIGHTER CANNOT SPEAK
CONFIDENTLY TO THE STATE OF
THOSE TO GO SHE ASIANS. OKAY IF
I COULD GET THE- THE. MADERA
MODESTO HEALTH DIRECTOR MADERA
HELP DIRECTOR PLEASE. SO MADAM
DIRECTOR AS AS YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH- GETTING LOGGED ON MY
QUESTION FOR YOU THAT YOUR
LEVEL SINCE THIS CONTRACT ISN'T
WRITTEN YET. WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SEE IN THAT CONTRACT
AND WHY. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
AND OTHER LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE ALSO
COMMUNICATED. ORTON'S OF
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
DETERMINING WHICH PROVIDERS ARE
A PART OF THE NETWORK. AND ALSO
MONITORING AT THE DATA WITH
REGARDS TO THE PROVIDERS-
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
REMOVING IMPORTANT PROVIDERS TO
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I'M FROM
THE NETWORK SIMPLY DUE TO
EFFICIENCY. I'M BECAUSE WHAT WE
KNOW AT THE GROUND LEVEL IS
THAT. WONDERFUL POPULATIONS
HEALTH LOTS AND LOTS OF OTHER
ACCESS ISSUES- FOR INSTANCE THE
DISABLED POPULATION AND BEING
ABLE TO GET A VACCINATION SITE
SO IT'S IF YOU HAVE A PROVIDER
THAT SPECIFICALLY WORKING WITH
THOSE POPULATIONS THE PACE OF
VACCINATION IS GOING TO BE
SLOWER. SO WHAT WE ULTIMATELY
WANT TO SEE IS THAT THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR IS WORKING HAND
IN HAND WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE GROUND
LEVEL IN COUNTIES WITH REGARDS
TO PROVIDERS AND WHO DOES
IMPORTANT PROVIDERS. ARE AS A
PART OF THE NETWORK. SO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE USING
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS TO GET
OUT TO YOU- DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS THE USE OF SUCH AS
DISABLED OR AG WORKERS. OR OR
OTHERS. THAT'S CORRECT AND THEN
ALSO PROVIDING- ADEQUATE
TRAINING WITH REGARDS TO YOU-
HOW TO INPUT THE DATA AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S ACCURATE
CONSISTENT AT THE ENTRY DOESN'T
HAVE ERRORS BECAUSE- YOU'VE GOT
AT. A SMALL CBO ON THE GROUNDS
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF DATA
EXPERTISE SO ADEQUATE TRAINING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE
PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND. SO
ENSURING THAT THE- WHATEVER
SOFTWARE THEY'RE COMING OUT
WITH IS VERY USER FRIENDLY IN
TRAINING GOES ALONG WITH THAT.
CORRECT. SO TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE I
MEAN WE KNOW THEY'VE HAD
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND I THINK
THE- A. T. USED LORD OF THE
RINGS HERE BUT IT'S KIND OF-
ONE ONE PROGRAM TO RULE THEM
ALL- WHAT DOES THAT I MEAN WHAT
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE. TO
YOU. I MEAN IF YOU HAD YOUR
YOUR WISHLIST YOU IN AND I AND
I TALKED TO MY- MY PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTOR TO IN IN ALL
THREE OF THEM. BUT WHAT WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FROM YOU
KNOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE IF YOU
COULD SAY THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE. A YOUR
TO TALK TO HIM RIGHT NOW. WHAT
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE. IT WOULD
INCLUDE THOSE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO TRULY OUTRAGE TO
THE ENTIRE POPULATION WITHIN AN
EIGHT COUNTY AREA. IT WOULD
ALSO INCLUDE A DATA SYSTEM
THAT'S EASILY ACCESSIBLE AND
ACCESSIBLE REMOTELY SO PROBABLY
CLOUD BASED. THE ABILITY TO
INPUT DATA REAL TIME THE
ABILITY TO CALL REPORTS REAL
TIME TO BE ABLE TO KNOW THOSE
I'M DATA POINTS ON THE GROUND
TO BE ABLE TO REPORT THOSE OUT
TO OUR LOCAL CAN- COMMUNITIES
AND THE MEDIA ARE BECAUSE WHERE
ELSE A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT
THAT WE JUST CAN'T. ANSWER AT
THIS POINT. AND WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THOSE SYSTEMS
I'M TO BE ABLE TO PLAN AND
MINISTER PODS ON THE GROUND.
OUR COUNTIES ARE SO DIVERSE.
AND BEING ABLE TO SCHEDULE
CLINICS THE WAY WE NEED TO.
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE USING THE
SAME INPUT SYSTEM. BUT WE MAY
BE ABLE TO LIMIT ACCESS TO THIS
GROUP VERSUS BACK GROUP TO BE
ABLE TO ALLOW SLOTS FOR THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION. FOR
EXAMPLE. WE HAD BEEN
PRIORITIZING ONLY SEVENTY FIVE
IN UP IN MADERA COUNTY DUE TO-
COMPUTER. ISSUES CONNECTIVITY-
AND JUST THEIR UNFAMILIARITY
WITH ONLINE REGISTRATION
PROCESSES. I'M AND WE OPENED UP
TO AGE SIXTY FIVE AN UP AND
ALMOST INSTANTLY WE HAD A
POPULATION THAT WERE CALLING
AND CALLING BECAUSE THEY JUST
COULDN'T GET REGISTERED FAST
ENOUGH. SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO CREATE SEPARATE CLINICS JUST
SERVE VERY VOCAL POPULATIONS
WITH SPECIFIC NEEDS. WHILE
WE'RE A PART OF THIS STATEWIDE
SYSTEM THAT SERVES EVERYONE.
THANK YOU I HOPE THEIR
LISTENING. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES IF I CAN FOR THE
BREADTH OF QUESTIONS I THOUGHT
IT WAS QUITE INFORMATIVE AND
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS. I WILL ADD
FIVE QUESTIONS IF I CAN BUT
FIRST I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS FROM DR PAM AS
WELL AS- SUSAN FINALE. ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE AND NEED FOR
GOOD DATA AND IT SYSTEMS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNICATING
EFFECTIVELY TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT
HOW TRANSPARENCY LEADS TO A
BETTER PROCESS ARE IMPORTANT
GOALS FOR US TO HAVE MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT DATA
AND TRANSPARENCY SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
SINCE I FRAMED IT AND STARTED
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT IT I
REALLY DO WANT TO ASK DR ERIC
ON DOCTOR PAN IF I CAN'T. ABOUT
THE DATA ON OUR CODE NINETEEN
VACCINES RIGHT NOW. ARE THEY
GOING TO THE POOR AND TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE ARE
THEY GOING TO WEALTHY AND THE
PRIVILEGED. ALTHOUGH STARTED
AND DOCTOR DOCTOR AND CAN ADD.
YOU'RE ASKING A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING IS REALLY
CRITICAL WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO
PASS DATA POSSIBLE BECAUSE
WITHOUT THIS DATA WE WILL NOT
HAVE VISIBILITY INTO WHO'S
BEING VACCINATED. AND SO IT'S
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO BE
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
THAT'S WHY WE'RE THAT FAR WITH
THE PROVIDERS. AS WE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE'RE REALLY GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THE QUALITY OF THE
DATA WITH THE WITH SOMEBODY TO
GET VACCINATED. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IT BE ENTERED
THAT THAT BE HAVE TURNED TO THE
WAY IT GOES INTO REGISTRY.
WHETHER YOU'RE BEING VACCINATED
AT A HEALTH FUND. AT A PHARMACY
IN THE COMMUNITY PHOTOMASKS
ACTIVATIONS- MEGAFIGHT. NO
MATTER WHERE YOU'RE GETTING
ACTUALLY- ARE YOU BEGINNING
BACKED INTO THE HOME OR IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. THAT
HAVE TO COME INTO IT IT HAS THE
DATA HAVE TO BE ANSWERED. SO WE
CAN THEN KNOW EXACTLY WHO GOT
VACCINATED WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S
OF CODE. AND HOPEFULLY SOMETIME
TODAY IS INCOMPLETE IN TERMS OF
RACE AND ETHNICITY SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY CHARACTERIZED. WHO'S
GETTING VACCINATED. EMAIL OR
CALL THE DATA IT. WE'RE WORKING
ON IT FOR THE CALL OF THE DATA
RALPH SHIPPED FROM. PHASE ONE
PHASE ONE IN. THEY WERE NOW
BEGINNING PHASE ONE B. OR THE
DATA IS GOING TO BE VERY VERY
CRITICAL. AND WE ARE WORKING ON
IN EQUITY PLANS SO THAT WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING
OUR EQUITY GOALS IN TERMS OF
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF THE
VACCINE. WE'RE WE'RE DEFINITELY
NOT THERE YET AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY THE DATA IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ALL OF US
INCLUDING THAT THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE EQUITY
GOALS WE COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU. COMING FROM THE VALLEY WE
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE I KEEP
HEARING THE CONVERSATION TODAY
AND IT REMINDS ME OF THE FOG
THAT WE HAVE IN THE VALLEY IT
REMINDS ME THAT IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR US TO SEE CLEARLY AND-
I THINK WHAT I'M TRYING. TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT FOG THE
REASON WHY WE HAD TO PIVOT IS
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AND
DATA THE REASON WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION NEEDED TO MOVE
TO A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
I WILL I WILL GIVE YOU SERVE MY-
MY PERSPECTIVE IS THAT AS I
THOUGHT IN THE CHALLENGES I
COME. BY WITH THE HELP OF BY
WITH THE HELP OF THEIR FOOD GO
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS. AND
SO I'M I'M I'M GONNA GIVE IT TO
YOU HI WE'RE PROBABLY FROM A
FROM A LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN WHATEVER
THE SEARCH HERE TO THIS COUNTRY
FROM FRO THE- SHOP OWNER OF
HER FROM COMING TO THE STATE.
THIS MACRO THIS VACCINATION.
PROGRAM THEY WERE GONNA TRY TO
CHIU. AT THE STATE IS MATH OF
IT IS MATH. AT ALL OF ALL OF US
HAVE COMPLEMENTARY ROLES EVER
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL. ALL OF
US HAVE TO DO WELL WALDRON
REALLY ALL OF US HAVE DIFFERENT
STRENGTHS. AND WE NEED TO BRING
THOSE STRENGTHS TO THE TABLE SO
THAT WE CAN GET AS MANY PEOPLE
VACCINATED IN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH CHARLES. IS REALLY
HAVE TERM EXPERTISE AGAIN
REACHING POPULATIONS. THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO REACH AND REACHING
HOMELESS. WELL WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN REACHING
IMMIGRANTS UNDOCUMENTED AND
HANDED OUT WORKING WORKING IN
CONGREGATE SITES ACTUALLY
PUBLICADOS THE TRIM TREMENDOUS
THE ROLE IN PARTNERING WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO GET PEOPLE
BACK WITH TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED. WELL WE NEED A
WHOLE LOT MORE THAN THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO SCALE UP AND
READ IT WE REALLY WANT TO GET
HELP IF WE WILL IF WE WANT TO
REACH. HERD IMMUNITY AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO SCALE UP TREMENDOUSLY FOR ME
WE HAVE TO IT'S ALMOST LIKE
BUILDING A FREE WARY. OF LIKE
WE'RE ADDING LANES TO A FREEWAY
IT IS GOING TO COULD OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. OUR PHARMACY
NETWORK OUR CLINIC NETWORK THE
INCLUDING GOT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER THAT
ARE IN THE IN THE COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS THE MEGA FIGHTS AND
AS WELL AS- FIGURING OUT HOW TO
GET IT BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WHO ARE HOMEBOUND.
THROUGHOUT THE UNIVERSE OR WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO VACCINATE
EVERYBODY HAVE TO COME TO THE
TABLE. OKAY MINISTRY TO THIS OF
THEIR REALLY BROUGH IT UP THERE
REALLY AT MANTA. THAT WORKS.
THERE REALLY AND- PAPER
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES. AND
KNOWING HOW TO HOLD HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. IN CLINICAL PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE TO MEETING TO
MEETING OUR TARGETS OF THE OF
THE VACCINATION. AND THEY THEY
THEY HAVE EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF
CONTRACTING HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND IT IT WILL IT
WILL NOT GOING TO DO IS WE'RE
GONNA WORK WITH THEM TO
IMPLEMENT OUR EQUITY GOALS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THEY'RE VACCINATING
PEOPLE THE MOST IMPACTED AREAS
POLITICALLY THE COMBINATION. OF
ALL OF THOSE SO PUBLIC TROUBLES
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PLAY A
REALLY CRITICAL ROLE AS AS-
EVER HELP OFTEN THROUGH PROVIDE
YOUR COUNTY WITH TWENTY NOW WE
REALLY DO NEED THEM. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY. WHO
THE COMMUNITY WE NEED TO REACH.
NOW- YOU WILL A LOCAL PUB HELD
OFF AND IT WAS NOT MISTER
FOSTER JUST WANNA BE CLEAR
THAT. WHO WHEN I WAS ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT DATA JUST THIS
PAST WEEK TOLD ME THAT THEY'RE
FLYING BLIND HIS WORDS NOT MINE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THEM ON A
FOGGY DEW IN THE VALLEY YOU
DON'T FLY WHEN YOU'RE BLIND.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO MAKE SURE WE ARE.
DOING ALL WE CAN TO. MEASURE
THIS BECAUSE OTHERWISE I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE IMPROVE UPON IT.
AND SO I. BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING CLEARLY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IS. REALLY WANTING
THAT DATA SO WE CAN HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY WE ALL ARE-
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC AND- I BELIEVE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS QUITE HELPFUL TO
THEM. I WANT TO MOVE ON THOUGH
IF I COULD BECAUSE DOCTOR ARE
GONE YOU SAID SOMETHING TODAY
THAT IS A NEW DATA POINTS
SOMETHING THAT- HAS CHANGED
SINCE THE LAST TIME WE'VE
SPOKEN. AND THAT WAS THE
PERCENTAGE FOR ALLOCATION AND I
DIDN'T WANT TO LOSE IT BECAUSE
I THINK YOU. REALLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE FOURTH QUESTION THAT I
ASKED ABOUT WHERE. WHERE ARE WE
GOING FROM HERE. AND FOR
CHANGING THAT PERCENT OF
ALLOCATION TO BOTH REPRESENT
POVERTY AS WELL AS RACE AND
ETHNICITY. IT SEEMS AS IF WE
WILL GET TO TOWARDS EQUITY
FASTER AND WANTED TO GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON
THE WAY OR IF YOU COULD. YEAH
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD- VERY GOOD
QUESTION AND WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH WITH A CALIFORNIA
SURGEON GENERAL DR- NADINE
BURKE HARRIS ON THIS ISSUE
WHERE SHE HAS BEEN SPENDING
TIME- DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK ON
HOW WE WOULD GIVE VACCINES TO
CHEAT THE CHIEF EQUITY GOALS-
PART OF. PART OF IT IS THAT WE
NEED WE NEED WE NEED TO SORT OF
EITHER THE QUALITY AND THEN
THERES EQUITY WE DO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VACCINES ARE
DISTRIBUTED FOR. INDUSTRY BUT
IN A WAY THAT ARE REACHES. THE
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND- THAT WE ALSO
HAVE ADDITIONAL MELTED OR
BETTER. ALLOCATED TO AREAS THAT
ARE MORE DISTANT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO BE USING
THE- HEALTHY PLACES INDEX.
SHOWED UP AREAS THAT ARE MOST
THAT ARE MOST ANTI HAVE BEEN
MOST IMPACTED BY IT BECAUSE-
COVERED PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO THE
LOW. LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
ARE GOING TO GET ADDITIONAL
VACCINE ALLOCATED TO AREAS. AND
THAT MEANS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HELPING PLACES INDEX YOU'LL SEE
THAT. THE RURAL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GONNA BE BETTER
REPRESENTED IN TERMS OF
GETTING. GETTING THE VACCINE
SUPPLY. THE OTHER THING THAT.
WE'RE HEARING FROM FOLKS ON THE
GROUND. THANK ARE ACTUALLY
DON'T APPEAR SOME OF THE DATA.
UP SOME OF THE POPULAR HEALTHY
SAID THREE GREEN THINGS LIKE A
P. I. SO I'M HERE FROM LOW
HEALTH. FOR EXAMPLE. THAT THEY
HAVE FOR. SHE ACT A RIGHT NOW I
JUST OF YEAR OR COME INTO THE
COUNTY. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
THEM THAT WE ALSO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO VACCINATE. WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BACK
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER AND
UNDOCUMENTED. ALSO THERE IT SO
WE DO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES BESIDES THE ONES
THAT ARE. DIVERSE SORT OF THE
BENEFIT OF OBVIOUS JUST FROM
WHAT THE TYPICAL PERSPECTIVE.
AND THE ONLY WAY THEY WERE
GOING TO REACH THOSE
POPULATIONS OF THE WORKING WITH
THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES BECAUSE
EVERY COUNTY IT'S GONNA IT'S
GONNA DIFFERENT EVERY COUNTY.
AND SO THAT BOOTS ON THE GROUND
IS REALLY GOING TO HELP US MEET
THE BEATLES. MEET THOSE GOALS.
GOOD THING I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT IS. SURE LEANING BACK ARE
TO COME ON ON ON THERE ARE
BECOME AVAIL FOR. THEY'RE GONNA
BE MY EASIER FOR US TO-
DISTRIBUTE ACROSS THE STATE. TO
THE JOHNSON AND JOHNSON VACCINE
WITHOUT BECAUSE AVAILABLE THAT
THE ONE SHOP VACCINE AND THEN
THERE ARE OTHER OTHER VACCINES
HAVE LOWER REFRIGERATION
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE ANTICIPATE
WE WANT TO BE IN THE POSITION
OF THE VACCINE OF THE PIE
INCREASES WE NEED A MAP OF THE
NETWORK OF PROVIDERS THAT CAN
REALLY DELIVER. VACCINES AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE. SPEAKING
AS ONE OF THOSE PROVIDERS WHO
TOMORROW WILL BE GOING OUT TO
ORANGE GROVE TO DISTRIBUTE
VACCINES TORE FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES I'M- HAPPY TO TAKE
THE CHALLENGE PERSONALLY AND
KNOW THAT- THERE ARE THERE'S
MUCH MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO IS
A STATE. BUT REALLY WANTED TO
DIG IN JUST A FEW MORE
QUESTIONS IF I COULD. I WANTED
TO UNDERSTAND THERE REALLY WAS
A DISCREPANCY IN TERMS OF
COUNTIES WITH DOSES
ADMINISTERED. THEY'VE BEEN
ALLOTTED A CERTAIN NUMBER. BUT
WE HAVE DISCREPANCIES AS WIDE
AS 50% AND 92% THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO US THIS WEEK. AND
SO MY- QUESTION FOR YOU IS. HOW
DO WE ENCOURAGE OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO. BE USING OUR
VACCINES- AS EFFECTIVELY AS WE
CAN WHAT DIRECTION ARE YOU
PROVIDING TO THEM TO. ENCOURAGE
AND INCENTIVIZE THAT. SO WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING DIRECTORS
TO- THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROVIDERS PRIMARILY TO THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
WE WERE IN CURRENT WORK WERE
ENCOURAGING THEM WE'RE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO NOT TO NOT
TO HOLD ON TO VACCINES VERY
LONG. WE WHAT WE WANT WE WANT
TO GET THE VACCINE IN IN IN IN
TO- THE COMMUNITY. AND SO WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING DIRECTIONS-
AND WHAT AND ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES HAS REALLY BEEN
IDENTIFIED CLOSING THE DATA GAP
THAT WE HAD BECAUSE WE
REALIZED. THE ONLY WAY THAT WE
THE SOURCE OF THE TRUTH FOR
DATA IS THAT. SOMEBODY'S WITH
SOMEBODY INTERACTION IT IS. WE
MAY NOT KNOW THAT THAT PERSON
WAS VACCINATED UNTIL THAT GETS
ENTERED INTO OUR REGISTRY. HOW
IT GETS INTO OUR REGISTRY
DEFERRED IF YOU HAVE AN
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD THAT'S
WHAT THAT THAT ALREADY
COMMUNICATE FOR REGISTRY WE
KNOW ABOUT IT. IT WAS ON A
PAPER SYSTEM ANY ATTRIBUTES WE
KNOW ABOUT IT OR DO YOU WANT TO
BE APPROVED- MANAGEMENT
SOFTWARE SYSTEM. AND INDUCTOR
COMMUNICATE TO OUR REGISTRY WE
KNOW ABOUT IT AND IT'S TAKEN US
A WHILE TO SORT OF REALLY SORT
OUT WHY INFORMATION WASN'T
GETTING INTO OUR SYSTEMS IN
SOME CASES IT WAS NEVER ENTERED
IT WAS ENTERED AT YOUR IT WAS
ENTERED IN LATE. WE WORKED WITH
SOME PLACES WHERE THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE PILES OF PEOPLE THEY
READ THE VACCINATED ADVANCE
PAPERS WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TO HELP THEM ANSWER ANSWER THAT
THAT INFORMATION. AND SO WE'RE
LEARNING TO THE PROBLEMS OF HOW
TO MAKE A HOW TO HOW TO MAKE
THAT MORE. EFFICIENT I'M NOT
SURE IF I ANSWERED YOUR WHOLE
QUESTION MAYBE YOU CAN IF YOU
CAN JUST REMIND. ME IF I WANT
TO SHARE ANSWERED ALL. THE
COUNTIES ARE- CHIU. TO HOLD A
SECOND DOSE- YEAH WOULD BE A
DEFINITE BUT BETTER GOOD CORD
MANY OTHER CHALLENGE THAT THE
WAY THIS GOVERNMENT START THE
PROGRAM. THIS TORRENT OF THE
PROBE WILL SAID YOUR DOES
YOU'VE- WANNA HOLD BACK FROM
SECOND DAY IT AND WILL WE WILL
SHIP OUT LATE TO YOU SO THAT.
IF I THAT. YOU HAVE ALL YOU
HAVE A SHOULD OF. CAPTION
DESIGNATE OF THIS DOES THAT
MISSION OF THE OF THE NATIVE AS
OF THE FIRST. BUT IT'S EXACTLY
THE SAME. BACK THERE IS NO
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DIFFERENT THAT. SO YOU CAN ALSO
WON'T THAT HAPPENS ESPECIALLY
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE BECOME
VACCINATED YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
MAY RECEIVE THEIR FIRST DOSE AT
ONE LOCATION BUT LATER ON
REQUIRE MADE ME RECEIVE HER
DAUGHTER THE OTHER LOCATION
BECAUSE IT'S MORE CONVENIENT OR
THEY'VE MOVED OR THAT'S JUST
WHAT THE VERY AVAILABLE TO
THEM. AND SO THEN WHEN THAT
HAPPENS IT BECOMES MORE
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE THIS IDEA
OF SOMETHING BEING. THE FIRST
OF HER SECOND DOES. WE'RE
ASKING PROVIDERS TO TREAT LIKE
ANY OTHER. THAT HAVE MULTIPLE.
APPLE HAS VACCINE APPETITE AB
T. SHOCK AND YOU START SERIES
YOU COULD YOUR AFTER IT RENEWS
GET YOUR SECOND SHOT. AS A
ROUTING NEED TO REALLY THINK OF
THEM DOLLARS FIRST OF THE
SECOND DOES IT BUT IT DOESN'T
IT DOES AND YOUR READERS
STARTING THE SERIES OR YOU'RE
COMPLETING A SERIES. OR DOING
AFTER REALLY COMES DOWN TO THAT
IT'S A. IT BECOMES AN EXERCISE
IN. BOB WE IS REALLY INVENTORY
MANAGEMENT. AND SCHEDULING
PERSONS TO EITHER COME INTO
STARTERS VERY AND TO COMPLETE
THEIR SERIES. AND SO THAT'S
PART OF THAT FOR THE
COMMUNICATION PLAN THAT WOULD
THAT WERE USING I DON'T KNOW
IF. YOU DON'T WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING BUT- THAT'S A STEP
SHORT VERSION. NO THAT'LL
PRETTY GOOD I. DO WANT TO ASK I
WAS INTENDING TO ASK THIS BUT
THE GOVERNOR HAS FREQUENTLY
SAID THAT THE STATE HAS NO
FREEZERS WE HAVE NO STORAGE I
WANTED TO CONFIRM WITH YOU.
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS
DELIVERED THE VACCINES DIRECTLY
TO THE COUNTIES OR PROVIDERS
CARE AND SO THE STATE IS NOT
HOLDING ANY ACCIDENTS BACK ANY
VACCINES THAT ARE NOT. MINISTER
ARE CURRENTLY BY A POLICY
CHOICE. AT THE COUNTY LEVEL IS
THAT CORRECT. WHAT DO YOU THINK
I SHOULD DIRECTLY PROVIDERS- SO
YEAH THAT THE STATE OF THE
STATE WE HAVE NO VACCINES. THEY
GO THEY GO THEY GO THE ROUTE
THEY GO OUT TO PROVE THAT THE
PROVIDERS. YEAH THE PROVIDERS
ARE SELECTED IN CONSULTATION
WITH A- HOW DO YOU LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTIONS. FUNNELED TO
QUESTIONS- WE TALK A FAIR
AMOUNT ABOUT MORTALITY WOULD WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT MORBIDITY. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW. WHAT THE
STATE IS PLANNING TO DO THE
STUDY. AND UNDERSTAND THE
AFFECTS OF COVERT NINETEEN ON
LONG HAULERS ON. PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CONTRACTED THE DISEASE.
ARE WE CURRENTLY UNDERGOING ANY
RESEARCH AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OR OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. TO HELP US TO
UNDERSTAND THIS MORBIDITY AND-
IF NOT- WOULD LIKE TO SAY. UP
WITH A PLAN THAT. WILL ALLOW US
TO DO THIS EFFECTIVE RESEARCH.
YEAH THERE THERE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESEARCH-
HAPPENING- AND I'M MORE
FAMILIAR WITH THE RESURS OF
HAPPENING AT AT THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO BECAUSE UP FOR I HAD
IT. NOT BEEN AFFILIATION- HAVE
SO IT THIS IS THE TRUTH WE'VE
UNIVERSITY STANFORD BUT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE UC SYSTEM
WORKING CLOSELY WITH. LOTS OF
LOCAL ALSO WITH THE STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ON CONDUCTING
RESEARCH WE DO HAVE ONE OF OUR
BRANCHES THAT- DESIGNING A
LONGITUDINAL STUDY BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE NEED
TO LEARN A TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT MORE. AND SO
WE HAVE OUR TESTING SYSTEM THAT
IDENTIFIES PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE
OPEN FOR POSITIVE. AND THEN-
VACCINATION REGISTRIES GOING TO
BE ANOTHER SORT OF IMPORTANT
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ABANDON VACCINATED WHO MAY
BECOME INFECTED PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED AND THEN
VACCINATED AND THEN WE HAVE
<c.blue>IFFERENT VACCINES. THAT ARE</c>
BEING INTRODUCED INTO ALL OF
THESE ALL THE SYSTEMS ARE GOING
TO HELP. TO ANSWER IMPORTANT.
RESEARCH QUESTIONS INTO THE
FUTURE. I SIMPLY. THAT THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO BUDGET. FROM THIS.
TO COME THIS RESEARCH. AND IF
THERE IS A WILLINGNESS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AYE I KNOW OF AN
OFFICE THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AS WE'RE
GOING FORWARD. FINAL QUESTION
IF I COULD IS- ON THE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION. HI I'M TRYING TO.
AND FOLLOWING UP WITH WHERE THE
DOCTOR WOULD WAS ASKING THE
QUESTION. MANY OF US ARE TRYING
TO GET AN UNDERSTANDING IF
THAT'S A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT.
BECAUSE IF IT'S A SIMPLE IF
YOU'RE TELLING US IT'S A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT. WE'RE GOING
TO EXPECT CERTAIN RESULTS AND
IF YOU ARE ABLE TO TELL US THAT
YOU WILL BE NEEDING MORE
RESOURCES TO EFFECTIVELY
DISTRIBUTE THIS VACCINE. THAT'S
ALSO A CONVERSATION I BELIEVE
ME AS THE LEGISLATURE NEED TO
BE INVOLVED IN SO I WOULD LIKE
TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU- YOUR
THOUGHTS ON- THE SUFFICIENCY OF
THAT ALLOCATION. YEAH I'M NOT
LET ME LET ME BRING TO THE SHE
WANTED TO WORKING MORE CLOSELY
WITH THAT SPECIFIC ALLOCATIONS.
SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE SUFFICIENCY OF
THAT BECAUSE IT IS NOT ONLY THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION BUT IT'S THE ABILITY TO
USE THE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION. THAT WE GOT IN THE L.
C. GRANT FROM CDC AS WELL AND
THAT MONEY COVERS NOT ONLY
VACCINE SUPPORT BUT ALSO
CASTING AND CONTACT TRACING AND
DATA ANALYTICS AND SO WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY'S NOW
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE AND YOU. WILL BE PUTTING
TOGETHER WORK PLANS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE THEM AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY ACROSS THE TWO
SOURCES OF FUNDING. AND WILL BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY GAPS IN THOSE
GAPS MAY NOT OCCUR IN THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS. BUT THEY MAY CALL
MATT DEPENDING ON. WE NEED
TRANSIT. TO PAY ON THE ROLE OF
THE TVA VERSUS THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS SO. I THINK THERE
ARE STILL SOME UNKNOWNS BUT I
THINK THIS IS. PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES THAT PEOPLE NEED
IMMEDIATELY AND WILL KEEP TABS
ON THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT. IF
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL RESOURCE
FOR O'CLOCK BUT WE LET YOU KNOW
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
AND- WITH THAT I REALLY DO WANT
TO THANK THE ENTIRE PANEL
THREE. AND WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO PANEL FOR. ON STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS RELATED TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE HAVE FOUR PRESENTERS
ON THIS WE HAVE DIRECTOR BOSS
MISS AUSSIE. MISS BLOOMBERG AND
MR OF THE BONA WE CAN GO IN
THAT ORDER PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN SHARE AND
MEMBERS CEREBUS FROM MADERA
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF GEAC. I
WANT TO BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT
BUDGET BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
WERE PERFORMED BY JACK IN OUR
PARTNER STARTING WITH THE
REQUEST FOR ONE POINT TWO
BILLION FOR COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES FOR THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS TO SUPPORT
CONTINUED CONTACT TRACING
DISEASE INVESTIGATION. TESTING
AS WELL AS VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION COSTS SUCH AS
SITE COST SECURITY AND STAFF.
WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDING THAT
ONE POINT TWO BILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDING TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO MEET THIS NEED
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT FEDERAL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALLOWS THESE FUNDS
TO BE EX BENDED OVER A TWO YEAR
PERIOD BUT BECAUSE OF THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL LIKELY EXPAND.
THESE FUNDS VERY QUICKLY. WAIT
ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
LEGISLATOR TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. LEGISLATURE
TRIED TO ENTER MILLION AND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
THE EROSION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT TO REACT
TO THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. INSTEAD WE NEED TO
LEVERAGE LESSONS LEARNED
THROUGHOUT COVER NINETEEN AND
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ADEQUATELY FUNDED NOW. OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS NEED TO
INCREASE CRITICAL STAFFING
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
INVESTIGATORS HEALTH EDUCATORS
DATA ARCHITECTS AND SYSTEMS
ANALYSTS PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
MICROBIOLOGIST AND LAB TECHS.
AND EQUITY OFFICERS ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO SUPPORT EQUITY WORK.
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS BEEN CENTRAL
TO THE CONVERSATION WORK AROUND
EQUITY FOR A LONG TIME.
INVESTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS TWO BIRDS
WITH ONE STONE IT MEANS WE'LL
BE ABLE TO WORK TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES THAT
LEAD TO INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN LAID BARE BY COPING
NINETEEN. AND THOSE SAME
STAFFER BROWN TO A AND- WELL
TRAINED EX. AND CAN. AND IT'S
TO VOTE TO. WHEN THEIR EFFORTS
TO BE DIVERTED TO A PUBLIC
CRISIS SUCH AS CARBONITE AND
FUTURE. LASTLY WE ASK FOR YOUR-
OF THREE POINT FOR ME. TO
SUPPORT AND EVALUATE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK AND IN. TO HELP
INFORM WHAT CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD
BE. AND HOW TO ENSURE A
QUALIFIED AND TRAINED WORK
FORCE IS IN PLACE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
REQUEST AND AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU MISS OFTEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND REMEMBERS MY
NAME SHOULD BE CROSSING AND I
AM AN STI YOU PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE BASED ON THE Y. AXIS FULL
BOOK AREA OF LOS ANGELES IN
ADDITION TO SERVING AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE FOR THE COUNTY I
ALSO WORK AS PART OF A
COMMUNITY EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAM. I'M HERE TODAY TWO YEARS
AFTER MAKING A SIMILAR APPEAL
IN THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC TAX TO
STATE TO SUPPORT OUR CORE
ESSENTIAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORK FORCE I
FINALLY INVESTING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. HAVE BEEN RAVAGED BY
COLBERT NINETEEN MORE
DEVASTATING LEVELS. THAN WOULD
HAVE OCCURRED HAD LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND PROFICIENTLY
STAFFED AND RESOURCE TO BEFORE
THIS PANDEMIC. I WORK WITH A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES PUBLIC
HEALTH INVESTIGATORS. ELLIS
EDUCATORS EPIDEMIOLOGISTS LAP
SCIENTISTS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WHAT QUICKLY RESPONDED
AND SHIFTED ALL OF OUR FOCUS
AND WORK TO CURBING THE SPREAD
COPY NINETEEN. YES I WOULD LIKE
TO REMIND US ALL THAT THERE ARE
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS IN
EVERYDAY COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
CONTROL WORK SEPARATE FROM
PUBLIC NINETEEN HAVE BEEN
OVERSHADOWED DUE TO THE LIMITED
CAPACITIES AND STAFFING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE. TO
ADDRESS THE CULPRIT NINETEEN
HAD TO MAKE A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I'VE BEEN REDEPLOYED
AWAY FROM CRITICAL PROGRAMMING.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH RESPONDING
TO THE CULT IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC INCLUDES NURSE FONG
TRIAGE. COBIT NINETEEN ALBERT
MANAGEMENT AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES WORKSITES EDUCATION
SECTOR OUTBREAK MANAGEMENT
STRIKING DEPLOYMENT PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE REGARDING
HOPE IT NINETEEN. BAXEEN
ADMINISTRATION AND MASKELL BIT
NINETEEN VACCINE ADMINISTRATION
AT OUR POINT OF DISPENSING
FIGHTS. MY PUBLIC COMPANY
COLLEAGUES WORKLOADS HAVE BEEN
REDIRECTED TO PRIORITIZE WILL
BE NINETEEN RELATED TASKS
PLACING OTHER ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE SERVICES SUCH AS
MANAGING THE RISE OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS. AND
ACUTE COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
LOWER ON THE PRIORITY LIST.
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF ALSO WORK
ON HEALTH EQUITY ISSUES AND
REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES BY
DOING OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT
TO ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND COMMUNITIES IMPACTED
BY CHRONIC BURDEN OF DISEASES
THIS MARKET HAS ALSO BEEN DE
PRIORITIZED UNFORTUNATELY.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
HIT INSTEAD WE MUST INVEST IN
AND REBUILD OUR CORE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. AS A SECOND
GENERATION PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
NOT ONLY THE OPPORTUNITY BUT
ALSO THE OBLIGATION TO RECTIFY
THIS ONLY WITH THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT AN ONGOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM MISS
BLOOMBERG. MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES IN AN EFFORT
TO MORE READILY RECRUIT AND
STREAMLINE TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS DURING THE PANDEMIC
HAS PROPOSED TEMPERATE
TEMPORARY NURSE ASSISTANT
PROGRAM WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR
ELIGIBLE CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANT CANDIDATES TO BE
TRAINED QUICKLY THE PAID DURING
THEIR TRAINING AND PROVIDE
SERVICES AS THEY BECOME
QUALIFIED AND COMPETENT WITH
EACH SKILL. CNA'S PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL INVALUABLE CARES A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
RESIDENTS IT IS A CONSTANT
STRUGGLE FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN THE NEEDED CNA'S TO
PROVIDE THIS NECESSARY CARE. IT
HAS BEEN EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
STRUGGLE WITH THE COBRA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT IS NOT
ONLY CHALLENGING TO FIND C. N.
A.'S BUT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR AN ACE TO COMPLETE THEIR
TRAINING PROGRAM AND GET A
TESTING DATE SET TO OBTAIN
THEIR CERTIFICATION. FOR MANY
FACILITIES AND RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS THERE'S NO
LONGER A TRAINING PROGRAM CLOSE
BITES TO WORK WITH. AS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF CNA'S AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND MORE
QUICKLY RECRUIT DIRECT CARE
GIVERS SHE MANY STATES HAVE
AUTHORIZED THE UTILIZATION OF
TEMPORARY NURSE ASSISTANTS.
TNA'S ARE PROVIDED WITH INITIAL
TRAINING AND ORIENTATION
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND HEALTH
SCREENS. THEIR CLINICAL
TRAINING IS UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF NURSING STAFF AT
THE FACILITY. THEIR CLINICAL
COMPETENCY IS OBSERVING
COMPLETED PRIOR TO PROVIDING
ANY DIRECT CARE SERVICES TO
RESIDENTS. AS THEY PERFORM
TASKS THIS IS DONE UNDER THE
MENTORSHIP OF A TRAINED
EXPERIENCED CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT AND DIRECTOR OF STAFF
DEVELOPMENT. IT IS STIMATED
THAT THIS PROPOSAL WILL HAVE A
ONE TIME COST FOR CDPH SAID
PROVED CNA TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS OF NO MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. CANCER
RECENTLY MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ABOUT ARTICLES TO STREAMLINE
THE CURRENT CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT TRAINING PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN KANSEN NECK. WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THEIR
INTEREST IN WORKING ON A
SOLUTION AND HOPE TO DISCUSS TO
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS. ANY
STREAMLINED OPTION TO TRAIN AND
PROVIDE TIMELY EMPLOYMENT TO
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING WORK IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WILL
HELP ADDRESS THE CURRENT
CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF DIRECT
CARE STAFF AND NURSING HOMES.
THANK YOU. MR VANO. YES THANK
YOU SIR SO WE DID MEET WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS REGARDING
THIS PROPOSAL- AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE COME UP WITH A-
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION WHERE WE
CAN ADMINISTRATIVELY. MEET THE
NEEDS AND THRUST OF WHAT THE
INDUSTRY IS PROPOSING MY WAIVER
MODIFICATION TO ONE OF OUR-
AFL'S ARE ALSO A LETTERS THAT
HAS OF COURSE AFFECTED OF
REGULATIONS. SO WITH THE OTHER
WE CAN MODIFY THAT LETTER TO
ALLOW THE TEMPER NURSE
ASSISTANT WHO CAN BE EMPLOYED.
AT THE LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
WELL CURRENTLY UNDERGOING A
TRAINING PROGRAM WITH ONE OF
OUR DISTANCE LEARNING. TRAINING
SITES. SO WE ARE PROPOSING THAT
THE TEMPERATURE SYSTEM WE'RE IN
ROLE IN ONE OF THESE E.
LEARNING PROGRAMS A FURTHER
THEIR CLICK THERE ARE TRAINING
ON OTHER BOOK TRAINING. AND
THEN THEY WILL SHOW UP FOR WORK
AT THE LOCAL SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY WHERE THE- DIRECTOR OF
STAFF DEVELOPMENT WE'RE- MY-
AND VIEW THE TECHNICAL ARE
SKILL. SIGN UP FOR THE
COMPANY'S AS- THEY B. AS A
BECOME MORE COMPLIANT WITH
THEIR KNOWLEDGE BASE IN THROUGH
THIS CRISIS THE FACILITY WILL
BE ABLE TO COUNT THIS TORRENT
NURSE ASSISTANT TOWARDS YOUR-
THREE POINT FIVE. OF STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS WELL THEY GAIN
MORE CONGRESS HE'S BECOME A CNA
AND ULTIMATELY PASS AT SEA IN
THE EXAMINATION. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH WITH INDUSTRY ON
IS MORE ADVANTAGEOUS THAN WHAT
IS BEING PROPOSED- I WE THIS
LANGUAGE. IN THE SENSE THAT.
THE PERSON GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT WE ARE ENVISIONING
WOULD PROVIDE THE FULL SCOPE OF
TRAINING. TO BECOME A CNA- AS
OPPOSED TO THE APPROVING
ANOTHER CURRICULUM WHERE THEY
WOULD NOT MEET THE FULL CNA
CERTIFICATIONS END OF THAT
TRAINING. SO WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY OKAY HAVE COME TO US
WITH THE PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO KIND OF LOOK INTERNALLY.
AND FIND. WHAT WE HOPE IS A
SOLUTION- AND MR SOLUTION. WE
ARE DRAFTING. REVISIONS TO THE
LETTER THAT I JUST MENTIONED
AND WE WILL BE SHARING THAT BUT
LETTER WITH OUR- STAKEHOLDERS
HOPEFULLY TOWARDS THE END OF
THIS WEEK MAYBE EARLY NEXT
WEEK. FOUR COMMENTS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE ON HOW WE CAN. MOVE
THAT LETTER FOR SO WE'RE
HOPEFUL HOPING THAT WE CAN-
HITCHES. WORK MARELLI- WITHIN
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AND GET
NEW PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING
FOR. GROWING OR CNA WORK FORCE.
THANK YOU SIR. THAT CONCLUDES
THIS POINT PANEL I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE- COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THEM
THANK YOU TO THE PANEL FOR
BRINGING UP THIS DISCUSSION I
THINK WHAT WE SEE HERE WITH
THIS PROPOSALS BOTH OF THEM
COMING FORWARD. IS WHAT'S BEEN
LACKING IN THE DISCUSSION OF
HAVING THE LOCAL VOICE- BEING
ABLE TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF-
DISCUSSION ON HOW THESE THINGS
ARE ROLLING OUT AT THE COUNTY.
MYSELF AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN- LOOKING ON TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
DISTRIBUTION PLAN HOW TO GET
THE VACCINES OUT. WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT. RIGHT SO
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BUDGET THE
FINANCING PART OF IT. BUT JUST
WHEN I GET TO OUR COUNTY AND
LEARN ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION
PLAN WHERE IT'S MOVING- THINGS
CHANGE SO NOW YOU HAVE A THIRD
PARTY- PERSON COMING INTO. THE
HOLY QUESTION SO NOW WE HAVE TO
RE ADJUST AND LEARN AND BE ABLE
TO ANSWER. OUR CONSTITUENTS-
ONE MORE TIME. SO I THINK
LOOKING AT THESE PROPOSALS
COMING FORWARD- IN THIS- PANEL-
HAS THE INPUT OF. OF THOSE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND OFFERING
SOLUTIONS TO. A PROBLEM NOT
JUST NOW TALKING ABOUT A
PROBLEM OF HOW WE'RE GONNA GET
THE VACCINES OUT. INTO THE
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED. BUT
NOW OFFERING SOME TYPES OF
SOLUTIONS. SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD
BE USED ON C. N. A.'S THAT
ALREADY THERE IN THE GROUP ON
THE GROUND. TO BE ABLE TO SPEED
UP THAT VACCINE GETTING INTO
PEOPLE IN OUR IN OUR AREAS. SO
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE THERE AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'VE I'VE
HEARD- IN IN THE PRIOR PANELS I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA DIGRESS A
LITTLE BIT BUT WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT. WE'RE GOING TO GET TO
WHERE THE VACCINES WON'T NEED
THE DEEP FREEZING COMPONENTS OF
IT. BUT YET ISN'T IT RIGHT- YES
SOMEONE CAN ANSWER THIS FOR ME.
IS THAT WHEN WE GET TO THOSE
VACCINES THAT DON'T NEED THAT
DEEP FREEZING THE LIKE MODERN
AND FISER DO. ALSO THE
PERCENTAGE OF HOW- ACTIVE THOSE
VACCINES ARE IN COMBAT IN THE
BACKSEAT THE- CLOVER NINETEEN
STARTS TO DWINDLE ALSO SOBRE TO
SAVING THAT. AS AN ANSWER FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
INCLUDING THE NATIVE AMERICANS.
I THINK WE HAVE MORE
DISCUSSION. ON THAT THAT
COMPONENT ITSELF. I THINK WHEN
YOU START TO LOOK AT- THE
PROPSAL COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE SUB ONE- PROPOSAL ONE
STARTS TO TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
SITES THAT ARE THERE AND BEING
ABLE. HAVE THAT- THE E. VALLEY
EVALUATION OF THOSE THAT ARE
THERE IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE-
HEARING AGAIN FROM THE
COUNTIES- C. SACK IN THOSE THAT
ARE THERE AND LEARNING NOW FROM
THIS PRESENTATION THAT THE
SECOND SHOT OF VACCINE IS THE
SAME VACCINE THAT'S GIVEN IN
THE FIRST ROUND. AND SO FOR
HEARING FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE THAT TOOK THAT
GOT THE FIRST VACCINE AND NOW
ARE ABLE TO GET THE SECOND
VACCINE MAKING SURE THE
LOGISTICALLY THE
INFRASTRUCTURES THERE SO THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS COME BACK. ON
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S BEING DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE HEARD IN
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION OF HOWTHE
STATE IN THE THIRD PARTY IN
OVERSEEING SOME OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS I GET IT WE
SAT ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR SOMETIME AND WE
KNOW IT'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
SO THERE COULD BE FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT PLANS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. BUT WHAT WE SEE HERE NOW
TODAY IS THOSE ARE ON THE
GROUND LEVEL ACTUALLY MAKING
THAT IMPACT- FOR OUR LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE THERE AND
SO MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE FOR THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WERE CARING
FOR WHATEVER MIGHT HAPPEN NEXT
WEEK OR THE WEEK BEFORE ART
WEEK AFTER AS FAR AS CHANGES.
TO A DISTRIBUTION PLAN THAT'S
HERE I THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE.
SURE THAT THERE'S SOME TYPE OF
LEAD WAY. TO THOSE THAT ARE
MINISTER. ON THOSE VACCINES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. MEANING HOW
CAN YOU PLAN HOW CAN YOU EVEN
PLAN A BUSINESS IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S COMING UP DOWN THE
ROAD. AND IF YOU PLAN FOR
WHAT'S COMING UP DOWN THE ROAD
AND IT CHANGES ON YOU. THEN HOW
DO YOU QUICKLY MOVE AND ADAPT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE IN THE
PUBLIC OUR CONSTITUENTS. TRULY
UNDERSTAND I HAVE FAITH IN WHAT
IT IS WE'RE DOING AND FAITH
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WE GOT SO MANY CALLS
COMING TO OUR OFFICE ONCE THERE
WAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT OF SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER. BUT YET WE'RE
IS THAT WORK ABILITY WITH THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHAT I SEE HERE IN
THESE TWO PROPOSALS COMING
FORWARD. AGAIN I'LL MAKE THAT
VOICE BE HEARD THAT I THINK
THIS IS THE DISCUSSION THAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING. FROM THE
LOCAL INPUT TO THOSE ON THE
GROUND AND OFFERING SOLUTIONS
NOT JUST. CRITICIZING THAT THIS
PLAN IS IT WORKING OR THIS
ISN'T WORKING OF THE STATE
OVERSIGHT ISN'T WORKING. A
THIRD PARTY NOW IS COMING INTO
AND THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK NOW
THIS PLAN. STARTS TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS AND I THINK IT HAS IT
HAS MERIT. IN ITS PRESENTATION.
I THINK IT'S A VOICE THAT NEEDS
TO BE HEARD. AND AS THINGS
START TO MOVE FORWARD I WOULD
ENCOURAGE- THAT WE LOOK INTO
THESE THINGS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT COME UP.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. THE FAITH
THAT THIS THIS BODY THIS STATE
IS MOVING FORWARD IN THE
CONTABILIDADE OF THOSE THAT ARE
OUT THERE. WHO KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT WEEK WHO'S
GOING TO THEN BE ALL BE ABLE TO
GET THE VACCINE AND YET OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ISN'T THERE WE
HAVE TO BE THE ONES TO ANSWER
TO OUR COMMUNITIES. AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A CALMNESS IN
A IN A TRANSITION MOVING
FORWARD. SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT THERE WOULD BE ONGOING
DISCUSSION WITH THOSE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. MAYBE EVEN SOME
TYPE OF A HEADS UP OF WHAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE SO THAT PEOPLE
COULD REACT TO IT. AND TO
CREATE A PLAN THAT STARTS TO
COME OUT AS MATT IT YOU KNOW
ONCE THERE'S A SOMETHING THAT'S
ANNOUNCED. THAT THEN THERE'S A
PLAN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL THIS. PAGE SAYING THE SAME.
BECAUSE OF WORDS HAVING TO SAY
ONE THING. LOCALS ARE SAYING
ANOTHER WE HEARD ON THE CALL
HERE TODAY THAT IT'S ALL OVER
THE PLACE BLIND IN THE FOG.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN'T
DO AS ELECTED LEADERS THESE ARE
THINGS AT THE STATE LEVEL WE
ALL HAVE TO BE SAYING THE SAME
MESSAGE. SO THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TRULY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR BEST WILL
IT IS WHAT WE'RE TAKING CARE OF
HERE IN THIS IN THIS CHAMBERS.
SO WITH THIS MARRIAGE OF THESE
TWO PROPOSALS MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK IT'S A VOICE THAT'S BEEN
MISSING BUT IT ALSO OFFERS A
SOLUTION RATHER THAN
CRITICIZING. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I JUST WANTED TO ASK- I KNOW
READING OVER THESE PROPOSALS
THERE'S A REOCCURRING- CONCERN
OR OR OR OR ISSUE TO ADDRESS
WHICH IS STAFFING AND PERSONNEL
NEEDS- DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PIPELINE
BEING TRAINED TO ADDRESS THESE
PROPOSALS I KNOW THAT THE THAT
THE CHAIR AND NUMBER OF A OF
THE MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE.
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT OVER
THE LONG TERM ABOUT JUST
SHORTAGES OF STAFF- TRAINING
PROGRAMS- PIPELINES PATHWAYS-
ESPECIALLY FOR MYSELF AND THOSE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY- WE HAVE
A CERTAINLY STAFFING CHALLENGES
BUT WE OFFICE OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
CONCERNS ABOUT TRYING TO FIND
THOSE PEOPLE AND GET HIM INTO
THE INTO THE AREAS THAT ARE
NEEDED SO HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS OR HOW WOULD WE
ASK OUR THOSE CONCERNS
ADDRESSING THESE PROPOSALS.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY NAME IS
MICHELLE GIVEN THE NAME OF T.
ACT AND I AND LIKE TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION IF YOU DON'T MIND. I
THINK THAT'S SUCH A GREAT
QUESTION TO RAISE I KNOW WE
HAVE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IN THE
PIPELINE. A PART OF THE REASON
WHY WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD THE
BILL AB TWO FORTY IS TO NOT
JUST LOOK AT THE IMMEDIATE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE. BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
NEED THAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO
DO JUST THAT TO HAVE THAT
ADEQUATELY SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE IMPACT PLAN IN PLACE.
I MEAN I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT IS THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WORK OVER. THE LAST FEW
YEARS LOOKING AT TYPE LINES TO
HEALTHCARE REPORT I THINK- PART
OF THE COMMISSION'S FINDINGS-
THAT WAS FOUND WAS THAT. PUBLIC
HEALTH REPORTS WITH ONE OF THE
TOP WORKFORCE AREAS THAT WE
NEEDED TO INVEST IN AS WELL BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME AD. KIND
OF INCENTIVES TO DRIVE UP THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE I'LL
GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
ABOUT CRITICAL WORKFORCE THAT
WE NEED AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. SUCH AS PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES MANY OF THEM ARE
REGISTERED NURSES THAT GO ON
AND THEY HAVE TO GET ANOTHER
CREDIT CREDENTIAL BEYOND TO THE
R. N. THAT THEY THEY HAVE TO
PAY ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND TAKE
ADDITIONAL CLASSES TO GET THAT
CERTIFICATION. AND YET- WE HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE NEED TO GROW THAT PIPELINE
AND INCENTIVIZE MORE TO COME
INTO THAT FIELD. SO I THINK-
PART OF THEIR YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A TWO PRONGED APPROACH THE
FIRST PRONG IS REALLY LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE INCREASE THE
RESOURCES FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO BE ABLE TO RAMP
UP THEIR STAFFING CAPACITY
BECAUSE YOU HEARD BY DIRECTOR.
ABBAS EARLIER TODAY WE DO RISK
LOSING MANY OF THE POSITIONS
THAT WE STOCK UP OR THROUGH
COLD. THEY COULD THEN BE
TRANSLATED TO WORKING ON OTHER
THINGS TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
CRITICAL ISSUES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO THAT'S THE
FIRST APPROACH IS GETTING THE
RESOURCES SO THAT THEY CAN
INCREASE THEIR STAFFING AND
SELECT. STAFFING COULD BE
FLEXIBLE BECAUSE WHAT WE ALSO
HAVE IS A LOT OF CATEGORICAL
FUNDING THAT REQUIRES YOU TO
ONLY HAVE A STAFF THAT CAN DO
THIS DISEASE ONLY AND CAN'T
REALLY TRANSLATE TO OTHER
THINGS. BUT THE SECOND PRONG
APPROACH IS REALLY AT AND. THE
REASON WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
STUDY TO BE FUNDED AS A THAT WE
CAN REALLY LOOK AT. OKAY HOW DO
WE GET THIS WORK FOR. WHAT'S
WHAT DOES THE WORK FIRST TO
LOOK LIKE IN A LITTLE. DEPART
BUT WHEN HE IT ALSO. TO LOOK AT
IN ORDER TO IN. THAT WE-
SKILLED AND HIGHLY TRAINED
STAFF AND- AGAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY. LABORATORY AND-
OTHERS. MANY CLASSIFICATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE HIGHLY SKILLED
AND SPECIALIZED. R. AS THE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. THAT THAT
RESPONSE AND I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH YOU I KNOW THE CHAIR HAS
BEEN VERY PASSIONATE UNITED
TALKED ABOUT EXPANDING PROGRAMS
GREEN PATHWAYS- ESPECIALLY FOR
US IN THE CENTER VALLEY. THE
CHAIR KNOWS THAT WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A NEED FOR THOSE
SPECIALIST SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THE AND
THE CHAIR ON THIS- YOU KNOW
CREATING THOSE PROGRAMS EXPAND
THOSE PROGRAMS AND GREEN AS
PATHWAYS. ARE ESSENTIAL TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS AND I THINK THAT'S-
THE REAL ONCERN I DO AGREE
WITH US AROUND US.THE PROGRAM
THE- FOURTEENTH BUT PUSHED OUT
BUT- WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL ISSUES TOO. THANK
YOU. I WILL MENTION JUST A
COMMON WITHOUT. INHERENTLY
HAVING TO ASK QUESTIONS BUT
REALLY WANTED TO- FOLLOW UP
WITH WITH WHAT MESS AUSSIE HAD
SAID. WHICH WAS IN REGARDS TO-
THERE ARE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THEY HAVE NOT BECOME
COUNTY. DEPARTMENTS OF COVERT
NINETY SIX. AND SO IF WERE
LISTENING EFFECTIVELY TO THE
DIRECTOR BOSS. I REALLY WANT TO
ECHO IN AGREE WITH HER THAT WE
CAN'T WAIT TO REACT. THAT WE DO
HAVE TO. LEVERAGE THE LESSONS
LEARNED AND TACKLING DR KELLY
WE HAVE TO USE COPING. NINETEEN
AS AN EXCEL AROUND FOR US TO
CHANGE. NOW WITH SO MUCH FOCUS
AND EMPHASIS ON PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS YEAR- SHAME ON US IF WE
CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO.
CONTINUE TO ELEVATE- THOSE WHO
ARE WORKING IN PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDENTS WHO HAVE AN INTEREST
IN THIS AREA. TO GO AND FOCUS
IN THIS AREA THERE ARE SO MANY
CONCERNS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH IN
OUR POOR AND ARE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THAT. I REALLY SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR US TO.
CAPTURE THIS MOMENT AND TO RISE
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC STRONGER
THAN WE WENT IN. WITH THAT- WE
WILL MOVE ON FROM ISSUE FOR AND
GO TO KENNEL FIVE. WHERE WE
WILL HAVE SEVEN PRESENTERS. IT
WILL BEGIN WITH MISS BLOOMBERG.
THEN MISS MURRAY'S MYSTERIOUS
MISS FLORI- AND WE WILL GO
DIRECTLY DOWN FROM THERE SO IF
WE CAN START WITH MISS
BLOOMBERG PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND AN EFFORT
TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
IMMEDIATE STAFFING NEEDS OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES DO
TEN PRESIDENTE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. COUPLED WITHAN
ALREADY COMPRESSED AND
COMPETITIVE EMPLOYEE MARKET CAP
IS PROPOSING THAT MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR STAFFING AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES HE
PAID AT A 100% OF COST. WE
BELIEVE THIS INFUSION OF FUNDS
WILL PLACE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND A MORE
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE AND THE
WORK FORCE MARKET PLACE AS
THESE HOMES TRYING TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN QUALIFIED QUALIFIED
DIRECT CARE STAFF. ONE OF THE
MAJOR CHALLENGES FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AS TO PAY
COMPETITIVE WAGES UNDER A MEDIC
HOW REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT'S-CURRENTLY CAPS LIMITED BY
BUDGET FUNDS AND PAID TO
FACILITIES TO YEARS AND
ARREARS. WE ARE ALSO SEEING
INCREDIBLE STAFFING CHALLENGES
AND LONG TERM CARE AS EMPLOYEES
NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF FOR MANY
REASONS INCLUDING QUARANTINE
DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EXPOSURE. CHILD CARE ISSUES AND
SICK OR PAID FAMILY LEAVE. BY
PAYING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AT A 100% OF THEIR
LABOR COSTS AND A TIMELY
MANNER. THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
ADDED SUPPORT AND FUNDS TO
OFFER WAGES TO ATTRACT AND KEEP
THEIR DIRECT CARE STAFF. THE
CURRENT MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO REIMBURSE
NURSING FACILITIES ON A
FACILITY BASED ATTITUDE AND
PREDETERMINED COST. BASED RATES
UNFORTUNATELY FACILITY RATES
ARE NOT ACTUALLY STRUCTURED SO
FULLY FUND NURSING FACILITY
COSTS OF LABOR. RATES ARE FIRST
SETS AT THE NINETY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF NURSING
FACILITIES LABOR COSTS. ARE
FURTHER LIMITED BASED ON A
FACILITIES GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
THEN ADDITIONALLY THE RATES ARE
REDUCED BY THE STATE'S OVERALL
PROGRAMMATIC BUDGETARY LIMITS.
BY REMOVING THE LABOR PORTION
OF RATES FROM THE LESSER
PERCENTILE THE GEOGRAPHIC
CAPPING AND THE OVERALL
BUDGETARY LIMITS LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES WILL BE ADEQUATELY
REIMBURSED FOR THEIR LABOR
COSTS. AND PROVIDED ASSURANCES
THAT IF THEY INCREASE WAGES
MEDIC HOW RATES WILL FULLY
REFLECT THE INCREASES PAID.
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
PROPOSAL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND NOW
THEY MIGHT HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE TRAINING FEDERAL APPROVALS
FOR THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR.
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE THESE
DISCUSSIONS TO SEE IF A
COMPROMISE SOLUTION CAN BE
REACHED. SH. THANK YOU MR
MURRAY. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA I APPRECIATE BEING
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS ERICA
MARIE I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HOUSES.
WE REPRESENTATIVE TWENTY ONE
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BUT
INCLUDE COUNTY OWNED OR
AFFILIATED SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
THE FIVE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL CENTERS.
THESE SYSTEMS PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
TO ROUGHLY THREE MILLION
PATIENTS EACH YEAR. MOST OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE EITHER ON ANOTHER
CALL I MET CAL OR UNINSURED.
MANY ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IMMIGRANTS OR HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
KOPET NINETEEN IN OTHER WAYS.
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
OUR SYSTEMS HAVE PLAYED AN
INTEGRAL ROLE LARGELY IN FOUR
KEY WAYS FIRST WE REDESIGNED
OUR HOSPITALS AND EXPANDED
CAPACITY TO PREPARE FOR AND
THEN RESPOND TO RECORD
INCREASES IN HOSPITALIZATIONS.
THIS REQUIRED OVERHAULING
OPERATIONS TO EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF BEDS SET UP ALTERNATIVE CARE
SITES IT PULLS STAFF FROM
OUTPATIENT CENTERS TO HELP WITH
IMPATIENT NEEDS. SECOND HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED- ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANTLY TODAY WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING AND DISTRIBUTING
VACCINES THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL CENTERS
PARTICIPATED IN ALL PHASE THREE
TRIALS FOR THE VISOR IN
MATERNAL VACCINES AND ALL OF
OUR SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL
IN THE LOCAL PLANNING AND
ADMINISTRATION EFFORTS WITH A
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON REACHING
LOW INCOME AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. THIRD WE'VE
INCREASED TESTING DESPITE THE
SURGE IN THE ROLLOUT OF THE
VACCINE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS HAVE MAINTAINED THEIR
TESTING CAPABILITY. AND FOURTH
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
FOR THIS DISCUSSION WE PROVIDED
TARGETED SUPPORT AND NOT REACH
TO VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR COMMUNITY. VISITING LOCAL
FARMS AND PACKING FACILITIES TO
DISBURSE MASKS AND PROVIDE
TRAININGS IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
ON SOCIAL DISTANCING AND HOW TO
ACCESS CARE GOING TO LOCAL
NURSING HOMES TO PROVIDE
TRAINING ON HOW TO USE GPS IS.
ACTUAL CONTROL AND DEPLOYING
STREET TEAMS TO PROVIDE TESTING
ON THE GROUND EDUCATION FOR
HOMELESS POPULATIONS ON HOW TO
STAY SAFE. SO SUPPORT THESE FOR
ROLES AND MAINTAIN SYSTEM
OPERATIONS PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN LEVERAGING
ALL AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDING
SOURCES. INCLUDING PROVIDING
RELIEF FUNDS. BMO SUPPORTS
CARES ACTED AND FLEXIBILITY
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED THROUGH
AN EMERGENCY MEDICAID WAIVER.
BUT CRITICAL GAPS REMAIN.
PLEASE SINCE AUGUST WE HAVE
SEEN AN INPATIENT VOLUME
INCREASE OF NEARLY 30% AND R.
I. C. U. VOLUME HAS NEARLY
DOUBLED DUE TO THE IMPACT OF
COOK AT NINETEEN. BECAUSE
PUBLIC HOSPITALS ARE ABLE TO
PUT UP THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
FOR INPATIENT MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE PATIENTS MANY OF THESE
COSTS HAVE GONE ON REIMBURSED.
WE'VE HAD TO SHIFT SERVICES
AWAY FROM OUTPATIENT SETTINGS
WHERE WE DO RECEIVE STATE
GENERAL FUND TO CARE FOR
INPATIENT ESPECIALLY I. C. U.
PH. AND THEREFORE WE ARE
SEEKING THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
IN THIS BUDGET REQUEST SHE
SUPPORT THESE UNREIMBURSED
COSTS AS WELL AS COSTS RELATED
TO VACCINES AND TO STAFFING ME.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ALL THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED TODAY
DURING THIS INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING TIME PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS ARE AN ENORMOUS
ASSET ASSET TO CALIFORNIA AND
WE STAND READY TO HELP IN ANY
WAY WE CAN. THANK YOU FOR THE
CAN YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST. THANK YOU MR MURRAY
MISTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS M. J. DíAS AND I WILL
BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ON TOP
OF THAT COS ARE SEIU MEMBER WHO
COULD NO LONGER MAKE TODAY'S
HEARING I WILL BE READING A
BRIEF STATEMENT ON HER BEHALF
AND I WILL BEGIN NOW WE ARE
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVE THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
REQUEST OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. TO HELP OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITALS SERVING A
LARGE NUMBER OF COLD IN
NINETEEN MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE PATIENTS AS WELL AS
FUNDING TO SUPPORT VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AND ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AS AN ELIGIBILITY
WORKER AT HIGHLAND HOSPITAL IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I NEED VERY
SICK PATIENTS IN THE ER AND
SCREEN THEM TO DETERMINE THEIR
HEALTH COVERAGE OR PAY OR
SOURCES OVER 90% OF THE TIME
IT'S MEDIC COW. I'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND HOW THE SICKEST PEOPLE TRY
SO HARD TO AVOID SEEKING CARE
EVEN WENT COLD IN NINETEEN
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD THE
COST OF HOSPITAL CARE I'VE HELP
UNINSURED DOCUMENTED AND
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS WHAT COLD
ED NAVIGATE. DIFFERENT S. A. L.
FOR. SUCH AS COVERED. OR OUR
ALLEN YOU COUNTY SPECIFIC
INDIGENT HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS IF
THEY ARE UNDOCUMENTED WHICH AS
YOU KNOW THESE COUNTY PROGRAMS
ARE VERY LIMITED. THE BEAUTIFUL
THING ABOUT WORKING ON A SAFETY
NET HOSPITAL IS THAT WE DO NOT
TURN PEOPLE AWAY UNLIKE OTHER
HOSPITALS. WE TAKE THE BRUNT
AND SERVE THE SICKEST PATIENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. MOST OF WHICH ARE OUR
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. I'VE SEEN HOW OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITAL RECEIVED MANY
PATIENT TRANSFERS FROM
DIFFERENT HOSPITALS GIVEN OUR
ROLE AS A SAFETY NET. OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITALS CONTINUE TO
GRAPPLE WITH DRAMATIC SURGE OF
POSITIVE CASES AND
HOSPITALIZATION AS A PANDEMIC
WERE WORSENED. WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WILL
BREAK AND WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
HOSPITAL CARE TO THE SICKEST
PATIENTS MOST OF WHICH ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. ARE FOR ALL
THESE REASONS AND MORE PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET REQUEST
THAT WILL HELP HELPED IN OUR
PUBLIC PARKS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME WILL
MOVE TO- MISS FLOORING. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES OKAY. GOOD AFTER A
GOOD EVENING THIS IS JENNIFER
LAURIE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY- IN ADDITION TO
THE SHARP FOCUS BEING PLACED ON
HEALTH DISPARITIES DUE TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC CONSUMER
ADVOCATES HAVE ALSO TURNED
RENEWED ATTENTION TO THE
BARRIERS ELIGIBLE PEOPLE FACE
WHEN THEY NEED MATTER HOW.
WHILE MOST PEOPLE WATCHING
EXPECTED A RECORD HIGH
MACCALLUM MOMENT GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT JOB LOSS IN
CALIFORNIA THE PROJECTED CHANGE
IN ENROLLMENT HAS NOT BORNE
OUT. WHEN BARRIERS TO
ENROLLMENT EXIST DISPARITIES
ARE EXACERBATED AND THE HIT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE
HARDEST. CONSUMER ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH DH CS
AND OTHERS TO- TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON WITH MEDIC CALLIN
ROMANCE AND TO WORK ON OUT
REGION OTHER ISSUES- AND TO
THEIR CREDIT DH CS HAS WORKED
HARD WITH CONSUMER ADVOCATES TO
BEGIN TO ROLL OUT AT POSTON
ROMAN VERIFICATION OF INCOME.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THIS WILL
TAKE SOME TIME TO IMPLEMENT
INTO ALL OF THE RELEVANT
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEMS INCOME
VERIFICATION IS OFTEN THE ONE
THING THAT HOLDS UP A MEDIC CAL
APPLICATION AND WHEN SOMEONE
LOSES A JOB OR HAS THEIR HOURS
REDUCED THE DATA THAT IS
AVAILABLE ELECTRONICALLY SUCH
AS TAX OR PAYROLL INFORMATION.
IS RARELY UPDATED QUICKLY
ENOUGH. TO BE OF USE AT THE
TIME OF APPLICATION. DURING THE
EXISTING HEALTH CRISIS DH CS
HAS BEEN ABLE TO USE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY PROCEDURES TO
SIMPLIFY ELIGIBILITY
VERIFICATION ALLOWING COUNTY
WORKERS TO DO MUCH MORE OVER
THE PHONE. ONCE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDS WE'D LIKE TO
KEEP THE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY
THAT IS ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW. WE KNOW THAT THE NEED FOR
MEDICARE WON'T AND WHEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTHEMERGENCY IS
LIFTED AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ONCE THE RELATED MORATORIUM ON
MEDICAL TERMINATIONS IS LIFTED.
BUT THE COUNTY WORKERS WILL
NEED TO CONDUCT MILLIONS OF
REDETERMINATION. GIVEN THIS
CONTEXT WE WOULD LIKE TO
REVISIT THE RELIANCE ON SWORN
PAPER AFFIDAVITS WHEN SOMEONE
NEEDS TO GIVE A REASONABLE
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY THEIR
INCOME OR PROPERTY DOES NOT
MATCH AVAILABLE RECORDS. OR
OTHER LIMITED TIMES WHEN
RECORDS ARE JUST NOT AVAILABLE
AND SELF ATTESTATION IS
PERMITTED UNDER FEDERAL
REGULATIONS. D. H. CS HAS
EXISTING GUIDANCE TO GET OUT
CALORIES ON HOW TO ALLOW
SOMEONE TO SELF TEST OVER THE
PHONE BUT THE PART OF THIS
GUIDANCE. PART OF THIS GUIDANCE
AS PERMISSIVE AS ITS CURRENT
STATE LAW AND IT DOESN'T CHANGE
THE REQUIREMENT FOR PAPER
AFFIDAVITS UNCIRCUMCISED IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
REQUIRING PAPER IS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
COMPLETING APPLICATIONS OR
RENEWALS AND DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH MANY OF THE NO WRONG DOOR
EFFORTS IMPLEMENTED BY THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO USE THE EASIEST
METHOD OF APPLYING FOR RENEWING
METCALF. TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
WHEN SOMEBODY RENEWS MEDIC HOW
I COUNTY WORKER IS REQUIRED TO
LOOK AT EVERY ALL THE OTHER
INFORMATION THEY HAVE IN THE
COUNTY FILE TO TRY TO HIT
ELECTRONIC RESOURCES FOR
MATCHING- THE DATA THAT THE
PERSON HAS PROVIDED- OR THAT
THEY ALREADY HAD ON FILE. WHEN
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN THEN COUNTY
WORKERS REACH OUT TO THE
PERSON- TYPICALLY THEY DO THIS
OVER THE PHONE AND THEY USUALLY
MAKE TWO ATTEMPTS- IF THEY ARE
ABLE TO GET A HOLD OF THAT
PERSON IF WE WERE ALLOWING FOR
TELEPHONIC ATTESTATION AND THEY
HAVE A REASONABLE EXPLANATION
AS TO WHY THE INCOME DOESN'T
MATCH. THE ISSUE WOULD BE
RESOLVED THEN AND THERE-
WITHOUT THAT THE PERSON HAS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO A SWORN
AFFIDAVIT SIGNED IT YOU GET IT
IN THE MAIL OR GET IT OVER TO
THE COUNTY. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TRANSPORTATION
LIMITATIONS OR WHO- JUST DON'T
HAVE EASY WAYS TO DO THINGS
OVER THE INTERNET. AND I'LL
BLOW THINGS TO A WORKER. SO
WHEN THE ROOT. ARE RULES ALLOW
FOR SELF ATTESTATION. AT
TESTING OVER THE PHONE OR
ELECTRONICALLY SHOULD BE JUST
AS ACCEPTED AS IN PAPER- DH CS
MAY NEED TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATION WITH THE FEDERAL.
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES AS TO HOW TO
DO TELEPHONIC VERIFICATION WHEN
I COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE
TELEPHONIC SIGNATURE CAPABILITY
OR THAT CAPABILITY ISN'T
WORKING WE EXPECT THAT IS THAT
DISCUSSION TO BE ABOUT HOW TO
ACCURATELY TELL DOCUMENT A
TELEPHONIC SAID SIGNATURE. NOT
WHETHER ONE IS ALLOWED AT ALL
IN PRACTICAL TERMS DH CS WOULD
BE MAKING VERY MINOR CHANGES TO
ITS MAGIC ELIGIBILITY
VERIFICATION PLAN OR STATE PLAN
FILED WITH CMS SUCH AS THE
LEADING THE WORD PAPER FROM THE
PHRASE PAPER DOCUMENTATION.
OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR PLANS IN
SHORT THIS SMALL TECHNICAL
CHANGE TO ALLOW APPLICATIONS
AND RENEWALS TO BE MORE EASILY
PROCESS IF WE'RE ACCEPTING
SOMEONE'S WORD IT SHOULD BE
EQUAL ACCEPTED VERBALLY AS IT
IS IN WRITING. AS WE MOVE
THROUGH AND OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC WE SHOULD MINIMIZE THE
BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE FACE AN
APPLYING FOR IN KEEPING THEIR
MEDIC CAL PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT DUE TO
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FLORI. MISS
CROSS SIMILAR. GOOD EVENING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
LUCY QUESTION A LOT I'M HERE
THIS EVENING ON BEHALF OF
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
ACCESS WHICH IS A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION IN LOS
ANGELES THAT SERVES THOUSANDS
OF CLIENTS EACH MONTH. THE
CLIENTS HAVE BEEN C. H. ACCESS
OUR FAMILIES OF HIS DENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS PREDOMINANTLY IN
LATINO COMMUNITIES AND MANY OF
THEM ARE IMMIGRANTS OR WITH
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES. IN SOME
OF THESE ARE COMMUNITIES AT THE
EPICENTER OF THE COVE IN
NINETEEN AND DAMAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. MEDIC COBIT
NINETEEN UNINSURED PROGRAM IS
AVAILABLE WITHOUT REGARD TO
CITIZENSHIP OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND IT'S A KEY MEDICAL
PROGRAM IT COVERS TESTING FOR
KOBE. AND CO RELATED MEDICAL
TREATMENT INCLUDING INPATIENT
HOSPITAL CARE AS A PREVIOUS
ANALYST MENTIONED MANY IN THIS
COMMUNITY MORE AID. GOING TO
THE HOSPITAL EVEN WITH KOBE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY. SO
DISSEMINATING INFORMATION ABOUT
MEDIC HOUSE COBIT NINETEEN.
COVERAGE AND MAKING THE PROCESS
CONSUMER FRIENDLY SO THAT
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES CAN BE
INCLUDED TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE THIS PROGRAM OR
PARAMOUNT. FOR RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT THE APPLICATION FORM
FOR MEDIC CAL SCOBIE NINETEEN
OPTIONS SURE TO PROGRAM AND THE
WAY INFORMATION IS COLLECTED
ABOUT STATUS BE MODIFIED.
GENERAL MATHS COULD STILL BE
CLAIMS WHICH OF COURSE IS
ESSENTIAL. BUT WE REALLY NEED
TO IMPROVE THE WAY THE
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED SO
THAT FAMILIES WILL BE LESS
AFRAID. TO FLY IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE. CHANGES WHAT ARE X.
IT IN. OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
CAN BE UNDER. BY THE LOCAL
LATINO HEALTH TASK FORCES AND
OTHERS WHO ARE COLLABORATING
WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
ENTITIES AND COMMUNITY CLINICS
WHO ARE THE PROVIDERS CERTIFIED
TO USE THE PLATFORM OR RULE
THAT. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON THIS ISSUE FOR SOME
TIME AND WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT FEELS THAT.
CURRENT FEDERAL GUIDANCE- BE
AND HERE TO A SOLUTION WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT HE DISAGREED WITH
THAT INTERPRETATION OF THE
SHIFTING CHANNELS BY. WHAT HARM
WOULD THERE BE AN ASKING THE
PRIVATE MINISTRATION WORK
CLARIFICATION WORK IF NECESSARY
ADDITIONAL MORE COMPLETE
FEDERAL GUIDANCE TO HELP
CALIFORNIA SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
CONTROL TO HELP AFTER DOES THAT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
FACING IN OUR AND ENROLLMENT IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY IS THE
CONCERN INTERFERE ABOUT
QUESTIONS BEING ASKED FOR
STATUS AND WHO CAN BLAME THE
COMMUNITY AFTER ALL THEY'VE
BEEN THROUGH ESPECIALLY IN
RECENT YEARS. WE HAVE BEEN ONE
OF THE BIGGEST BOOSTERS AND
SUPPORTERS OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
COBIT AND INSURED PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA WAS OUT THE GATE
EARLY IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
WITH WHAT IT THEN CALLED THE P.
E. PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
COPING PROGRAM. AND WE APPLAUD
THE DEPARTMENT FOR ITS
INNOVATION IT'S INITIATIVE AND
ITS CREATIVITY AND HAVING
CREATED THAT AS THE STATE ONLY
PROGRAM WHICH NOW IS BEING
MATCHED WITH FEDERAL FUNDS
THROUGH THIS NEW META CAL COBIT
CATEGORY. IT REMAINS OPEN TO
ALL IMMIGRANTS AND I WANT TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR ABOUT THAT
STATUS IS NOT A DISQUALIFIER.
BUT THE CONCERN AGAIN IS THAT
THE WAY QUESTIONS ARE ASKED IS
A DETERRENT TO MANY IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. AS OTHERS SPEAKERS
HAVE NOTED UNFORTUNATELY THIS
PANDEMIC AND ITS CONSEQUENCES
WILL BE WITH US FOR A WHILE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ITSELF
ASSUMES THAT FOR THE MEDIC HOW
BUDGET. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY FEDERALLY DECLARED
WILL CONTINUE AT LEAST UNTIL
THE END OF THIS YEAR. WE KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS MANY OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS ARE BURDENED
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH ALL THE WORK
THAT IS TO BE DONE. BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT
FINDING A SOLUTION TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM OF MAKING
THE COVERED UNINSURED MEDICAL
APPLICATION PROCESS MORE
CONSUMER FRIENDLY SO THAT IT
CAN BE DEPLOYED IN COMMUNITIES
TO REACH THE FARM WORKERS TO
REACH THE FOOD WORKERS. TO
REACH PEOPLE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHERE MANY
IMMIGRANTS LIVE WORK AND GATHER
MUST BE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THE SOLUTION. THE OTHER ISSUE I
WAS ASKED TO ADDRESS. CONCERNS
HOW THE MEDICAL PROGRAM COVERS
BLOOD PRESSURE MONITORING COSTS
AND THE MONITORS THEMSELVES
DURING PREGNANCY AND GENERALLY.
WHY IS THIS SEEMINGLY DETAILED
SMALL ISSUE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION. IN
SHORT RACIAL EQUITY IN BIRTH
OUTCOMES IN OUR STATE. THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THERE'S A DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN IN HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
HYPERTENSION AND RELATED
DISORDERS THAT CAN KILL PEOPLE
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY A
CONCERN DURING PREGNANCY IN
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN ARE FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY
AS OTHER POPULATIONS TO DIE AS
A RESULT OF PREGNANCY
COMPLICATIONS. AFRICAN AMERICAN
NEWBORNS EXPERIENCE INFANT
MORTALITY RATES TWICE AS HIGH
AS OTHER NEWBORNS IN CALIFORNIA
AND UNFORTUNATELY I THINK WE
CODE PANDEMIC HAS MET WITH
ADDITIONAL STRESS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND ALREADY UNDER
SERVE ACCESS. TO MEDICAL CARE
AND SERVICES. THERE ARE
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
DOING AMAZINGLY EVIDENCED BASED
WORK TRYING TO GET OUT THESE
ISSUES THE MANY PERINATAL
HEALTH EQUITY INITIATIVES THAT
THE STATE AND OTHER ENTITIES
ARE NOW SUPPORTING. BLOOD
PRESSURE MONITORING SELF
MONITORING DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND BEYOND IS A CRITICAL PART
OF THESE INITIATIVES TO GET OUT
COULD JUST TO GET OUT THE
DISPARITIES IN BIRTH OUTCOMES.
AT PRESENT MEDI CAL PLANS HAVE
THE CHOICE TO PROVIDE THIS
ACCESS TO THE BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORING EQUIPMENT AS EITHER
A PHARMACY BENEFIT. OR AS
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT WHEN
IT'S PROVIDED AS PHARMACY. THE
PRENATAL CARE PROVIDER NEEDS
SIMPLY EMAIL THE PRESCRIPTION
TO THE PHARMACY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL'S CHOICE AND IT CAN
BE READY THE SAME DAY FOR HER
TO PICK UP RIGHT THERE AND
SHE'S LEAVING THE CLINIC OR SHE
PREFERS ON HER WAY HOME OR IN
HER NO HOME NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE
EVER THE CASE MAY BE. IN
CONTRAST WHEN THE BENEFIT AS
SOME OTHER PLANS DO IS COVERED
AS DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
THERE ARE LONG DELAYS AND THIS
IS VERY VERY DANGEROUS
ESPECIALLY IN THESE LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS. ONE APRIL FIRST
THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO LAUNCH.
A MAJOR CHANGE IN THE WAY
MEDICARE L. DELIVERS THE
PHARMACY BENEFIT THROUGH
MEDICARE ARE EX WE ARE AMONG
THE FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A MAJOR
IMPORTANT UNDERTAKING.
INVOLVING MANY PARTS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AND ALL ASPECTS OF
THE MEDICAL DELIVERY SYSTEM. IN
SOMEONE ONE MIGHT ASK WHY FOCUS
ON ONE SMALL PIECE OF THIS
BENEFIT. THE ANSWER OF COURSE
IS THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AWAY TO LOOK
AWAY FROM THE UNIQUE HEALTH
CARE NEEDS OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THIS
CRISIS AND DURING PREGNANCY.
OUR REQUEST IS THAT AT THE VERY
LEAST. THE HEALTH PLANS BE
PERMITTED TO CONTINUE GOING
FORWARD WITH THE CHOICE TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THIS BENEFIT AS PHARMACY EASY
QUICK SIMPLE TIMELY ACCESS TO
SAVE LIVES AND FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE PLANS TO BRING
EVERYONE ON BOARD THE US
SURGEON GENERAL HAS RECENTLY
RECOMMENDED THAT SELF
MONITORING OF BLOOD PRESSURE BE
DONE AND ALL PREGNANCIES. AND
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
NECESSARY THAN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WENT IN PERSON
PRENATAL CARE VISITS ARE NOT
HAPPENING AND AS WE GO FORWARD
WITH TELL THEM TELEMEDICINE
WHERE THAT WILL BE A MODALITY
USE MORE COMPLETELY. THANK YU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
AND WE ARE READY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MA'AM I MAY
HAVE DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR COOPER COMMENT
ON THE FIVE PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
JUST BEEN PRESENT. DR ARAMBULA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALBOM. TWENTY
WITH YOU ALL MOVED I'M GOING TO
START WITH. BRIEF OBSERVATION
ABOUT ACROSS FROM- COST
REGARDING OTHER NURSING SOLELY
LABOR COSTS AS MISS BLOOMBERG
SAID ON KERR IS WORKING. BUT DH
C. S. ON WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
WHAT IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL-
HE AS YOU PROBABLY RECALL-
THROUGH THE DURATION OF THE
PANDEMIC WE ARE PROVIDING A 10%
RATE BUMP ON TO THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. ALL LATER
THIS YEAR WE'RE STARTING ON
FOCUSED CONVERSATION WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS- TO. BRING
TOGETHER THE CONCEPTS- OE OF
THE BEST AND MOST ADEQUATE
RATES BUT ALSO HOW DO THEY MAKE
TO QUALITY WE DON'T WANT HER
WALKER SOLD CENTER COST BASED
APPROACH ROAD. BUT WE WANT ONE
THAT. COMPASSES QUALITY
DEMENTIA. OF DECEMBER WELL THE
CALIFORNIA CARE FOR. SURE OF
COURSE ALL CODED IMPACT SINCE
GOVERNOR SO. SERVE BUT DATABASE
THEN HAD ALL THE FRENCH-
RESIDENTS SAFETY WAS A FACTOR
OF FIVE OR SO TO ONE BETWEEN
FOR PROFIT AND NONPROFIT
NURSING FACILITIES SO THEY'RE
CLEARLY ON QUALITY ISSUES TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
ARE COMMITTED TO DOING SO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS- MISS COOPER I
THINK MAY HAVE SOME. ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. GOOD EVENING
EVERYONE SO WALK THROUGH
ADDITIONAL- FLAGS ON THE ON THE
KAFIR PUZZLE AND THEN ADDRESS
EACH OF THE OTHER I PROPOSALS-
AS WELL. UNTIL JUST A FEW
THINGS AND IN ADDITION TO
WILL'S COMMENTS- THE CLARIFY
FROM THE AGENDA RIGHT UP THE
NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE CAP IS
UTILIZED. UTILIZED TO LIMIT THE
LABOR COSTS TO THE NINETY FIFTH
PERCENTILE WITHIN THE
FACILITIES- GROUPING THE CAP
ONLY IMPACTED FORTY FIVE OUT OF
THE ONE THOUSAND AND IN THIRTY
ONE FACILITIES WE JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS
CLEAR BASED ON ON THE RIGHT
AFTER. ALSO A. B. EIGHTY ONE-
UPDATED THE PEER GROUPINGS TO
BE MORE ACCURATE- IN REGARDS TO
REFLECTING COST AND THE CAP WAS
RAISED FROM NINETY PERCENTILE
TO NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE
STARTING IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY FORWARD- AB EIGHTY ONE-
ALSO PROVIDED FACILITIES WITH
EIGHTY THREE POINT SIX TWO
PERCENT. A RATE INCREASE OF FOR
THE BRIDGE CARRIES BETWEEN
AUGUST AND DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT 5% RATE
INCREASE FOR CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THESE ARE IN
ADDITION TO THE 10% DH CS RATE
INCREASE THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
IN WHICH WILL WAS REFERENCING-
THAT 10% INCREASE. WAS THERE TO
YOU- ACKNOWLEDGED THE HIGHER
COSTS OF PROVIDING SERVICES
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WHICH INCLUDED
INCREASED LABOR COSTS-
ADDITIONALLY- THE DEPARTMENT
WANTED TO RAISE A FEW CONCERNS.
AS MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION. BY MISS
BLOOMBERG- THAT WE ALSO WANTED
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE STILL
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN REGARDS
TO WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE UPPER
PAYMENT LIMIT LIMIT. SO FEDERAL
LIMITATIONS ON SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES HAVE TO BE
REIMBURSED- BASED ON THE UPPER
LIMIT- AND THE DEPARTMENT IS.
FIVE SORRY OF THE 10% INCREASE
THAT IS CURRENTLY- IN PLACE FOR
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
SO WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
CMS ON NOT. ON ANY ADDITIONAL
COSTS- THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
PUT THAT IN JEOPARDY IN REGARDS
TO GETTING THOSE APPROVALS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY SINCE WE ALREADY
WENT OUT FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD REGARDING THE INCREASED
RATES THAT I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY ON STARTING
EFFECTIVE AUGUST FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY- THAT COULD BE AT
RISK IF WE HAD TO BOTH- BACK IN
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH CMS
REGARDING THESE PROPOSED
ADJUSTMENTS- I WOULD ALSO NOTES
THAT- THERE IS A LIKELIHOOD WE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO RETRO BACK
TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS PROPOSED- IT ALSO COULD
POTENTIALLY PUT THE MANAGED
CARE RATES IN JEOPARDY AS THOSE
ARE CURRENTLY PENDING. WITH CMS
UP FOR. REVIEW AS WELL AND- AND
THAT WOULD BE A LARGE CHALLENGE
FOR US TO OVERCOME- AND AS WELL
MENTIONED REALLY ON THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK THE DEPARTMENT
IS VERY FOCUSED ON. A WORKING
CLOSELY WITH- THE INDUSTRY IN
REGARDS TO REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGIES THAT REALLY THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO FOCUS NOT
ONLY ON COST- BUT ALSO ON
QUALITY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THAT NO- NO LATER
THAN SEPTEMBER FIRST- SO THAT
IS OUR CONSCIENCE OF REGARDING
THE- CAP. PROPOSAL I WILL NOW
TURN THE- TO THE PROPOSED BY
HELP. SO OF PUBLIC- REGARDING
IN MEDIC CALIFIA FOR SERVICE-
KOBE PATIENTS ON THE DEPARTMENT.
HAS GONE THROUGH AND EVALUATED
WHAT WAS IN THAT PROPOSAL ON IT
IS CORRECT THAT PUBLIC
HOSPITALS ARE REIMBURSED. AT
WHAT'S CALLED CERTIFIED PUBLIC
EXPENDITURE METHODOLOGY. BASED
ON COST WHERE THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE IS PROVIDED BY THE PUBLIC
CONSTABLE SYSTEM. BASED ON
OFSTED REPORTS THIRTY PERCENT-
IS A REASONABLE APPROXIMATION
BE FILL OF THE PERCENT OF
PATIENTS ON MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE PATIENTS THEY ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES TO- WE ALSO
CAN CONFIRM BASED ON DATA THAT
WE HAVE SUCH A 65% IS AN
ACCURATE PERCENTAGE- WHEN
COMPARED TO TOTAL FUNDING
PAYMENTS. AGAINST UNCOMPENSATED
CARE COSTS WHEN CONSIDERING
BOTH A MEDIC CAL ON AND
UNINSURED POPULATIONS. BASED ON
OUR CURRENT DATA WE ALSO- DO
YOU SEE ON THAT THERE HAS BEEN
A VERY HIGH RATE OF FEE FOR
SERVICE- KOBE CASES- A LOT
HIGHER THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OUR MANAGED CARE POPULATION TO
BE. A CLEAR- FOR EXAMPLE OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
IN THE FOR SERVICE OUR RESEARCH
HAD COULD BE CASES. PURSES AND
MANAGED CARE ONLY A HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE FOR ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- AS A COMPARISON. WE
ALSO ARE NOT HIGHER UP FOR
SERVICE YOUR UTILIZATION IN
TWENTY TWENTIES THAN IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN MANAGED
CARE- AS WELL AS AS- LOWER
UTILIZATION OF THE OUTPATIENT
CARE. IN TWENTY TWENTY FOR
FUTURE SERVICE VERSUS MANAGED
CARE- THAT COMPARISON IS QUITE
STARK I WITH 480-004-0090 PER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND IF YOU FOR
SERVICE VERSUS. 850-002-0010
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
OUTPATIENT VISITS IN MANAGED
CARE. AND FORWARD. CONTINUING
TO WORK AND PARTNER WITH OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITAL SYSTEMS- AS
THEY HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN AND
THE CO THAT NINETY RESPOND
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN REGARD TO THE WESTERN CENTER
LOS POVERTY RELATED TO THE TELE
SELF ESTES AT THE STATION A
MEDIC CAL APPLE- HERE WE WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT- THE POLICY
REQUIRING WRITTEN SIGNATURE ON
AFFIDAVIT OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY BASED ON OUR
INTERPRETATION OF FEDERAL
REGULATIONS. ON IS WHAT IS
OUTLINED IN OUR CURRENT
CALIFORNIA MANAGE AYE
VERIFICATION PLANHOWEVER I. G.
H. YES IS WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH ADVOCATES IN IS SEEKING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM CMS
ON THIS VERY THING- ON ALLOWING
TELEPHONIC SIGNATURES ON
AFFIDAVITS- FOR OUTSIDE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ARMED
IF CMS AGREES WITH OUR
APPROACH- THEN WE WOULD NEED TO
AMEND OUR NATURAL VERIFICATION
PLAN IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT.
THIS PROPOSAL- IN MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT PROPOSAL OVER THE- TO
THE MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH
ACCESS. RELATED TO THE CODE
NINETEEN UNINSURED- APPLICATION
SIMPLIFICATION- SO AS J. DH CS
WAS. AS IMAGINE WANTED FIRST
DATES OUT THE GATE I TO COVER
THE CODE NINETEEN UNINSURED
GROUP THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE FAMILIES FIRST
CORONA RESPONSE ACT- WE DID.
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT THAT IN
APRIL OF TWENTY TWO- THROUGH
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY. AFTER
THAT LAUNCH AND THROUGH MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH CMS- THEY
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE TO
ALL STATES- IN SPECIFIC A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA IN WHICH TIME BE
RELAUNCHED AN AUTOMATED PORTAL
WITH A NEW APPLICATION- THAT.
IN IN AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY-
AND THE NEW APPLICATION WAS TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL RULES-
SPECIFICALLY CMS REQUIRES
STATES TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS
WITH AN APPLICATION THAT
COLLECTS CONTACT INFORMATION
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER SEDITION
STEP IMMIGRATION AN ATTESTATION
THAT THE APPLICANT HAS NOT
ROLLED IN ANY OTHER FEDERALLY
FUNDED. COVERAGE OR SIGNATURE-
HOWEVER GIVEN THE CONVERSATIONS
TODAY- WE WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH AND
PROVIDED AN ADMINISTRATION ON
ANY CHANGES TO THE POLICY AS WE
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY DIRECTED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. ARE
PRIOR. AND ALLOW WEEK REGARDING
METRO CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
RELATED TO YOU- BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORS AT THE DEPARTMENT IS
VERY COMMITTED TO HEALTH EQUITY
AND ENSURING THAT BLOOD
PRESSURE DOCTORS ARE AVAILABLE
AND THE FEE FOR SERVICE. AND
MANAGED CARE- I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A PHARMACY OR MEDICAL
BENEFITS VERSUS. BEING ABLE TO
BILL BY A PHARMACY OR MEDICAL
PIECE AND ALL KIND OF EXPLAIN
SOME OF THAT IN HERE AS WELL-
BUT JUST TO MAKE SURE WORST
YEAR MEDICARE DOES COVER THREE
TYPES OF BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORS. THE FIRST ONE IS
BLOOD PRESSURE COSTS WITH US
THAT THE STETHOSCOPE SKEWS ME.
A BLOOD PRESSURE CUFF AS WELL
AS AUTOMATED BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORS. IN DEEPER SERVICE ON
THESE DEVICES ARE ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
HOWEVER THEY DO YOU NEED
PRICING I MEAN THEY'RE BUILT BY
REPORTS AND THEY ARE
CATEGORIZED- INTERNET ACCOUNT
AS A MEDICAL BENEFITS- AND SO.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT A
PARTICULAR. ITEM IT'S ALSO
CATEGORIZED AS DM ME I'M IN SO
THERE IS THAT REQUIREMENTS-
THAT IS BUILT ON THE ON THE
MEDICAL SIDE AS WE CURRENTLY
DON'T COVER IT IN OUR- PHARMACY
BENEFIT HOWEVER. WHAT WE ARE
DOING IS IMPLEMENTING THIS
SPRING IT SHOULD BE A ROLE THAT
SOON OF THAT PHARMACIES SHOULD
BE ABLE TO FILL. ON THE MEDICAL
SIDE THAT DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND WE DO THINK THAT
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO- THE
BLOOD PRESSURE MONITORING
SYSTEMS AVAILABLE ON THE FEE
FOR SERVICE. RIGHT HOWEVER 80%
OR SO OF OUR BENEFICIARIES
RECEIVE SERVICES ON THE
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE SIDE- AND
YOU CAN RECEIVE THE BLOOD
PRESSURE MONITOR. FROM DM ME-
SUPPLIED BY EITHER A PHARMACY.
OR PROVIDERS. OR DME PROVIDER-
AND THAT MAY VERY DEPENDING ON
THE PLAN BUT THE MAJORITY OF
WOULD BE THERE- INDIAN ME WILL
REMAIN THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE MINISTER CARE PLANS AFTER
MEDICARE. ACTS OF LIFE- SO
AGAIN AND PHARMACY AT BILL BOTH
ON THE MEDICAL. AS WELL AS THE
BENEFIT SIDE HOWEVER SO IT IS.
DME I IN THE REMAIN THE
RESPONSE TO MAKE CARE PLAY THEY
WOULD TO BILL. ON THAT SO WHAT
THERE ARE A CHARM. OR A- STUFF
WE WANT TO CLEAR THAT. YOU AND
A CALORIE. SO THIS WILL INCLUDE
OUR CLUB WERE. ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS IN HAPPY TO. ANSWER
ANY. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
MISS COOPER AND- LIKE FOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST. THANK
YOU OF MISTER CHAIR INTO YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HE'S QUITE
IN THE WILL CENTER-
REIMBURSABLE OVER MEDIC CAL-
YOU KNOW I SAID ON THE SAMITY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SEEN HOW ARE OUR LOCAL
ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER AND THE BUDGETING
CONSTRAINTS THAT HAPPENED- WELL
I SAT THERE. AND- COBIT
NINETEEN HAS HIT SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY PARTICULARLY HARD-
SECOND ONLY TO L. A. COUNTY
NUMBER OF CASES WE'VE HAD IN
OUR COUNTY. AND ARROWHEAD
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITAL THAT SERVES THE
DISTRICT HAS TAKEN A LEAD ROLE
IN OUR LOCAL RESPONSE EFFORTS
INCLUDING WITH TESTING
RESPONDING TO THE SURGEON
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN ENSURING
THAT OUR LOW INCOME POPULATIONS
ARE RECEIVING HIGH QUALITY CARE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WHILE
DOING ALL THIS- THE SYSTEMS
LIKE A R. M. C. ARE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FRONT FINANCING A
LOT OF THESE EFFORTS- EFFORTS.
THEY GO ON UNREIMBURSED- AND IN
THE REPORT HERE IT TALKS ABOUT.
HOW IF I'M READING IT
CORRECTLY- FOR MEDIC CAL FFS
PATIENTS WHICH COMPRISES
ROUGHLY 30% OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS. HOSPITALIZATION
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
RECEIVE NO STATE GENERAL FUND.
SO TO ME THAT MEANS THAT THE
GENERAL FUND THAT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL HAS TO. MAKE UP FOR THAT
THAT THAT DISPARITY THAT'S
THERE. AND I'M THINKING THAT
WITH THE PREVENT. NINETEEN AND
THE BUSINESS IMPACT AT THE
LOCAL LEVELS- COUNTIES
INCLUDED. THAT HOW HOW
REALISTIC IS IT NOW TO CONTINUE
TO ASK FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONTINUE TO PUT
IN FROM THEIR GENERAL FUND.
WITHOUT HAVING SOME MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE TO START TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE AND THE PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN PROPOSED AND PROPOSAL
NUMBER TWO STARTS TO MOVE THAT
DISCUSSION FORWARD- ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT- WHEN THERE
IS- FEDERAL PORTIONS ONLY COVER
ROUGHLY SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. DID
ANY OF ALLUDED TO IT IN YOUR
PRESENTATION ANSWERING TO THE
PROPOSAL THERE IS- THAT
DISPARITY THAT'S THERE BUT
GETTING BACK TO WHAT WE'VE ALL
SEEN HERE IN THE LAST YEAR AND
WHO KNOWS WHAT. THE NEXT YEAR
OR EVEN TWO YEARS FROM NOW IS
GOING TO BRING US IN THIS REALM
OF PANDEMICS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE COMING OUR WAY.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE IMPACT WITH
BUSINESS- HAS BEEN SEVERELY HIT
WITH BUSINESS AND THEN- THOSE
THAT WOULD BY- HOMES FOR
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAXES ARE
GOING TO THE COUNTY LEVEL- IT
WAS. A STRETCH TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FEELING THAT IN WHEN
I SAT ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND NOW KNOWING THE
IMPACT THAT'S GOING ON I THINK
IT MERITS- SOME TYPE OF
DISCUSSION TO START TO TALK
ABOUT- SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND
HOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. IS
MEETING THAT GAP THAT'S IN
THERE ESPECIALLY AGAIN WHEN YOU
SEE THAT 30% OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH. HOSPITALS RECEIVE NO
STATE GENERAL FUND MONEY THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL
HAS TO MAKE UP FOR THAT SO I'M
I LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHERING
THIS DISCUSSION AND WORKING-
WITH THOSE TO THE CHAIR. TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS DIALOGUE
WITH LOCAL INPUT IN HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
DRESS- THIS UP PANDEMIC THAT
WE'RE ALL IN AND CERTAINLY
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
WE SEE THE CONSTRAINTS GOING ON
IT AT EVERY LEVEL FROM THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION. TO THE
STATE LEVEL TO THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. BUT WE HAVE BE ABLE TO
SIT DOWN AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND HOW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- IS WEATHERING
THROUGH THE STORM. TOGETHER AND
COLLECTIVELY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING FOR THE DIALOGUE ON
THE- THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROMANCE AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS THIS HAS BEEN A
VERY HOT HEALTHY DISCUSSION. WE
WILL NOW BEGIN OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION AND AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING OUR NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES SIX THROUGH
SEVENTEEN. WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. AS THERE IS
NO ONE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH TWO
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A
REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND ALSO SHOULD BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS A PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO.
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2890 NINE AND THE STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND WHEN
YOU'RE MY NUMBER IS CALLED.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS CASKET BURKE WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR VERY THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS TODAY TO OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE PH. AND THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND I
WANT TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
OUR BUDGET REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALL OF THE
ISSUED YOU TALKED ABOUT TODAY
STAFF TRAINING LABORATORY
CAPACITY AT THE DATA SYSTEM
DOES ALL NEED TO BE FUNDED ON
ON GOING BASIS. NOT JUST DURING
THE PANDEMIC THE CELEBRATED
DON'T FUND THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
ONLY DURING THE WILDFIRE SO
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LIFESAVING
PUBLIC HEALTH WORK. I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. MY TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA
ADDICTED AND GAVE THE ACT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF STI YOU CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING ON ISSUES TO UNDER OUR
SPENT WITH THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND YOU KNOW FOR
DECADES ADDRESSING
UNSUSTAINABLE HEALTHCARE COSTS
HAVE BEEN A TOP PRIORITY FOR
STI YOU. BECAUSE HEALTHCARE
COSTS CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTH CARE
IN THE QUALITY OF WORK FIRST
FOR GO WAITING CREATED. TO PAY
FOR INCREASING HEALTHCARE COSTS.
WITH THAT SAID THE ALL MONTH
MON A CONSTANT EFFORTS ON
BEHALF. WORKFORCE AND THE
TRAINING NEEDS OF WORKERS. IF
IT'S TO ENSURE THAT HOSPITALS
AND OTHER HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS
DO NOT CONTROL COSTS. SIMPLY BY
CUTTING WORKER WAGES OR LAYING
OFF WORKERS ESPECIALLY NOW
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
ADDITIONALLY IF PROVIDERS WILL
BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE AUDITED
FINANCIAL REPORT WE OPE THAT
THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC REVIEW
PROCESS OF THE DOCUMENT TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER DEFENDED
PEACE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION ON THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AT. GBL COMES OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHARAMBA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KNOW BOTTOM
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION BECAUSE TO ITEM
FORTY TO SIXTY FIVE ISSUE THREE
EIGHTY P. H. FIRST- ON BEHALF
OF OUR STATEWIDE FARMWORKER
ADVOCACY COALITION WE SUBMITTED.
WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE VACCINE
ADVISORY AND SO THE COMMENTS
SUBMITTED TO THIS COME. ARE
THESE WILL AT THE VERY THIRD ME
WHICH FOCUSED BACK ALUM FOR
FORMER- PARTNERING WITH YOU
BASED OREGON. TRACKING FINDING
WE CAN EDUCATION FOR ALL YOUR
INFORMATION AND REFERENCE. OF
SECOND TO UNDER THIS ITEM ON
BEHALF OF SURELY FOUNDATION. WE
SUPPORT. ON THE CODE NINETEEN
WORKPLACE THAT WHICH BUDGET SHE
PROPOSED. AND IT IS CRUZ FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. AND I WILL MAIL
THE TROUT H. YES I DON'T TWO
MISSION. FIVE HE SHERRY WITH
THE COLDER POLICY PROPOSED ON
THAT CAL ITEM THREE AND FOUR.
TO WHEN IT HAS BACK TO QUALITY
MEDICARE L. FOR ELIGIBLE
IMMIGRANT. APPRECIATE ALL YOU
WORK DONE TO AND A LITTLE BUT
DISCUSSION REALLY LONELY FOR
PUBLIC. DURING THAT ENDEMIC
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING. YEAH
NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY EIGHTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
K. STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET ASK FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON ONE FOR OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE HE
THOUGHT IT WAS STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS PROPOSAL BUT I ALSO
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- THE PANEL WITH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SOME OF THE ISSUES COVERED
THERE. WE STRONGLY ALSO SUPPORT
THE SENDING AND APPROVING IT
YEAH HE FEDERAL FUNDING TO
COUNTY THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WITH THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY THE
DOCTOR COME ON ALPINE THAT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. BATES
ALTERNATION FOR ALL COUNTY AND
THEN DIVIDED UP BE A POPULATION
POVERTY RATE. CITY WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
OF THE HOPE THAT THE JAIL BC
BUT ALL THE- LET'S LEADERS NO
HOW IMPORTANT FUNDING AND HOW
QUICK COUNTIES NEEDED. ON THE
P. PROPOSAL THIRD CAR HAD FOR.
WE JUST WANT EVERY THAT COUNTY-
LIKE I HEALTH SYSTEM WE ARE
SUBDIVISION OF THE STATE AND
THAT WE ARE PARTNER WITH THE
STATE ON THE TP A PROPOSAL NOT
JUST ANOTHER PROVIDER AND SO WE
WANTED. TO REMIND THE
LEGISLATURE. PLEASE YEAH BUT P.
BROUGH BURKE THE- OTHERS HAS.
REACHING OUT WITH WE VERY VERY
MUCH. BUT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT CAN AGAIN AND SOMETHING
THAT OF THE STATE AND THE ONLY
EMPATHY TRY. WITH ONLY. BUT I
ENSURING AND- ADEQUATE THAT TO
OUR THE ENTIRE CAN- SET
CAMPAIGN BE- RETAIN THEIR-
ELIGIBILITY TO RECEIVE AS MUCH
AS- AS THEY WOULD. NOW WITH
SHORTAGE SO CAN TO RE FEEDBACK
YOU SO- OF HELL PROVIDERS THAT.
IN GETTING DOES AS THEIR- BUT
ONE FIVE INCREASES WE WANTED
THAT COUNTY THAT THE OF THE LAW.
BECAUSE AGAINWE'RE UNDER THE
OF COURSE. HARD TO REACH- AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES AND- AGAIN
WE'RE NOT A PROVIDER WE ARE A
SUBDIVISION OF THE THING. SO
WHAT THEY'LL COME I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK COULD NOT THANK YOU.
NINE SIX SEVEN YOUR LONG IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT THAT HE
CANNOT WOULD KEEP REPUBLICAN ON
BEHALF BUT FAMILY. HERE THIS
EVENING REPORTER THE LOCAL FOR
PROPOSAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND-
UNDER THE- AS WELL TRIAL BACK
BECAUSE OF FOR BLOOD PRESSURE
MY- IN OUR PROVISION THE AGE CS.
AND P. AS YOU KNOW PROVIDES
TIME SIR HOME VISITING FOR THE
FIRST TIME PREGNANT WOMEN AND
THEIR NEWBORNS. HE IS FOR. BEEN
DELIVERED THREE COUNT PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. MANY OF OUR
PARTNER COUNTY. HEALTH AND BEEN
REAL TO COPE AND RESPOND BACK
IN DELIVERY. NEVERTHELESS AND
IF YOU'RE- AND ABLE TO FOR OF
THESE. FOR THREE. VISITS IS CO
STOP RITESH ALLOW. THEM STATE
SUPPORT THE PAPER TO THE
CRITICALLY NEEDED NOW. OUR LOW
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS.
CLEARLY COUNT NEEDED STOCKING
RATES. IN PROTECT PUBLIC
NURSING. TO MEET THESE. HE'S
PROPOSAL GOES WELL WITH BLOOD
PER MONITOR. ARE NEEDED TO HOW
ALREADY UNDERSERVED FAMILIES
KEEP AND MAINTAIN CRITICAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND IF YOU HAVE BEEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THESE. PER
LETTER AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NINE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING PERRIN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JACKIE GRAY WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE FTW WESTERN
CAPE TOWN BALL I YES W. WITH
ONE OF THE MAIN SPONSOR THAT
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE AND WE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION COMPLEMENT THE
PUBLIC DATABASE PROVISION THAT
THE BELL. THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION WILL ENSURE THAT
CDPH IS IMPLEMENTING EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND INTENDED
BY OUR DOCTOR AND THE BOND
BEARS DOING GOOD WORK ADDRESS
SAYS NUMBER OF EXPOSED
INDIVIDUALS AND INDUSTRY
REPUBLICAN WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT
TO PUBLIC DATA ABOUT WORKSITE
EXPOSURES. AGENCIES REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO SELF REPORT CALVET
NINETEEN WORKSITE EXPOSURES AND
INCOMPLETE PROTECT EXPORT
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES AT
GREATER RISK BECAUSE THE STATE
HAS NO CLEAR PICTURE OF WHERE
CALVET NINETEEN WORKPLACE OUT
BIRTHDAY. CARDS WHAT THE BEST.
IN PROBABLY LACKING IN. WHAT
FROM THE STATE- LOW WHEN IT.
THAT OCCURRED JEOPARDIZE WORKER
THERE FOR. AND COMMUNITY BY THE
HOW EACH OTHER PLAY MANY. THAT
ARE NOT TAKEN INTO. MANNER TO
PREVENT DELAY THE WORK X. ABOUT
A DATA SETTING THAT THAT
WORKSITE ADDRESS AND THEN OF
THE PRESIDENT INTERVIEW.
THERE'S NO ONE FOR BACK IN
TRYING AND ARE. FONG FORTY. IF
FOR ANY REASON WE URGE COURT
THAT THE FOUR POINT THREE CENT.
EIGHTY SIX FIVE. REQUIREMENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK.
NINE SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
ARAMBULA MA'AM OF WINDOW WITH
LESS AND ON LAW POVERTY RELATED
TO LAST ON MEDICARE WE SHOULD
CONTINUE PHARMACY ACCESS TO
BLACK MY CAN COME THAT PATIENTS.
AS WE'VE SEEN DELAYS WITH AND
GOT ARE TREATED DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT CONSIDERING THE HIGH
MATERNAL. RATE AMONG BLACK
WOMEN DUE TO HYPERTENSION
BERMAN EQUITY LENDS IT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE TIMELY ACCESS AND
ADDITIONALLY SUPPORT MAKING IT
EASIER TO APPLY FOR MEDICAID
HOW COLD IT UNINSURED PROGRAMS
BY REMOVING APPLICATION
QUESTIONS THEY CAN HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. HI. NINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MEGHAN SUPERB
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
PLUS ADVOCATE TO PRESENT IN
THAT COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS. WE PROVIDE CARE TO
ABOUT A LITTLE OVER SEVEN
MILLION PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW AND THAT IS THE ONE
AND THREE MEDIC CAL
BENEFICIARIES I JUST WANT TO
GET ON A COUPLE TOP LINE WE-
FIRST ONE I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR THE
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS UNDER US PAD- AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM WHICH IS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ASSISTING OUR
TEACHING HEALTH CENTERS- AND
CONTINUING THEIR RESIDENCY
TRAINING PROGRAM AND THEN I'M
JUST ALSO WANT TO PROVIDE A ME
TOO ALL OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
STAKEHOLDER COLLEAGUES ON THE
PREVIOUS PANEL- WE REALLY NEED
TO BOLSTER OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE EQUITY AND REACH
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHICH MEANT THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND INCLUDE THE REACH
AND THE ABILITY OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AND THIS IS TRUE
FOR ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH SERVICES
AND OF COURSE VACCINE ACCESS TO
THANK EVERYBODY. FOR THEIR TIME
THIS EVENING THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES WE
WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OUR
COMMENTS WITH SHE ACT SK YOU
AND OUR OTHER LOCAL HEALTH
PARTNERS REGARDING THE NEED TO
INVEST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN ADDITION OF
A GRADE READ A BRIEF STATEMENT
FROM OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DR
HELP GOLDSTINE. PUBLIC HEALTH
IS CENTRAL SUGGESTING MANY OF
THE PRESIDENT EQUITY ISSUES
FIFTY CALIFORNIA ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE COVERED PANDEMIC.
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA HOMELESSNESS
CROP OF THESE FOOD SAFETY
MENTAL HEALTH WATER QUALITY AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE LEGISLATURE
CAN'T WAIT TO INVESTING
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE
INSTRUCTOR. TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA RESPOND TO THESE
ISSUES NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
OUR LIVES AND THE LIVES OUR
CHILDREN LEARN EARLY DEPEND ON.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
ASSURE THESE COMMENTS OVER TIME
THIS EVENING. LINE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DIANA
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF CALL BACK
THE CALIFORNIA BEGAN ISSUE
THREE HEALTH ACT THAT THE PARTS
ARE ABOUT FUNDING FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION IF THE MOMENT HAD
WITH EFFICIENCY AND EQUITY IN
THE FOREFRONT IT WILL RESULT IN
A MAJOR RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN
LIVES SAVED AND A QUICKER
RECOVERY. FUNDING WILL ALSO
REDUCE BARRIERS AND ISSUES IN
THE LOGISTICAL LAST MILE OF
ACTING DISTRIBUTION WHICH IS
REALLY WHERE EQUITY LEADS AND
THEN IF YOU'RE FIVE BACK WITH
THE SUPPORT OF EFFORTS TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO MEDIC
CALABRO MENTALLY SUPPORT
FLEXIBILITY FOR MEDICAL POT
MEDITATION TO TAKE PLACE OVER
THE PHONE OR ELECTRONICALLY.
ASSEMBLY REMOVED THE ADDITIONAL
BARRIER OF PEOPLE WORK WE
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT WORKS
TO LOOK TOWARDS STREAMLINING
ENROLLMENT. INCOME VERIFICATION
ATTENDING AND THIS IS- MILLIE
SAYS A SMALL STEP TO TAKE IN
THE MEANTIME PUBLIC THAT THEY
ALSO IN FAVOR OF MODIFYING
LANGUAGE IN THAT CUPBOARD
NINETEEN UNINSURED GROUP
APPLICATION RELATED IMMIGRATION
STATUS THAT MEANS HER SOME
FAMILIES FROM SEEKING COVERAGE
THIS TIME WE CAN'T AFFORD TO BE
SENDING MIXED SIGNALS ABOUT
QUALIFICATION FOR FAMILIES THAT
ARE MOST. AT RISK DURING THE
PANDEMIC THANK YOU. MIND A-
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS MIDSIZE WITH THE CAL
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO- HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED ALLOCATION TO HELP
CDPH STAND UP THE PUBLIC FACING
DATABASE ASSOCIATED WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHT FIVE.
WE WOULD DEFINITELY ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS DATABASE AND
ALSO THE OVERALL BILL WE REALLY
DO BELIEVE THIS WAS ARGUABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WAS APPROVED
LAST YEAR AND LARGELY BECAUSE
OF THIS PIECE THAT PUBLICLY
FACING DATABASE. AND
SPECIFICALLY THE DETAIL OFFERED
BY THE DATABASE AND KNOWING
WHICH WORK PLACE AND WHAT KIND
OF AN OUTBREAK AND WHEN THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT INFORMATION
TO HAVE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS BUT NOT ONLY DOES IT
HELP DIFFERENT PUBLIC ENTITIES
ENFORCEABLE LAW IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR WORKERS TO KNOW
WHERE THE HOT SPOTS ARE. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE JUST KIND OF STABBING
IN THE DARK AND WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHERE THESE ARE HAPPENING-
IF THE EMPLOYER DOESN'T REPORT
TO US OR IF THE MEDIA DOESN'T
REPORT ON IT AND HAVING A
PUBLICLY FACING DATABASE WOULD
BE INVALUABLE IN PROBABLY
ALLOWING WORKERS TO MAKE. GOOD
HEALTHY DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO
STAY SAFE AT WORK ALSO ALLOWING
US TO FOCUS SCARCE PUBLIC
DOLLARS ON WHERE THEY CAN DO
THE MOST GOOD BUT ALSO ALLOWING
THE PUBLIC. TO KEEP THEMSELVES
SAFE WHERE APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STARED
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF SERVICES MENTIONED
HERE TODAY INCLUDING A COUPON I
DON'T CARE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAM OPERATE CLINICS IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE ROBUST A FASHION ON
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND ONE NOTE
THAT HEALTHCARE DISTRICT'S
SERVICE BACK LATER COORDINATORS
IN PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT IN
ADMINISTRATION OF THE VACCINE
BUT MANY OF THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS MENTIONED HERE
TODAY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO LEARN ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
THE BUDGET TO LOCAL PROVIDER.
AND ALSO MENTION OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ADDITIONAL ARE SPREAD
WORKFORCE FINDING ITEMS
SPECIFICALLY THE ADDITIONAL
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND OR BUILDING A MORE
ROBUST YEAR AFTER WORKFORCE IN
ADDITION WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CAST A CATHOLIC. FIRST FULL
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE COST OF
LABOR AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AS WELL AS GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF THE OTHER MEDICAL
PROPOSAL POSTED HERE TODAY AS
YOU SEE AN ESSENTIAL
CHARACTERISTIC. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT.
TODAY THANK YOU. MY EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LONG IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS LAURIE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND I WISH TO CONVEY EMA'S
ACTIVE ON THE BACKING
DEPLOYMENT ISSUE. VMA JOINS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION INSTRUCTING THE
NEED FOR EQUITY IN OUR VACCINE
BALL OUT A VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM THAT FOCUSES EXCLUSIVELY
ON AGE WOULD REINFORCE THE
DISPARITIES THAT ARE BEING LAID
BARE BY COPE AT NINETEEN. YEAH
I RECOMMEND THAT BACK ALLOCATE
CONSIDER MORBIDITY AND
TRANSMISSION RATE IN COMMUNITY
WHAT ALLOCATIONS WEIGHTED
TOWARD BOTH COMMUNITIES WITH
THE GREATEST STRAIGHT THE
TRANSMISSION. AND THAT BACK IN
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THIS SHOULD BE PAIRED WITH
CONCERTED OUTREACH TO
POPULATION WITH POPULATIONS
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES BETTER
ACT THE HIGHEST RATE. ONE
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF REACHING
COMMUNITY IS MOBILIZING THE
EXISTING HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES AT THE PIE INCREASES
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GET VACCINATED THROUGH THEIR
OWN DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR CLINIC.
BASED ON A RECENT CMA SURVEY A
COMMUNITY PHYSICIAN PRACTICES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
BOTH THE CAPACITY AND INTEREST
IN ADMINISTERING THE VACCINES
TO THEIR COMMUNITY. RESOURCES
ON SUPPORT SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO UTILIZE THESE
PRACTICES TO ADMINISTER THE
VACCINES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING WHERE YOU JOHN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HOLD THE WORD WE
APPRECIATE THE CRITICAL
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE RAISED
TODAY AROUND COLDER VACCINATION
DATA DISK- TRANSPARENCY AND
EFFORTS TO ENSURE EQUITY A WE
WANT TO THANK BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS FOR DILIGENT
WORK WE WOULD LIKE TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT FOR GEOX BUDGET REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH PARTICULARLY
FOR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
STRENGTHENING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRUCIAL FOR
ON ADDRESSING EQUITY IN OUR
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AS WELL AS
LONG TERM RECOVERY FOR
DEPENDENT NEXT ADDITIONALLY
REGARDING THE LAST PANEL ON A
MEDIC HOW WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT SEVERAL COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE- FIRST OF ALL WE WILL
LIKE TO SUPPORT WESTERN CENTER
IS COMMON REGARDING SIMPLIFYING
MEDICOLEGAL THE PROCESS EASIER.
BY CONTINUING TO ALLOW SELF
ACCUSATIONS OVER THE PHONE OR
ELECTRONICALLY EVEN AFTER
DEPEND ON NEXT WE ALSO SUPPORT
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
ACTIVELY COMING AROUND ON THE
MEDICAL INSURANCE PROGRAMS.
WHICH SUPPORT FURTHER
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION PROCESS
AND MAKING- MAKING AS EASY AND
WELCOMING AS POSSIBLE FOR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES- SERRET WE
ALSO SUPPORT ACTIONS YOU BLOOD
PRESSURE MONITORING EQUIPMENT
THROUGH LOCAL PHARMACIES SO
THAT MANY COMPANIES ISSUES CAN
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE. HEALTH
WITH WITH EASE THANK YOU. WINDS
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GOOD EVENING CRACKLES
FOR FROM A P. LA HEALTH YOU
EIGHT B. AND ONE OF THE LARGEST
HIV SERVICE PROVIDERS AND L. A.
COUNTY. FIRST I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
FOCUSING TO DATE HEARING ON THE
STATE COBEN RESPONSE ON
ESPECIALLY THE CHAIR FOR
MAINTAINING A FOCUS ON. HELP
JUSTICE AND EQUITY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE I
AM ALWAYS CERTAINLY RECOGNIZED
THE CODE MUST REMAIN A TOP
PRIORITY FOR CDPH AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS I DID JUST
WANT TO CALL ATTENTION TO
SEVERAL OTHER ON GOING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES. I WOULD ALSO
BENEFIT FROM THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND THAT THE ON GOING
CONDEMN ECHOED HIV HEPATITIS
STD IS AN OVERDOSE SEN I'LL
JUST QUICKLY SHARE A COUPLE TO
DETECT. THE FIRST IS AROUND THE
STATE STD EPIDEMIC A NEW CASES
ARE UP 40% SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND K. CONCEPTION
SYPHILIS ARE UP NEARLY. 4100%
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
THEY'RE WELCOME AND THAT CAME.
IN OVERDOSE. DEATHS TO HEROIN
ARE UP ABOUT HOW CHRIS. AND
RELATED TO FAT OR UP THE QUID.
IN YOU THE TWELVE. ALL OF THESE
CRISES THAT. IMPACT ACCUSED OF
COLOR- THE VERY FOLKS NOW BEAR
IN THE WORKS AFFECT THE
COVERAGE AND SO IT'S
RESPECTFULLY- URGE THE
COMMITTEE THAT WHILE WE
CONTINUE OUR FOCUS ON THE STATE
CODE RESPONSE. THAT WE NOT LOSE
SIGHT OF THE ON GOING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES. SO LIKE THE
CHAIRS THAT WE CAN COME OUT OF
THE ENDEMIC STRONGER THAN WE
WENT INTO IT. I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE STATEWIDE AND THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION HAS OUTLINED
A NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. OTHER WE'VE ALREADY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE.
CLEAR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AND GOOD EVENING- INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD BE JEALOUS ON BEHALF OF
CHAIRED BY THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS- I
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
THEY REFLECT SOME OF THE COMMON
IN. WHO ARE YOU WHICH ARE YOU
SUPPORT A PROPOSAL NUMBER FOUR
WEEKS SIX THE SIMPLIFY AND
ENSURED THAT THE CURRENT-
APPLICATION- FOR A DOCUMENT
DETAILING THE DOCTRINE AND
WELCOME BECAUSE THE TENSION OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING. I HAVE ENDED
UP LOCATION NOT BE CLEAR ARE
WELCOMING WOULD ACTUALLY GET
HER IMMIGRANT FROM APPLYING THE
SERVICE THAT THE SPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONE THIRD OF
EXTENSION WORKERS ARE
IMMIGRANTS MANY OF THEM ARE
UNDOCUMENTED WILL BELIEVE THAT
IS A TEMPLATE CHANGE THAT WE
MUST DO TO ENSURE THAT IF THEY
NEED TO FIX SOME OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT CAN RESOLVE
UPCOMING NINETEEN ARE THEY ABLE
TO DO SO IN A IN IN A IN A WAY
THAT THEY FEEL SAFE AND WELCOME
AND WITH THAT APPRECIATE
RETENTION. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO
GIVE ME ONE MORE I CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF OUR OLDER DEATHS
NURSING HOME WORKERS I WILL TO
SPEAKS OF TO THE DECOR PROPOSED.
PRESENTED BY CAPITAL PART OF
TEN NURSE WITH THE TEN AN
INCREASE IN THE DIRECTION. .COM
21100% WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO INCLUDE WORKERS INTO THE
WORKFORCE BUT THE TEMPORARY
NOTICES PROPOSAL AND DOESN'T
ACCOUNT FOR THE NEED FOR THE
CURRENT WORKERS INCLUDING THEIR
CURRENT RESPONSIBILITIES AND
WORKLOAD BEFORE ADDING-
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
WITHOUT COMPENSATION WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS PROPOSAL
CREATES ANOTHER LOW WAGE
CLASSIFICATION WITHOUT A DIRECT
PATH TO STAY IN THE WORKFORCE.
SO WE WILL OFFER TO A FIFTY
INDUSTRY AND THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS- BEFORE
MOVING FORWARD REGARDING THE
100% LABOR CARE CALL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION EXCEPT FOR THE-
LATER THIS YEAR TO ADDRESS NOT
ONLY THE ISSUE BUT OTHER
RELATED MATTERS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT INVESTMENT
IN INDIRECT AND ENDEAVOR TO
LABOR CARE BUT WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE WORKERS THE- I
DIRECT BENEFITS OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON. BOTH TOPICS
THANK YOU. LINE FOR TWO YOUR
LINE IS A- PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD EVENING MANY IS FORGET
WITH A SENSE ACCESS HEALTH- WE
FOCUS ON SECTION RIBBON HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL- WE ALSO ARE A
COMMENT ABOUT NEEDING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S OTHER
RESSING PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEFERRED AND
CONTINUE TO WORSEN AND ARE
ACTUALLY COMPOUNDED BY
COLLUDED. THE CHRONIC UNDER
FUNDING OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
BEST ILLUSTRATED BY THE RAPID
RISE OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASE RATES THAT WERE ALREADY
SKYROCKETING TECH CRISIS LEVEL
PRIOR TO THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC NEARLY A QUARTER OF A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WERE
ALREADY INFECTED WITH SYPHILIS
CHLAMYDIA OR GONORRHEA TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE MUCH HIGHER FOR
TWENTY TWENTY AND FIND THAT THE
STF AND I MAKE HAS BEEN
NEGLECTED FOR FAR TOO LONG HAVE
ALREADY MANIFESTED IN VERY
ALARMING WAYS- FOR EXAMPLE THE
CDC CONFIRMED A FEW MONTHS AGO
THAT A NEW ANTIBIOTIC RESISTANT
STRAIN OF GONORRHEA BEGAN TO
SPREAD ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
DURING THE CALL THAT CRISIS AND
OUR OWN STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO ISSUED AN
ALERT THIS PAST DECEMBER ABOUT
THE RISING NUMBER OF
DISSEMINATED GONOCOCCAL
COMPLICATION OF UNTREATED
GONORRHEA THAT SPREADS ACROSS
THE BODY THROUGH THE
BLOODSTREAM. THIS IS LIKELY A
RESULT OF PEOPLE NOT IN FCT
TESTING DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED BABIES
WERE BORN WITH CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS I'M DURING THE
PANDEMIC. OF THE COST OF
INACTION IS FAR TOO GREAT TO
CONTINUE IGNORING APPROXIMATELY
BILLION DOLLARS IS SPENT
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA THING
CALIFORNIA ON HEALTH COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PD. AND
ALTHOUGH THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IS AFFECTING ALL
COMMUNITIES IF CALIFORNIA YOU.
BLACK COMMUNITIES INDIGENOUS
AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR AS
WELL AS BE BISEXUAL AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THIS ISSUE AND SO THIS IS A
SOCIAL JUSTICE PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE THAT. WE MUST CONFRONT
IMMEDIATELY AND WE URGE YOU. TO
PLEASE THIS IN MY WHILE AFFECT-
THE STATE BUDGET WE HAVE. ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE YOU FOR AND
APPLY THE WORK OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MELANIE MEDICAL AN
OBSTETRICIAN- WHO TAKES CARE OF
PATIENTS THAT SOME OF THE CODE
GENERAL HOSPITAL IN EACH YEAR
THAT. TODAY ON THE ISSUE OF
HOME BLOOD PRESSURE EQUIPMENT
ACCESS FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE. OF
THE PROVIDER AND SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN FIGHTING TO GET THIS
EQUIPMENT INTO THE HANDS OF OUR
MEDIC COUNTERED PATIENTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO PRINT PREDOMINATELY
OVER THE LAST YEAR CO THAT. I'M
HERE TO SHARE THE COVERING THAT
THE CLINTON THREE DME BENEFIT
HAS NOT WORKED. AND PROVIDING
ACCESS UNDER THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT IS CRITICAL AND ALSO
PROVIDES AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE ACCESS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE- YOU'VE
HEARD THE NEED FOR HOME
EQUIPMENT AND NOT GET BAITED AS
MOST OF US KNOW THERE'S THE
MATERNAL MORTALITY CRISIS AND
BLACK WOMEN. ARE DYING AT THREE
TO FOUR TIMES THE RATE OF
EVERYONE ELSE. OCULAR RELATED
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE LEADING
CAUSE PUT TOGETHER THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH MATERNAL
MORTALITY CRISIS- WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD THAT. THE IS THAT CLINTON
IS BEING COVERED BY BOTH THE
HEALTH PLANS THE MEDICARE FEE
FOR SERVICE BECAUSE WOMEN NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MONITOR THEIR
BLOOD PRESSURE AT HOME SO THEY
CAN COME IN. AND GET TREATMENT
BEFORE IT BECOMES- A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN LEADS TO
DEATH. JUST BECAUSE THE
COVERAGE THAT THE EQUIPMENT IS
COVERED DOES NOT MEAN WE CAN
GET THIS EQUIPMENT OUR
PATIENTS- IN FACT I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST. YEAR
WE HAD SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
UNDER THE DME BENEFIT OF
DIFFERENT CLUED A LACK OF LOCAL
VENDORS LARGE DELAYED WITH OUR
PATIENTS GETTING THE EQUIPMENT
WHEN WE USE THE MAILING VENDORS
FOR DME- AND HAVING DIFFERENT
APPROVED VENDORS FOR EACH PLAN.
FRANKLY THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
IT WAS BROUGHT UP A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THAT LOCAL PHARMACIES
CAN SIMPLY BECOME DM YOU
VENDORS WE HAVE TRIED DEBTS IN
OUR LOCAL ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
LAST YEAR. OUR PHARMACIES WILL
NOT BECOME DME VENDORS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHY PRESUMABLY
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY THAT
DOING SO BUT IT'S BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR THAT THEY WON'T DO THAT-
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT- YOU KNOW THESE BARRIERS.
HAVE BEEN SO SIGNIFICANT FOR US
THAT FOR THOSE PATIENTS WO ARE
COVERED UNDER THE DME VENDOR.
THOSE THE VETERAN COUNTY THAT
CAN GET DONORS WE'VE ACTUALLY
STARTED STOCKPILING DONATED
BLOOD PRESSURE EQUIPMENT SO WE
CAN SIMPLY HAND. IT TO OUR
PATIENTS AND NOT HAVE TO GO-
TRUE THE DMB HAPPEL- SO I'M
QUICKLY I'LL JUST SHARE WITH
YOU WE ARE LUCK. IN SAN. CA
THAT WE- TO HAVE A HEALTH PLAN
WHO WHEN. THE ROUTE OF COVERING.
AS A PHARMACY BENEFIT THE BLOOD.
QUITE AND- I CANNOT TELL YOU
HOW DIFFERENT IT IS I SIMPLY
RYE A PRESS. I TELL AND ALL OF
OUR- CALL. SIMPLY RIGHT ACROSS.
OUR PACE. HAVE EXT. EASY ACCESS
AND THEIR LOCAL NEIGHBORHOODS
AS WELL AS- ALL THE PHARMACIES
AROUND THE HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS. YES I HAVE AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO EXTEND THE BAD
USE OF ACCESS. EVERY MEDIC
KALINJAR GET PREGNANT PATIENT
CALIFORNIA. BY ACTUALLY ADDING
BLOOD PRESSURE EQUIPMENT NOW TO
ITS NEW MEDIC CAL OUR ACTS FOR
ME LARRY. THIS IS WHAT I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE DH YOU HAVE TO
DO. I KNOW THAT WE'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT JUST ALLOWING HEALTH
PLANS TO CONTINUE THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT I WOULD GO EVEN
FURTHER. WE ARE IN A MATERNAL
MORTALITY CRISIS AND THIS IS AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL FOR ON GOING
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC HOSPITALS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR PLAYS A UNIQUE ROLE IN
THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE STATE
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC
HOSPITAL NEEDS. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PUBLIC HOSPITALS ARE BOTH
CRITICAL PARTNERS TO REACHING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESSING EQUITY ISSUES I
PARTICULARLY- IN REGARDS TO A
VACCINATIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND ROBUST DISCUSSION
THIS AFTERNOON AND EVENING WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. MY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
COMMENTING ON ITEM FORTY ONE
TWENTY THE DA AND THE DENTAL
TEAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
SPECTRALLY URGE AND THAT COULD
HELP US FORGE COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIPS. WITH PROVIDERS-
AND LOCALLY TO HELP MORE.
PROFICIENTLY DISTRIBUTE STATE
STOCKPILE BODIES THE PRICE AND
AVAILABILITY OF PPP AND OTHER
INFECTION CONTROL SUPPLIES
CONTINUE TO BE A MAJOR BURDEN
FOR DENTAL PRACTICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I'M IN GENERALLY
SPEAKING PROVIDERS ARE PAYING-
AS MUCH AS TEN FOLD MORE. THAN
PRE PROGRAMMED FOR NEW
MANDATORY INFECTION CONTROL
SUPPLIES- WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
IMPACT TO COORDINATE. WITH THE
STATE STOCKPILE. AND THEIR
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
THAT SUPPLIES ARE APPROPRIATELY
DISTRIBUTED AND EMPHASIS SHOULD
BE PLACED ON PROVIDERS OUTSIDE
OF FORMAL FORMAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM FLYING DENTIST AND
PRIVATE PRACTICE PHYSICIANS.
THAT ARE UNABLE TO PURCHASE
SUPPLIES AS EASILY AS HOSPITAL
SYSTEM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL AND SAYS
ON FUTURE STATE STOCKPILE- THE
DISBURSEMENT A STRATEGIES-
QUICKLY MOVING ON TO ITEM FORTY
ONE FORTY CDA AGREES WITH THAT
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
INCREASE PIPE. PROGRAMS- THESE
ARE NEED TO AND- HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES SUCH AS
THOSE IN DENTAL ASSISTING.
ADDITIONALLY ON ITEM- FORTY TO
SIXTY FIVE ISSUE THREE- AT THE
STATE EMBARKS ON I'M
RESTRUCTURING OUR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION THROUGH THE NEW
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATION
CONTRACT- THE WE ARE- BLUE
SHIELD TO FORM STRATEGIES
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CDA AND OTHER
RGANIZATIONS- THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO EXPANDING. ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE- THIS ALSO
INCLUDES ENSURING THAT ALL
QUALIFIED PROVIDERS INCLUDING
DENTISTS ARE ON INCLUDED IN ANY
FUTURE- DISTRIBUTION AND
REIMBURSEMENT PLAN- ALSO- WANT
TO QUICKLY TOUCH ON THE ISSUE
FOR I'M A PDA SUPPORTS- EFFORTS
TO STRENGTHEN THE CAPACITY TO
PERFORM CRITICAL ONGOING WORK.
OF LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
IMPROVE ON HEALTH EQUITY BEYOND
IMMEDIATE PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
I'M THINKING FOR YOUR TIME THIS
EVENING. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS. THIS OPINION
CHAU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT POLICY
CENTER. I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS THE PROPOSAL. TO
MOVE THE IMMIGRATION STATUS
QUESTION FROM THE COVER
NINETEEN UNINSURED GROUP
PROGRAM APPLICATION. WE CAN
EXPEDITE RECOVERY FROM AND BANK
THAT ALL CAN YOU AND IMMIGRANTS
FEEL SAFE ACCESSING TREATMENT
WITH MAXIMUM BECAUSE NINETEEN.
THEREFORE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FROM THAT ACCOUNT
COMMITTED NINETEEN UNINSURED
PROGRAM SHOULD BE MADE AS
WELCOMING AS POSSIBLE FOR
EVIDENCE AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
PUBLISHED BY THE URBAN
INSTITUTE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALMOST ONE IN SEVEN ADULTS IN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ON THE
THIRTEEN PERCENT. REPORTED THAT
THEY WERE A FAMILY MEMBER
INCLUDED A NON CASH GOVERNMENT
BENEFIT PROGRAM. DURING A
PANDEMIC OF THIS TREND IS
ALARMING IT AFFECTS THE
UTILIZATION OF THE CALL THE
NINETEEN HUNDRED COULD PROGRAM.
DUE TO A HISTORY OF TARGETED
ENFORCEMENT AND EXCLUSION FROM
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM MANY
IMMIGRANTS AVOID TAKING
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE. WHAT WE
DO THE WORK PROBABLY TO ADDRESS
THIS CRIME THE FEAR YOU NEED TO
TAKE MEASURES TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS AND BUILD
TRUST WITHIN THE CONTINUOUS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PARENTS. MOVING THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS QUESTION A
SIMPLE YET EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO
THIS THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DR RANDALL
MEMBERS ARRIVE CENTER ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STRYCHNINE AND I'M SURE
THE BOYS ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF
STATE GOING TO POLLS AND NUMBER
FIVE AS RESENTED UNDER ISSUES
AFFECTING MEDICO HI THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ENSURE SELF
MONITORING BLOOD PRESSURE.
MONITORS MAKE IT CAN BE OFFERED
AS A PHARMACY BENEFIT IN
SUPPORT OF BREVITY AND WE DO SO
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS STATED
BY. THE SPEAKERS OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION.
NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU COMPLETE-
OFFERING A DIFFERENT IN MY NAME
IS KEVIN SMITH I AM THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE OBGYN
DEPARTMENT FOR THE ALAMEDA
HEALTH SYSTEM WE'RE THINKING
THAT. SYSTEM PROVIDING AFFECT
YOUR CARE FOR OAKLAND. ALAMEDA
HEY WE'RE BERKELEY AND OF THE
CROWNING CATCHMENT- LIKE MY
WHAT THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
INCLUDING MY PARTNER HERE IN
SAN FRANCISCO JUST SPOKE WE
HAVE FOUND THAT THE ARMY HAS
NOT WORKED- FOR PROVIDING-
BLOOD PRESSURE MONITORING AT
HOME FOR PATIENTS- YOU ALL KNOW
HOW THE DATA AROUND HOW THE
UPDATE BEFORE THIS WOMAN WHICH
IS- MATERNAL-RACIAL DISPARITY
THE WITH RESPECT RETURN OR TELL
THE AND- AND- MORBIDITY. AND WE
KNOW THAT HAMMER IT DIDN'T
HYPERTENSION ARE LEADING CAUSES
OF THAT- B. PANDEMIC YEAH THE
CURRENT CONNECTICUT NINETEEN
HAS A WAY TO LOOK AT SOMETHING
PRACTICALLY THAT ARE IN OUR
CARE INCLUDING HELLO HELLO-
LIMITING LOOP LENGTH OF STAY-
THIS. INCREASED ACCESS TO HOME
BLOOD PRESSURE MONITORING
PUBLICLY PROVIDE A SUPPORT FOR
THAT AS WELL AS EARLY
INTERVENTION- I DON'T KNOW IF
WE CAN. CALL HERD IMMUNITY A
GOAL HERE BUT WE CERTAINLY-
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO- REJECT
LOW HANGING FRUIT TO YOU AFFECT
THE PRETTY IMPRESSIVE PANDEMIC
THAT PRE EXISTED CO THAT THANK
YOU FOR MARK. NINE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RAJ EVAN JOHNNY AND I AM THE
CHIEF OF THE PROJECT HIGHLAND
HOSPITAL I THINK YOU HAVE
HOSPITAL IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. 95%
OF THE PATIENTS THEY SERVE HAVE
MEDICAL I AM COMMITTING MY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND SUPPORT A
GOOD CAUSE AMONG THE FIVE.
MATERNAL HEALTH ACCESS BUT
PRESSURE COMPASS DURING
PRENATAL CARE. ALMOST TWENTY
PER OF THE WHO BY HASN'T. HAVE
A DIAGNOSED OF PAPER. IN
PREGNANCY. MAJORITY OF THESE
PATIENTS THANK ACTUAL GAIN HOW
FOR BLOOD PRESSURE. BECAUSE WE
ARE UNABLE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
TRAINING PRESSURE CUFF THE
DURABLE MEDICAL. EQUIPMENT IT'S
A QUESTION ABOUT THE CHICAGO I
DO IN THE BANK. POLITICAL IN MY
ACCESS TO ARTICLE TWO FOR THE
PATIENT TO THE CAR. ASIAN BAG
NOTABLE PROHIBITIVE FOR THEM I
DON'T SEE WANT HAVE TO WAIT. HI
MAKARAND ABOUT QUITE.
ESPECIALLY TO THE IT FROM
MORTALITY. BECAUSE MANY PATIENT
CO RELY YOU NEED UNDERSTOOD BY
PRESSURE DROP HAVE BEEN. TO
HAVE A MY I SEARCHING EITHER SO
OF FUNDS. FOR THE PANDEMIC THE
I THOUGHT ON EDUCATION. NOW
THAT WE ARE INDEPENDENT AND THE
MOST PRIVILEGED CARE AND
BEGGING FUNDING TODAY MONEY BUY
PRESSURE CUTS COULD NOT BE TO.
RECEIVED ABOUT PRESSURE CUFF.
ADDRESSES A- MANY OF THE BY ARE
HOUSE INSECURE AND DON'T HAVE A
HAD. ADDING ANOTHER BARRIER TO
STUDENT PRESSURE TO IN. HANG
PROCEEDS ACT YET AGAIN HIGH
WITH SERVICE I FORGOT TO LEND
OUR SUPPORT TO THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR REQUESTS
FROM THE PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEM. THERE CRITICAL SAFETY
NET HOSPITALS AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KAREN
MEMBERS EHRENSTEIN OF OUR OWN
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP WE APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS FOR YOU TO
ADDRESS INEQUITABLE
REPERCUSSIONS OF THE PANDEMIC
TO CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY THOSE IN.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FIRST TIME
LEAN ON THE TINY ACTED TO BLOOD
PRESSURE EQUIPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THE MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS IS FOUR TIMES HIGHER
FOR THE OTHER POPULATION FOR
INTO FOR INSTANCE THE TYPES OF
HIGH. MEDICAL NEEDS ALL
POSSIBLE APPROACHES TO ADDRESS
THIS AND SHOULD NOT MAKE IT
HARDER TO GET MONITORS WILL
CAPTAIN SOUTH MONITOR BLOOD
PRESSURE BY SWITCHING FROM
PHARMACY TO DEAN DM ME. FURTHER
WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH AND ACT
THE PROPOSAL TO MAKE THE
COMPANY NINETEEN AND INJURED
PROGRAM MORE CONSUMER FRIENDLY.
THE ONLY WAY TO END THE
PANDEMIC FOR ANY OF US IS TO
MAKE SURE THE LATIN ACTS AND
ALL OTHER COMMUNITIES ARE
TESTING TESTING TREATMENT AND
VACCINATION PER CODE NINETEEN.
I WANT TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL
LASTLY FACILITATING CUSTOMS AND
BENEFITS ACCESS TO OUR
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES IS
CRITICAL APPLICATION QUESTION
FOR MEDIC CAL COMPANY NINETEEN
AN INSURED PROGRAM SHOULD MAKE
IT AS WELCOMING AS POSSIBLE FOR
FAMILIES- WITH IMMIGRANTS. IF
MORE FLEXIBLE YOU SEEM TO BE
NEEDED FOR THAT WE AGREE THAT
WE SHOULD SEEK ASSISTANCE FROM
THE PRIDE AND MENSURATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH KNOWN ON BEHALF
MARCH DOWN- THANK YOU MR PEROT
I WAS THE BY PROMISE JUST ONE
OF WAY IN- AND BRADLEY AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE I NEEDED
FOR MEDICAL CARE SERVICES AT
THE STATE WATER PROPOSALS THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
OPERATOR DO NOT CHECKING ONE
MORE TIME. THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE DO HAVE TO FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE.
NINE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KAREN
FARLEY ON THE CALIFORNIA WITH
CONSULTATION REPRESENTING
EIGHTY THREE WORKING AGENCIES.
PRECIADO ALL THE CONVERSATION
TODAY TRAINED IN EQUITY IN
ACCESS. BEFORE WILL HAVE ONE
SUPPORTERS SHE'S SAYING THE NCH
PROPOSAL TO STREAMLINE. AND IN
THE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. AND
IMPROVE THE ACCESS FOR BLOOD
PRESSURE MONITORS ME OF
PHARMACIES CERTAINLY MORE CHIP
MATERNAL MORTALITY IS A VERY
HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE WEEK
AGENCIES. THEY ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE WORK WORKFORCE-
IN RELATION TO THE DISCUSSION
ON MEETINGS. WITH CORPORATE
HELP PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IN
INNOVATIONS AND CURRENTLY
THEY'RE AWAKE- THERE'S A HUGE
WORK FORCE OF WICKS STAFF
TRAINED IN INTERCEDING IN
NUTRITION. WHO ARE ALREADY
WORKING IN SOME INNOVATIVE WAYS
WITH OUTSIDE OF WORK SERVICES
WITH ACTUATE SEASON COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CONVERSATIONS
AROUND. OUR FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE BUT ALSO- BEING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WITHIN
WORK THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT TO GROW DIETITIANS
AND WORKFORCE AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT A NEW ISSUE
THAT WASN'T DISCUSSED IN MORE
DO WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
THERE. BUT ISSUE THIRTEEN-
BOOKS FOR A WEEK AGENCIES AND
EARLY LITERACY AND SUPPORT OF
THE LOOKING INTO HER EARLY
BETTER STUDENTS AND OUR-
LONGSTANDING- SORT OF. EFFORT
ON AGENCIES IN THERE ARE
INCLUDE TO SEE THE ON IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
YOU SPRING ISSUE MY NAME IS DR
AFTER MANSON OPPOSITION GOING
TO COLLEGE AT. WORK THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND I WANTED TO
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF
ACCESSIBLE FOR YOUR COMFORT HM
SEVEN MILLION OF THAT SENTIMENT
THAT IS NOT. A FIT DAY I. NO
HELLO MY QUALITY OF THE
THINKING BUT THEY HAD NEVER AT
THE DATA WITH THEIR THE THAT I
DON'T CAUSE DEATH THE FEES AND
THANK YOU YOU KNOW I AM NEED
HERE HAVE WHAT NOW THE
CHALLENGES NUTRITION HAVE FAITH
IN TRYING TO NAME BUT A COMPLEX
YES- APPLE. I LIKE BOTH THE
ALSO- BUDGET WHAT YOUR LOCATION
I'M NOT BECAUSE AN INCREASE
DIFFICULT- AS MORE AND MORE P.
ARE. I NEED AND- NEED THEM
AVAILABLE BILL VIEW I THINK THE
THING IS THE CAPITAL BETTER
BENEFITS PEACE. AND A DRAFT THE
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY IN
WOULD ABOUT. POPULATION
SPECIFICALLY. OUR WITH THAT ARM
OF ONE OF POPULATION ARE BY
FIFTY POPULATION GIVEN UP IT
HIGHER- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. IN OUR LAST COMMENT
IN THE IS EIGHTY NINE MINING
NINE ELEVEN OPEN- MY NAME IS
MARGIE HUTCHISON I. A MIDWIFE
AT SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL
HOSPITAL AND I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
TO THE- ISSUE OF BLOOD PRESSURE
MACHINE ACCESS. MY COLLEAGUES-
HAVE SPOKEN ELOQUENTLY TO THIS
ISSUE I WOULD JUST. ADD MY
EXPERIENCE AS WELL WHICH IS IN
SPITE OF. MANY MANY HOURS
DEDICATED TO TRYING TO GET OUR
PATIENTS ACCESS TO RELIABLE
ACCESS TO BLOOD PRESSURE
MACHINE AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
ARTICULATED. IT HAS BEEN FOR
NOT AND WE HAVE ALSO. HE HAD TO
RESORT TO RAISING THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FROM PRIVATE DONORS TO-
DELIVER BLOOD PRESSURE MACHINE
TO OUR PATIENTS- AND THE SYSTEM
FOR DME THAT'S BEEN AVAILABLE
FOR SOME OF OUR MEDIC HELP
PATIENT HAS REALLY NOT BEEN
ADEQUATE- THEY'VE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS. IN ACCESS
TO THE MACHINE THROUGH THAT
MECHANISM. AND THE VERY LIMITED
NUMBER OF DME SUPPLIERS ARE NOT
SET UP TO. SERVE OUR
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS WHO
FOR MANY REASONS- FIND A SYSTEM
LIKE THAT CHALLENGING. SO I
WOULD I STRONGLY URGE FOLKS TO
THINK ABOUT MAKING THIS THE
PHARMACY BENEFIT THAT IT NEEDS
TO BE THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WITH THAT I
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENTS AS WELL
AS THE PARTICIPATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS CONCLUDES
TODAY'S HEARING.